yours. Okay. Jeez.
>> There's no way. >> Like he has to do that intentionally,
>> Again, that's not a secret. >> Sure. I I think
that that that's a way that you could read that, but I mean,
you could also just say that like >> like this is Oh, he's
like perfectly doing the thing. He's like Taylor was just like,
"Dude, what the you just spit in my face. Like, here's what Brian
Tyler Cohen said." And he's like, "Well, that's one way you could
think about that." Well, it's raining out here, dude. It's raining
out here. It's actually raining out here right now. Oh, it's
so weird how it's raining like >> Like the Now I'm starting
to understand why they had all those donation things, right?
Everybody does this. These organizations are so slimy. They go
they go they say, "Hey guys, help us raise money, right? Help
help us raise money. Tell your tell your fans to donate to us,
right?" And then they go, "We're grassroots. We've had 5,000
small money donators." And one of those donators is 1630 doing
like 99.99999%
of your funding.
Does he understand yours? Okay. Jeez.
There's no way. Like he has to do that intentionally, right?
He He has to understand, too. Okay. He can get away with this
with the little wiggler on screen. If he ever does this while
he's cammed up, he's so It's so over for him if he ever does
this while he's cammed up. Every time he's canned up, canned
up, cammed up, he's walking a tight rope, I'm telling you. Okay.
Yep. So, big news. Taylor Loren hopped on Destiny's stream today
to go through I don't know. I don't even know what the like how
this was set up or anything, but she's here to defend her journalistic
integrity.
>> That's crazy to me. I literally would have thought this
never would have happened because she's like a giga Hassan simp.
Oh, she should think that this guy is like radioactive right
now, especially with the most recent claims. >> Well, she
actually >> she knows he's radioactive, but I think she
I think she buys a little bit of the uh what would you call like
Hassan Pike or Hasbro? I think she buys some of this stuff where
he he'll tell people that like Destiny is the center of all of
this stuff, right? I think this seems to me like she's buying
into that and she's like, "Okay, I'm going to step into the lion's
end cuz my reporting's solid." Or I would imagine she believes
that. I don't I don't see her stepping onto a stream with Destiny.
It's not like she's unaware of who he is. If she was un or if
she lacked confidence in her
>> Yeah, people probably know who I am. I'm Taylor Loren.
I'm a journalist. I cover the content creator industry and online
influence. I write about
basically online culture and like the influencer economy. So,
a lot of it's like entertainment adjacent. Um, and then I also
cover like sort of the political like politics and business and
culture related to like influencer stuff. >> Gotcha. Gotcha.
Okay. Um, so obviously you've written an article that's blown
up quite >> Wow. I'll point out guys, the intro to this
way nicer than the intro with Glenn uh Glenn Greenwald. Okay.
Remember when Glenn Greenwald was like he made like some like
slightly snarky comment and Taylor like shot back immediately
is already going better. Okay. So I I don't know. I'll give Taylor
a little bit of points here. She obviously considers Destiny
a closer political ally. Okay. >> Was Glenn >> closer
political ally than >> I felt like he extended an olive
branch and she sn >> Okay. Don't Are you Are you trying
to Are you trying to say what I said? Cuz I I agree was a little
snarky. It was a reference. I didn't get the reference. >> but
I think it was I think it was a reference to like our favorite
>> Does not get the reference either.
>> Well, I think he had previously been like, "It's Taylor
Loren, our favorite journalist." And he previously like totally
[__] on her as a journalist like completely right.
>> Oh, I Okay, that went over my head.
>> I think he uh Yeah, I think that came back at him a
little bit. A little bit. Why does Really look like the boy in
the striped pajamas? Cuz we're doing the fast food thing. He's
like a White Castle guy. Roy's White Castle quite a bit on >> Yeah,
I do. I straight up look like I'm from Awitz, bro. >> I
Okay. Internet caused a lot of >> Yeah. You think a lot
of the people in Awitz looked like you really >> just play
the video. >> People some grief. Me included. Okay. Who
are upset? Um and then obviously we got a lot of coverage from
>> You weren't in the program though, right? You weren't
in the program. >> I don't know. Was I in any of the documents?
Who maybe I was one of the dark dark money recipients, you know?
Um no, I wasn't personally, but um I'm on the I would say I'm
on the same team as a lot of those people. So,
um I guess uh I don't know what the joke was there. Am I in the
documents with the dark money?
I guess one of the things that I'm kind of curious about I guess
the first question before we dive into it is one of the questions
that's been posed a lot by well by me and other people is why
not ever publish any of the contracts themselves cuz it feels
like obviously there have been a lot of creators now that have
come out and responded saying that a lot of the claims weren't
true. I think you've replied to them that the replies aren't
necessarily rebuke anything you've said, but I'm curious. Yeah,
why not just publish like parts of >> It's such a good
question. No, it's such a good question. Um, and it's some >> So,
I'm going to say what I assume it is is that they feel like publishing
those contracts would obviously out their sources. They don't
want to out those sources. They don't want to burn their bridges
within these spheres or whatever. They kind of feel like they're
um those sources are, you know, some something like whistleblowers,
right? and and they just don't want to out them. I think they're
willing to say like they're willing to put their reputation on
the line. They say they have the information. Um you can disprove
it if you like or try to or go for a retraction, but we have
all the information. So >> something that
all the time, you know, when I reported for instance on Mr. Beast's
um years ago before all the Mr. Beast stuff came out publicly,
I wrote a big cover story for the New York Times about uh Mr.
Beast's labor practices and these really restrictive NDAs he
was signing people to and some of the other stuff. And you heard
the same thing from like publish the receipts like publish the
receipts like publish the contracts. And this is something like
like I I think people have gotten used to because of social media
and because most of the sort of content that they're consuming
um is maybe through YouTube or through like social media content
where there's this like receipts culture, right? Where which
is great in a lot of ways where people are sort of showing evidence
on screen as they're talking about things. Um so I wish I could
publish like 100% of our reporting material. I feel that way
about all of my stories. Um, but we have sources. So, with the
in order to report this story out and how I originally found
out about the story is actually from people in the program themselves.
So, people in the program reaching out and being like, "Hey,
I don't like I feel weird about this. I think you should write
about it. Like, I'm part of this program, but I want to essentially
like be a whistleblower and and kind of like draw attention to
some things that I, you know, I have problems with in the program."
So, we have to protect these people's identities. And um one
thing that we heard from one of our sources is that uh the the
the the contracts themselves might be watermarked with weird
spacing. Um and so there might be some identifiable things like
that where which is something that's totally common by the way.
Like companies do this all the time. They actually do this with
internal emails as well. So you know whereas we used to get these
things especially in tech journalism you'd like get these emails
like oo internal email from meta like here it is screenshot.
now company. >> Okay, so I'd say that's most of the things
I thought although I'd never heard this idea like it makes sense
the the idea that you could sort of very easily through some
software manipulation make contracts so that they're individually
identifiable, right? I think that's uh I think that makes sense.
It it's all going down to sourcing double spacing or weird spacing,
something like that. >> Yeah, like if you took screenshots
of it or or uploaded the PDF, it might just be obvious who who
it was from. That makes >> Companies have gotten smart
to that. Obviously, if you're a company, you want to know who's
leaking your stuff. And so, they'll put these weird little things
in like an extra space here or something here.
>> I will point out that I don't remember what Destiny's
specific uh complaints were, but a lot of people said like this
is proof that she's lying. Taylor lies. Uh to me, it was always
obvious that Wired stamped their, you know, their reputation
on this article. They said Wired editorial staff viewed the contracts
according to contracts viewed by Wired according to contracts
viewed by Wired is a line that repeats multiple times throughout
the article. So I always thought it was like a little weird for
people to suggest that they might not be able to publish them
or they might not have the information. They might be like making
something up. I don't think a big publication like Wired would
do that. I think it's like yeah just playing fast and loose with
your reputation. So I like how stale stale asking or sorry I
liked stale asking how do you know that? Yeah, that whole line
of argumentation questioning was kind of strange to me, but it
>> That sort of differentiates each each thing uh, you
know, each sort of like person's contract or person's email or
whatever that to make it identifiable. So, we just want to be
really careful and protect our sources. That said, um, many people
at Wired reviewed the contract. We had a lawyer go through it
of course like you know no no one's disputing what's in this
contract and
nobody has been able to disprove what we've reported on. So you
know the for instance these creators that are like well that's
a lie. You know our contract doesn't say that they also have
not published the contract publicly. But what they could do even
if they didn't want to publish the contract publicly is they
could go to Wired and say here's the real contract. It doesn't
say what Taylor's claiming. And of course they haven't done that
because the contracts actually do say you know our story is is
factually correct. So I know that there's lots of misinformation
about the story and I do think people have taken I think a lot
of people also cuz it's paywalt are taking
making a lot of like wild assumptions like based on the story
you know to sort of speculate on a lot of things. But I would
encourage people to actually read the the story because it is
pretty pretty straightforward where we're just
>> uh I I would say based on some of the stuff I've seen,
Taylor's engaged a little bit in that as well. Like when she's
not being restrained by the wired editorial staff or by some
editing team, right, or editorial team. I think she she can engage
in that, too. Nowhere near as bad as someone like Hassan does.
Nowhere near as bad as some of the people on Twitter do. But
I I'd say the the wild speculation from both sides has been pretty
crazy. And I it struck me as strange like a lot of the speculation
from sort sort of some of the liberal content creators I follow
where they've just been like oh this is a clear like lie all
of its lies the article's debunked when to me it's like okay
if the article was debunked you could go to Wired you could get
them to print a retraction. I I haven't seen it happen. Oh we
got two uh Assan is bad. Assan is bad. There you go. >> Reporting
on sort of like what the contract says if that makes sense. But
that's why we can't just come on and not just we by the way our
reporting wasn't just based on the contract right we also had
zoom of recording of an entire zoom call uh where all of this
was discussed we have screen recordings of all of the group chats
where uh all of these influencers were discussing the contract
and discussing the program and discussing the nature of the program.
We have internal emails from the company about the contract and
about the program. We have um negotiation uh we have copies of
receipts of um you know emails and text messages uh during the
negotiation process. So we have a lot more than just the contract
and of course we have the testimony of the people that are in
the program themselves who have spoken to us. So we have a lot
of reporting. Uh but yeah we unfortunately that's how a lot of
journalistic institutions are are where we we are not like operating
by the same principles as I think like the the way the rest of
the internet does. But I wish we could because I totally understand
people wanting to see the contract and that's why I've encouraged
these creators to share the contract. I think it would just it
would dispel a lot of misinformation on their part on on everything.
>> Gotcha. That's uh that's awesome. Just a little shot
there at the end at like everybody who's been criticizing her,
right? Where it's like
uh ah you know we have to operate at different standards than
the rest of the internet. I feel like that's a shot at a couple
people who've been taking uh stabs at her. I don't even know
if she's familiar with Destiny's commentary on it. I'm not 100%
sure other than I heard him basically disparage Taylor, but in
criticizing Taylor Lorenz's actions in the article, Hutch's biggest
problem was the by line, but that's written by the headline writer.
Wired should be criticized more than Taylor if they're going to
criticize anyone. So, I don't Has that been cleared up? Does
that get cleared up in this interview? Cuz another question I
really want to ask Taylor is did you write the title or the by
line? Because the by line is where like basically all of people's
anger comes from. And I don't know that she would have written
that. Uh it's unusual that an author would write the title or
by line for a piece in a major
>> Okay. So here are a few questions. So the first question
is if you had to guess, how many of these contracts do you think
you saw or got to read >> A few. Yeah, a few. I mean there's
only So there's a few tiers of the program, right? So and we
talk about this. So there's and we have contracts for multiple
tiers. So most of our stories is focused around the the highest
tier paid, you know, version. >> Yeah. The 8,000 a month,
whatever one. >> Yeah. But we've seen all of the we've
seen all the contracts, you know, for the different tiers um
and compared them as well. >> Is it So,
uh I'm I'm going to try to let this flow a little better, but
I do want to keep pausing and just saying stuff like um right
here if So, it's possible they have outof-date contracts or something,
right? Taylor and Wired reached out for comment from from uh
Chorus and all the creators involved. If they had out-of-date
contracts,
why not just provide the updated contracts? Why not just provide
a comment saying, "Here's actually we updated this. We noticed
some feedback. We updated it." Right? That's what seems strange
to me is the the inherent like attacking back at her instead
of saying, "Oh, here's how we updated the contracts and take
a look and look, we're not doing anything like that, right?"
Is it not trivial to just like open up two contracts and look
at them side by side or overlay them to see if there's like weird
spacing or watermarking that happens? So there are there are
slight there are slight uh there are slight differences and that's
and and also there's identifying info in some of them. So yeah
that is what sort of originally made us a little bit >> cuz
for the identifying info or for slight differences. So often
times for journalistic outlets rather than showing you an actual
thing they'll show you like a reconstruction. So this is really
common when people are reporting on text messages for instance
you're not actually seeing a picture or a screenshot but they
can reconstruct the text in a program and then show you like
what it would look like. Yeah. So, I guess I feel like a lot
of things that would be put that would be put to bed for um people's
questions about some of the claims in the story is like just
so he could do that or sorry, you could do that, but what if
they were swapping words? What if they were swapping like um
like what if they were using, you know, semantically similar
but different language in some of them? Like that that should
be actually trivially easy easy to do with something like chat
GBT, right? So, you could you could have that. Why would you
want the exact language of the contracts? possibly isn't like
wired reading them and then you know summarizing them. Isn't
that as a major publication? Shouldn't we be trusting that institution
that's been trusted for a lot of other reporting the exact language
can be super important? Yeah, but I assume you second that you
get a lawyer in to tell you, right? Like you you get a lawyer
in to say this is like the exact thing. You would look at all
of them and you say this is the exact meaning of this. I assume
>> just a reproduction basically of some of >> I
would love to do that. I I actually have advocated this for a
long time and it's so funny because I this was something that
people got really mad at me for previously when I said like I
had a previous story about text messages and I was saying why
don't we just >> write the text messages and we do in the
story right we do reproduce the text messages in the sense that
we're quoting directly from the text messages in our story um
so there is that but I I agree I think it would be great unfortunately
we're not able to do that for whatever you know this this is
ultimately
>> judgement Um, there's reasons why they don't show source
material, but I I agree. I would love that. I think for honestly
the burden of proof is on
>> Oh, dude. I I'm just I'm going to people are going to
see, but this is actually the way it goes with it's going to
go in all of these I think all of the questions here. It's going
to be I would love to do that, but you got to go to the wired
editorial staff. I don't get to make that call. That is a call
that I think almost anybody familiar with journalism would know
is not made by her. Right. It is not it's not made by her and
and trying to throw her or burn her reput throw her under the
bus or burn her for the decisions of the editorial staff is crazy
>> on the content creators like they have not been able
to provide a single copy of any contract that refutes our reporting
but yeah I mean I'm all for a transparency. I don't know if you
remember my interview with >> I well just a real quick
thing. So, I feel like in terms of burden of proof, um, assuming
that there's a standard NDA clause on any of these, you would
be you're not going to get in trouble personally if you publish
any of these contracts, but the contract creator themselves would
probably have to be released from an NDA if they signed a contract.
So, they would >> So, couldn't Chorus just like Chorus
says they're that Wired's lying. Why wouldn't Chorus release
one of these contract creators from their NDA to show that Chorus
that Wired is lying or Taylor is lying? In either case, >> Brian
Tyler Cohen is in charge of it. like Brian Tyler Cohen and these
other creators, some of them are all stakeholders in Chorus.
So they're they don't they you know and they continue to say
that this is a public program. So you know they're they're free
if they feel that our that we are not representing the contracts
correctly, put them online and let people decide. But so far
they have not been able to to disprove that. >> Would that
be the standard though that like if anybody writes a story or
makes a claim about a particular company's contract then that
company is always forced to publish their contract to disprove?
could just reach out. No, they could just reach out to Wired
and say, "Hey, you guys misrepresented this XYZ, you know, and
Wired H Wired obviously has the contracts, right? So, they don't
have to do it publicly. They can do it behind the scenes, but
they haven't done that either. >> If you were publishing
fake contracts, if Wired was publishing fake contracts and Chorus
reaches out and says, "Here's the real contracts. Whatever you
have is a fabrication.
Chorus, if if Wired's not willing to work with Chorus, Chorus
will have a real slander, liable, defamation lawsuit. Not sure.
I think liable in this case, but they would have a real lawsuit
on their hands, right? They could actually sue. But I have not
seen any evidence yet whatsoever
that Chorus or any of the creators involved have reached out
to Wired and said this is a >> And so I think that's the
thing is that they have just been unable to refute any of the
facts of our story. And I understand like I you know it's frustrating
for them but the few you know the the the few the bits of information
that have come out rather um have confirmed our reporting but
yeah I mean I if they aren't going to do it
>> uh I'll just remind you guys that Destiny essentially
thinks uh there are two neutral claims and all the rest of every
other factual claim in this article is bad according to Destiny
and he says
uh eight eight are false. 1 2 3 4 five are irrelevant and one
is true. So, you'd think he's got a lot of meat to work with
here to show that Taylor's just lying, right? He's shown that
these are false apparently on his stream >> privately.
And they aren't going to do it publicly.
I don't know what else to tell them. But >> like when you
say they aren't going to do it publicly, I feel like a lot of
creators have come out and have like there have been several
claims I think that have been explicitly refuted by Brian Tyler
Cohen, by David Pacman. >> Well, they can refute them,
but they have no proof to refute. So they can they can go online
every day and say that the sky is purple, you know, or whatever
they want to say, >> but we deal in facts here and so we
are dealing with a fact with the facts of our reporting and the
facts of our source material. And so >> David Pacman can
make a video every day saying that this article is debunked and
it's all slander, but unless he shows why the specific contract
language referenced is wrong,
uh he he's just Yeah. He's uh wasting air. Okay. He's wasting
oxygen. if they provide counter, you know, if they if they can
debunk something or they could say, "Hey, that's not what this
says. Here's what it says." Of course, is happy to look at that,
but I've not been able to do that. >> Let's say that I
say that um you wrote, I don't know if you're formerly hired
by Wired or if you do freelance, but like if I were to make the
claim, oh, Taylor has a contract with Wired and they have a clause
saying that anytime Taylor publishes, she has to use the word
and 47 times in her.
>> Yeah. So, the way this would go based on what Taylor's
saying, based on standard like uh journalistic
practices is you would say as the company who's being uh you
know you say maligned you would go and you'd say actually our
contracts have never said that here's what our contracts do say
if you want to share with us those contracts we'll point out
to you exactly where this is being do like where it's being doed
and this is a lie and somebody is slandering us so it's either
you or it's the person providing it to you right and I've seen
no evidence that Wired is sorry that Chorus has attempted to
do that yet. Yeah. So, it's weird that Dusty's gonna say, "Well,
I could just make up a claim." And it's like, "Yeah, but then
I could go and go to that editorial staff wherever you publish
that and say, "That's a fabricated claim. Here's my evidence
to show what the truth is, and unless you can prove otherwise,
like, now I've informed you of what the truth is. Uh, please
retract or I'm going to sue you." That's the steps you take,
>> Uh, story. Now, you need to disprove that. How would
you even disprove that claim? Would you just have to publish
your entire employment contract? Like, how would you disprove
the claim that there's not a secrecy clause or disprove a claim
that there's not like content? um direction given. >> I'm
not a step ahead. I'm not, just to be clear, I'm not a step ahead.
Every single person who's being honest, I don't even know that
much about journalism. Every single person who's being honest
understands certain things about journalism. If you've been following
like political stories on the internet for any amount of time,
right? Like this is this is just obvious to me. It's what I said
from the very beginning when I first looked at this stuff, it's
been my like the same thing I've been repeating almost the entire
time given by the company. I don't even know how you would begin
to disprove that claim beyond like publishing their contract.
>> What are what are you talking about? Wired has lawyers.
They have people that reviewed the contract and if these content
creators want to dispute anything in our story, they can reach
out and they can say, "Hey, here's the proof that shows >> uh
please retype this in English. I'll answer whatever that question
is." >> But so far, they have not provided any proof that
shows that our reporting is false. So I welcome them reaching
out and showing proof that our reporting is false, but they have
not done that. They have not done that publicly and they have
not done that directly in the sense that they have not they they
have not proven anything false. And so I just don't know what
to tell these people other than this is months of reporting.
We have in addition to the contract all of these other documents
that back up the facts of the contract and that's why ultimately
there are no corrections on the story.
Now, is there a lot of false stuff around the story where that
people have taken our story and sort of speculated on things?
Certainly. Uh, and I hope that we can get into sort of debunking
some of that. But in terms of the facts of the story, the facts
of the >> Oh, I hope we can get into debunking that. She
shows up and she's like, I want to help you guys, okay? I want
to help David Pacman, Destiny, Brian Tyler. I want to help you
guys debunk some of the falsehoods that are out there.
that is a bit of a power move. remain. And I think you'll you'll
note too uh I don't know if you go by Destiny or Stephen on on
stream.
Okay. Sorry. You know, one thing that that they've attempted
to do uh you know, since this has come out, a bunch of nonsense,
right? Of course, they're going to make it all like they're going
to start conspiracy theories about me and stuff, but one thing
that they've done repeatedly is is make this claim, well, Chorus
is public. Chorus is public. So, we've always been able to talk
about Chorus. Here's the website. Here's whatever. No one is
disputing that, right? Chorus, I myself have written about chorus
publicly before. There's an entire New York Times story by Ken
Benzinger about chorus that's public. So, no one's disputing
that chorus is public. The unreported part and the stuff that
our our story focuses on is this funding system. And so, that
was the non-public part. And I think that that is something to
focus on. I think look, if you want to debate the ethics of dark
money, there there is a debate around that. Some liberals feel
that we should use dark money. Some liberals argue against it
like that. You know that is a debate. But I think what most people
would agree on if you ask the public and certainly this is what
I think like you know any sort of ethical expert would would
say as well is that disclosure is really important and if you
are take if you are presenting yourself as a journalist online
which several of these content creators are presenting themselves
as news sources or >> Hold on. Hold on. >> Couple
different things. Number one, uh, Apac is a more right-wing group
and in the US are very, very liberal. So, there are Jews who
support Apac who vote in the United States. But look at evangelical
Christian support of Apac and of Israel. That doesn't even seem
to >> okay. So, what did he what he saying? >> 48
hours took the Wired story and expanded it with even more outrageous
clips. Well, that clip goes on suggesting that it's APAC or IPAC.
I I don't even know how it's pronounced. Apac. IPAC >> that
is funding this show or >> Oh, sorry. I thought it was
clear he knew. Wait, does he actually talk about the pronunciation
here? I was like, oh, it's he's said it like eight times now.
>> He mentioned here. It's an important >> If you
if you click the original one, I'm sorry. Click the original
um tweet. >> What's quote? Yeah, click that. Your ADHD
brain needs the smaller clip below it. Keep scrolling down. Keep
scrolling there. Click that one. >> Twitter video, folks.
Twitter video. >> Apac is a more right-wing group and in
the US are very, very liberal. So, yeah, there are
who vote in the United States. >> But look at evangelical
Christian support of Apac and of Israel. That doesn't even seem
to be mentioned here. It's an important factor. >> But
then we get to the bigger picture. You can recognize that this
is playing on longtime anti-semitic tropes and still support
boycotting Israel, for example, and the reflexive reaction I
saw from many on the left to say this can't be anti-semitic
because they felt as though it would in some way invalidate their
support of boycotting Israel or their opposition to Benjamin
Netanyahu.
Separate the two things. You can be an opponent of Benjamin Netanyahu
and believe that Ilan Omar here is knowingly or unknowingly playing
up anti-Semitic tropes. You can be for or against boycotting
Israel or Israeli companies or whatever and still recognize that
it's a really bad idea to even go near approximating these anti-semitic
tropes. It's bad for Democrats. It's bad for the progressive
movement. It's bad for those who want reform in Israel. That's
okay. You don't have to feel as though merely admitting that
this was a mistake that it was either ignorant or malicious and
both are problematic and that doesn't change the validity of
your perspective on the Israeli Palestinian conflict or what
policy should be towards Israel. And I was concerned before the
election that exactly this type of nonsense would start flying
after the midterms and it has and it's only doing damage to the
progressive movement.
Never mind. It never went on to I don't know what clip I watched.
Never mind. >> I'm just going to say total total ADHD victory.
Okay. First 20 seconds of that clip were the only things that
were relevant and I I switched over and that was all that
minute 26 pack. Okay. >> Okay. Fair enough. Fair enough.
Okay. All right. We're back to the Taylor Loren's Destiny interview.
All right. So, I'm expecting we got Destiny showing that there's
a whole bunch of falsehoods in the article. I would love I would
love Destiny to point out some of these falsehoods to her, right?
We remember a couple of these, right? Uh mentions multiple times
the program is secretive and mandates extensive secrecy about
payments disclo payment disclosure. One, Chorus seems to be openly
and publicly spoken about both on the website itself and by several
content creators. I'm not sure what is supposed to be secretive
that they're being paid. BTC disagrees with this as well in his
Twitter video. Uh that's not disproving something. Um, yeah.
My dad said that this is wrong. I don't know. This is the work
we're doing nowadays. Is it? Okay. All right. You know what?
You know what? Okay. Quick pallet cleanser, guys. Quick pallet
cleanser. >> Okay. Quick palette cleanser. >> Understand
yours. Okay. Jesus Christ. My [__] voice. Yours is
a >> Why? Why' you do that's supposed to be >> I'm
going to keep that. I'm going to keep that. I'm going to keep
that around. That's uh That was a unique one. Okay. That wasn't
just like a little That was a pretty crazy one. All right. All
right, we're back to our Taylor Loren's interview with Destiny.
Very excited. Taylor's doing very well so far, although she's
mostly just yapping and Destiny's kind of like listening. He's
He knows there's a powerful white woman speaking. He's sitting
his white app down and listening. Okay, related. Oh, we're not
doing more. No. Okay, one more. One last one related meme to
the to the voice crack for Queen. We're being told
>> yours. Okay. Jesus Christ. >> I can see it. I
could see the vision as soon as I saw as soon as I heard it.
I can see the vision. Okay,
>> Kathy won. Kathy won. Kathy won. Oh my goodness. Kathy
won. Holy [__]
Amazing stuff. Amazing stuff. All right.
Jesus. H I We'll We'll keep watching. Okay, we're we're going
to keep watching. Apparently, we're big Taylor Loren supporters
now. Okay. So, we need we need Taylor to pull out a W here. Okay.
>> I'm on the side of women. true. >> These content
creators want to dispute anything in our story, >> they
can reach out and they can say, "Hey, here's the proof that shows
that this is false." >> But so far, they have not provided
any
>> I just want to say Taylor is totally aware that a bunch
of them have said they've provided proof and she's explicitly,
as far as I can tell, trying to bake Destiny into saying, "Well,
here's some proof they gave." cuz every like I'm saying every
single piece of proof proof proof proof has just been like li
like they're basically saying like I'm disproving what you said
and they know explicitly they're not or
I I feel like that's how it looks to me. >> Proof that
shows that our reporting is false. So I welcome them reaching
out and showing proof that our reporting is false. But they have
not done that. They have not done that publicly and they have
not done that directly in the sense that they have not they they
have not proven anything false. And so I just don't know what
to tell these people other than this is months of reporting.
We have in addition to the contract all of these other documents
that back up the facts of the contract and that's why ultimately
there are no corrections on the story. Now is there a lot of
false stuff around the story where that people have taken our
story and sort of speculated on things? Certainly. Uh, and I
hope that we can get into sort of debunking some of that. But
in terms of the facts of the story, the facts of the story remain.
And I think you'll you'll note too, uh, I don't know if you can
go by Destiny or Stephen on on stream, but
>> okay, sorry. Um, you know, one thing that that they've
attempted to do uh, you know, since this has come out, a bunch
of nonsense, right? Of course, they're going to make it all like
they're going to start conspiracy theories about me and stuff,
but one thing that they've done repeatedly is is make this claim,
well, Chorus is public. Chorus is public. So we've always been
able to talk about chorus. Here's the website. Here's whatever.
No one is disputing that, right? Chorus, I myself have written
about chorus publicly before. There's an entire New York Times
story by Ken Benzinger about chorus that's public. So no one's
disputing that chorus is public. The unreported part and the
stuff that our our story focuses on is this funding system. And
so that was the nonpublic part. And I think that that is something
to focus on. I think look if you want to debate the ethics of
dark money there there is a debate around that. Some liberals
feel that we should use dark money. Some liberals argue against
it like that, you know, that is a debate. But I think what most
people would agree on if you ask the public and certainly this
is what I think like you know any sort of ethical expert would
would say as well is that disclosure is really important and
if you are take if you are presenting yourself as a journalist
online which several of these content creators are presenting
themselves as news sources or journalists that you should be
public about being part of a politically driven
funding program because that's just valuable for your audience.
audience to know just the way that >> No, it's not politically
dri It's It's policy driven. It's policy driven. Doesn't that
make everything different? Yeah, I know all of these people do
like the exact electioneering I'd want to support, but you know,
it's policy >> But, you know, Stephen, if you were taking
tens of thousands of dollars from some, I don't know, political
effort or something like even if you say, "Look, they never gave
us >> uh hold on. I I like this question. We we talked
about it a little bit. Are chorus streamers actually presenting
themselves as journalists?" I would say in a lot of cases a lot
of a lot of streamers, a lot of content creators do present themselves
as journalists without actually trying. It's like John Stewart
when he argues about politics, right? And he goes, "Well, I'm
a comedian. I don't have the same, you know, boundaries." But
in in almost all cases, John Stewart would act like a journalist,
right? And I think eventually once enough people are watching
you, I think you start to become like uh sort of imbued or you
you gain these like obligations to follow some ethical guideline,
right? If you're a massive creator who has a bigger following
than actual journalists, I think you suddenly do get you you
do gain the obligation to be truthful. You gain the obligation
to follow some ethical guideline. >> Yeah. And if if nothing
that you're doing is funny, at some point you're going to have
to admit you're not a comedian. I am just laring as a journalist.
That wasn't at you. >> Oh, I know. I know. Sorry. I was
reading Kilo's point. He's agreeing with us. Yeah. Um John Stewart,
of course, walking the line. He gets to be both funny and informative.
I don't think you Sorry, I'm going to read this on stream so
I'm not leaving out the audio only viewers. Okay. I don't think
you decide when you're not doing journalism. If you're talking
about news and you intend to report information accurately, you
are participating in some form of journalism. Yeah, exactly.
And as you gain like a bigger following, I think you start to
actually like you you do have some there is some like moral
in my opinion like moral requirement that becomes like obligation
>> relevant. Yeah. Obligation moral obligation that becomes
that like to be truthful or attempt to be truthful.
Yeah. Anyway,
>> I'd say, and by the way, I just say that our favorite
guy, Hassan, Hassan is bad. He he basically gives us like this
is what proves it to me is almost everybody when Hassan misreports
that bombing of the hospital, right? I think almost everybody
looks at that and goes, "Yeah, that's really gross. Like you're
you're talking to so many people. You're like this popular. You
probably get about as many concurrents as like probably more
concurrence than most local news stations, right? Or almost as
many as like big city local news stations, right? Like you you
obviously have some requirement to be truthful in my opinion.
Anyway,
>> Uh let's see here. Warp thing donated to Jtock does
the Hassan laugh.
There we go. >> Points. I don't have to disclose. You're
right. You don't have to disclose legally. There's no legal reason
that you have to disclose. But, you know, is it is it good for
transparency to have this sort of uh, you know, non-public money
like flowing around our political media environment? I don't
think it is. And so, that is how some of these content creators
felt as well.
>> If none of those content creators actually base their
their content on anything Chorus is doing, what is the downside
of of the funding of disclosing the funding? It literally doesn't
matter, right? Why would you not want to talk about it? Why would
you not say you're getting money from Chorus? it doesn't affect
any of your content. Why would it be a big deal if you disclose
that you're getting the money? I don't >> And that is part
of why they reached out to us is because they they didn't feel
comfortable. They signed the contract, but they they didn't feel
comfortable with certain things within it. And so anyway, that's
and I'm very surprised, by the way, total side note, that they
didn't preempt my story and just do some puff piece about we're
excited to announce some funding program because it would have
completely thwarted our story, but they didn't do that. I don't
know why. >> Sure. So, um I mean there's a separate discussion
to be had about disclosure. I think my biggest issue is I I feel
like um selective disclosure is is worse than no disclosure.
As in if only some people >> selective disclosure. Okay.
Actually, selective disclosure is worse than no disclosure. So,
if if Democrats do this and Republicans don't, it's worse. Why?
I thought this didn't affect their content. Why is it worse?
Are forced to disclose than and others aren't. I I think that's
not good. So, I think I feel like the push should be towards
changing the the legal framework around what the reporting requirements
are. Otherwise, you're just like basically playing from behind
because obviously like conservatives or other movements doing
this, but >> 100%. Yeah, of course. >> Circling back
on the um I guess I a couple questions just to to nail down something.
So, the first thing is you said nobody from Chorus or from the
1630 fund or anybody associated with this. Nobody has reached
out to you or Wire personally to have a conversation. >> They've
reached out Oh, not to me personally. They've reached out to
they've reached out to Wired, but they've been unable to provide
any facts that dispute our store. They've been unable to provide
any evidence that disputes the fact of our story, but they've
certainly responded. We incorporated their request for comment.
We I tried to reach them for weeks, right? And so, as soon as
we published the story, they gave us comment finally and we incorporated
that comment into the story, which is obviously something we
would always want to do. We tried to do that before publication.
And then for the the second part of that, so before this story
went live, you're saying that >> I would love to see like
some of these creators engage with the idea that like >> this
this story wasn't like sprung out. It it wasn't like, oh, I'm
I'm
surprise.
Here's a slanderous piece. That's like not what happened at all.
And Taylor's actually been reporting on Chorus for a while. When
she says, hey, we have like a story we're going to run like this.
She didn't pop out of the bushes.
Why? Why are you acting like this was like so shocking? She literally
reached out for comment. Why didn't you comment and give Why
did they have to wait until after until you saw how it was received
to get any comment at all? >> Provided like full copies
of the contracts to Wired's I guess legal team in order for them
to go through to make sure that the claims and the articles comped
with what they saw in the >> Of course. Yes. Of course.
>> Okay. the so I guess like just I guess like a couple
clauses because some me some people have released like parts
of the contracts publicly that they've gone over and maybe >> I
saw like some on Instagram or some video a girl >> Tik
Tok and reals and everything else. Yeah. So obviously I I'm not
privy to the entire thing at this point. Um so I can't speak
to any particular clauses. So I'm curious if there are other
things that you saw because there were some things that just
didn't seem to be based on the things that I was reading. One
of the big claims I think that was made in the article is the
idea that you had to funnel all of your independent contacts
through chorus if you're going to arrange for like a meeting.
>> You had to loop them in. So you have to loop them in.
So I think one thing that's interesting in that video that that
girl made sort of disproving thing. Number one, the email that
she shows where she's reaching out to someone directly is from
June 2nd >> before the program even began. So >> that's
all of Alli's all of Alli's proof is from before the program
existed, which is so goofy. >> It doesn't disprove anything.
Now you don't like it. According to the contract, you were supposed
to use Chorus Newsroom to book engagements. Chorus Newsroom is
this like internal tool or whatever. >> That doesn't that
that just means that you're supposed to use that for booking
things with lawmakers. You basically you just they want you to
loop them in on things. That doesn't mean that they're um that
they have like approval or disapproval or whatever. It just means
that you're looping them in. And >> so why not? Because
I'm curious because when I because I've signed a lot of these
contracts. Uh my background is in pro gaming and I've signed
a lot of influencer contracts. I've seen a lot of contracts.
The language in the article was that creators in the program
must funnel all bookings with lawmakers and political leaders
through chorus. That doesn't sound like looped in. That sounds
like you're basically handing over your political >> I'm
guessing. So, what I'm guessing is is when you go to do anything,
okay, this is what it probably looks like when you go to book
through Chorus, you go, you select a contact, you're getting
introduced to like this politician, you select that contact,
you say, "Here's the time I'm meeting with them at, right? It's
a whole booking software." I'm guessing what they mean by funnel
is that if you're going to talk to a politician, you you should
actually be going, you're agreeing to go use the software, go
create a contact for them, go and set up the meeting through
Chorus so that it goes through the software so that the software
is aware and they can use that going further, right? That's that's
what funnel funneling contacts through means.
Could have been bad wording. I don't even think it's like particularly
bad wording. I just see like I think I proposed this as obvious
from the language when it came out. I said, I think you have
to enter it into their software. I think this is obviously software.
I think you have to enter it into the software. I talked about
CRM. We talked about Salesforce, right? It was pretty clear from
the >> Is this kind of like >> pretty clear to me?
Maybe. >> Would you compare this to how >> or No,
>> dude. Oh, you just cut out totally. You would you I
heard. Would you compare this to And then you cut out. >> Oh,
okay. Would you compare this to like how some iPhones like they
have like what is it the lightning charger? basically buying
an iPhone, they they basically like rope you into also having
to use their charger to sort of just uh >> Yeah, sure.
>> get you on multiple avenues. They're selling you one
product and all of a sudden now you're on two products. >> It's
like that, but it's um it is like that, but it's um
they're trying to force you to use >> normalizing it. >> Well,
that's what they're trying to do. They get they get what they
get out of the software is that you put the contact for that
that uh politician in. That's what they get. Uh, internet ray
was talking about Taylor, not Cherry, by the way. He knows he
can't talk about Cherry like that. Just so you're clear as easy.
>> wait. So, this this software, what is it called again?
Newsroom. >> Newsroom. Chorus newsroom.
>> Chorus newsroom. Okay. So, that's not going to be like
publicly accessible. It's literally just for them. >> Yeah.
It's not publicly accessible. It's for chorus creators and themselves,
>> anything like that. >> It's like they're what
they're trying to do is make it so that they build up a rolodex
of politicians,
>> right? And you do have to funnel those contacts, I believe,
through this chorus newsroom and saying, "You agree to do that.
You also agree to do bookings through this and like book and
talk to these people, right? It's trying to build up that network
effect. They're they're trying to build like a group of people
who all talk >> network or it can't just be network. It
has to be their information grabbing so much more than just network."
Like that Ice Poseidon thing, you know, how he made an app for
the game. He's like, "Haha, now I have all of your guys'
>> yeah, but I don't think they close to that. I think
they want the basically the way you maintain contact with these
people with these politicians. I think they want like a ton of
this is just figuring out, you know, actually instead of just
a contact at like Minnesota gov whatever, right? Like for some
senator, let's say, you actually have their PR director. You
get their PR director for for like that politician, you attach
that name and suddenly you are way closer to actually talking
to that politician, right? It's minimizing the amount of contacts
you need to do to get in contact with a politician >> and
they're they're going to have that contact and they might even
be able to hide that or keep it to themselves as a >> Wait,
that I'm sorry, but that just doesn't make sense to me cuz you
would get that contact information if you're going to have a
meeting with them, right? getting them to sign up to a a program
to have a chat inside of like software
that's like added contact information that you wouldn't have
gotten like otherwise.
>> I don't know if that is actually something they do.
I don't know if you add the contact if they they have some ability
to work within that newsroom as well. I don't know like I I I
don't know if that's there or not. So they might just be adding
the contacts and they add the contact information that they couldn't
have gotten otherwise, but it is contact information to actually
talk to this politician, right? Or it's it's even saying this
politician has talked to just real quick. This is Yeah. >> So
I'm just going to finish this idea that they they want politicians
who are willing to politicians or policy experts who are willing
to collaborate with smaller creators, right? If they're willing
to collaborate with one smaller creator, so by adding them, you
know that they've collaborated once, you think they might collaborate
again. So it's also building a network of people who will talk.
>> Yeah. I think most people who sign up to Zoom, they
use a basic email that they would have contacted with the person
otherwise. So you're not getting new information from that email.
You're not getting their name for the first time. This would
have to get other information for it to be like a concern in
this way. >> So I don't I don't think it's that it's it's
not like a concern. It's not even necessarily bad. They're just
trying to find people who are actively willing to collaborate
and get their names in a specific system meant for collaborating,
right? So, you could go get these emails from some other source,
but you don't know that that's what they're for. You don't know
that if you email that email, you'll actually get an email back,
right? Or you you don't even know that they'll talk to you. You
might just be sending messages out into the void. So, you get
a contact where you can actually talk to them, where you can
actually set stuff up with them, and you have confirmation. you've
already filtered them down to being somebody who's willing to
collaborate with other people who do the same thing. So, you've
validated that. Validated contacts are worth a thousand times
validated leads or validated like uh sales contacts are worth
a thousand times more than an >> calls those those um those
lists that people will get. >> Yeah, I understand. >> Yeah.
Uh free pie. Yeah. Hot leads versus cold leads. Yeah, exactly.
But I get what you're saying that like if they maybe that is
something they try to do is like set them up on that software.
Uh, I do believe they have I believe the requirement the funneling
is for the contact info. I believe that's what it means, guys.
Uh, we'll see if Taylor says anything else. She can expand here,
too. I think she will expand. So, uh, I think we add I I get
what you're saying, though, that you would expect um like that
they have something else. There's some other benefit there. >> It
grabs IP. It grabs
um like I I don't know what else it would grab besides IP.
>> Yeah. I so I think when you only have 86 creators, I
don't think there's any way to get enough data out of that that
you'd really build meaningful analytics. Like maybe over time
you could start building up some kind of but I don't know I don't
know why it would be I I can't see the I I can't see it. Maybe
there would be but I get what you're saying that in a lot of
cases that would be good but this seems to be if there I guess
they'd be building it up through other ways too. Maybe there
could be something there but I'm not to I'm not totally sure.
They're probably saving all that info all the people who log
in and stuff but it' be >> Yeah. I don't know. I don't
know. It also depend on if it's bespoke software, like if they
wrote it themselves or if they're just reusing like Salesforce
or
>> My my head is just like in a movie. Okay. I've been
watching way too many movies because I'm sitting here thinking,
"Oh, if you're a small content creator and you talk to a politician,
have them log into our software. Make sure they log into our
software." I'm like, "Okay, what? Why?" I just I jumped to like
the worst conclusion. >> Yeah. So I don't think that's
even a requirement, the login requirement for the politician.
They might that could be something you build in, but I don't
think that's like an element there. >> Because political
leaders through chorus. That doesn't sound like looped in. That
sounds like you're basically handing over your political contacts
to um chorus for them to >> you are hand you are handing
over your contacts and that's what I think some creators were
concerned about. >> Well, you're also not just handing
them over, but that like they have to then set up all of the
meetings and arrangements. Like if you're funneling something
through somebody, you're not >> funneling them through
the chorus
>> Through through Chorus Newsroom, right? You're doing
it through their systems.
>> Yeah. I >> And I >> Sorry. I'm just like
I don't think any of this is confusing. I >> just want
to state we we don't, you know, we're not >> obviously
it is a little confusing. I get that. So I think I have the advantage
and a lot of people in chat actually have the advantage of having
used sales software before. sales software very explicit like
terms terminology like a flow that goes through it that we can
all kind of identify that they're using here and when they talked
about funnels that was explicitly why what I thought funneling
through I'm like oh a salesunnel you're talking I it all made
sense to me right um if you're unaware of this software I think
I could see it not making sense to you if you've never used the
software or seen this software before >> making
good point >> what's that >> we have to do like facial
recognition into the software so that they can map that onto
the deep fakes that they make on these people. >> A uh
we don't even need we don't even need guys. Epstein can Epstein
can go now. Let him let him go. Let him retire wherever he's
going. Okay, we'll say he died. We don't even need him anymore.
We could just make these guys kids. We don't even need them in
the room. Okay, we'll just do deep fake [__] All
right, it's it's over for them. >> Anyone from interview?
>> Yeah, blackmail angle anyone. But I think this this
became ability to based on the article, right? They could block
you from doing it. >> We don't we don't know if they would
or wouldn't do that, but but I think the issue that >> Yeah,
the that's he's so close. They they have the ability to the contract
provisions are there. I believe the contract provisions are there
and I think this is to avoid the electioneering hit like the
the idea that you would be electioneering with this money >> that
creators expressed to >> trying to clarif
but they could they if you have to funnel it through them it
seems to imply that they could block you from doing some content
if you independently organized it. No, >> I mean I I don't
know their their systems and I >> I think that is the case
based on what we saw, right? I thought so. Hold on. Politicians
loop chorus in on must funnel all bookings with lawmakers and
political leaders through chorus. So this is through chorus.
This should say chorus newsroom to be ultra clear. This should
say chorus newsroom to make it clear that it's going into the
software. Okay. So to loop any uh in on any independently organized
engagements with government officials or political leaders. I
do think that this was what we saw, right? Can I see can somebody
link me the alley picture again? I know I've had it from a couple
different
but I kind of need this alley picture like out of nowhere here.
Kind of need it. Kind of need it. Okay, hold on. I've got the
video. No, I don't. Damn it. If anybody can Yeah, get me the
exact language here. I've had it a couple times, but we'll continue.
>> I don't know if they they would do that. I don't know.
We don't you know, we didn't talk to anybody that had that that
had that problem. But the the problem that they're the reason
I think you're I think you're missing why creators had a problem
with that clause and creators that we spoke to had a problem
with that clause, Stephen, >> because
there's increasingly this problem really since the Democrats
lost, but even through the election last year where um there's
these sort of middleman type organizations that hoover up a lot
of contact details and kind of insert themselves as middleman
and get in between creators establishing these more direct uh
relationships with these lawmakers offices. And so I think some
creators bristled given what had previously happened. What previously
happened with chorus um one time where they did this event uh
I can't remember it was for some Trump address in Congress or
something. They had a bunch of creators come the creators created
the content and then and then creators felt like well chorus
is kind of taking credit for this content cuz they helped facilitate
part of it but I really want credit for the content and so creators
at least in in terms of like that funneling the booking stuff.
I think creators felt like I don't want to have to use chorus
newsroom for booking. I don't want to have to share information
with the chorus network. Like I just want to maintain, you know,
my own relationships and I want to have this one-on-one relationship
with the lawmaker and now I have to be part of this bigger you
know this bigger ecosystem where suddenly for instance uh a smaller
creator gets a big interview. I think their fear at least what
they told us is like well what if some other bigger person in
the program then once course is looped in does the interview
and that person gets more views than me or whatever. So I think
it's they sort of just >> yeah I do think this is like
a concern and yeah I think um then you don't get 8K a month.
I do think this is like somewhat a little bit it's like okay
they are paying you maybe there should be some
element of benefit to them right I I I think you can report on
it you can say it's concerning I don't see I thought there was
a different clause in here that is not this one that's basically
said if you're going to support or talk about a specific candidate
maybe it's if you're using chorus funds maybe that's the clause
I'm thinking of but this is uh
yeah that you need to disclose to them and then collaborate fully
with chorus regarding all such separately arranged engagements
and again um the the dispute I've seen of that point is I didn't
have to do this and it's like no you didn't do that and they
might not even be aware that you didn't do that and they might
just not be able to enforce that because they didn't know about
it right you can't show me that it's not in the contract show
me that it's not in the contract you're showing me the contract
that says exactly what I said it said and then telling me well
they didn't enforce it on me it's like that doesn't mean anything
that's not disproving what I said that's just saying some that's
just saying some yeah they might not know about it you might
have gotten permission from them to go around those rules But
that that contract provision applies to everybody and people
most people who read it will automatically do it without asking
any questions or doing anything differently. >> They felt
like they you know they wanted to maintain
released from that the three parts of it that idea of them being
able to be a blocker or that you would have to funnel anything
through them. I didn't see that unless there was another part
of the contract that didn't get released. So again, funnel contacts
through. >> It says Yeah, it says it says I give you the
right screenshot. >> What? Yeah. Oh, I pulled I think I
pulled it up. Ozel gave it to me. >> Oh, did you? Oh, okay.
>> Ozo gave it I looked at it a little bit >> Yeah.
Yeah. >> We can feel comfortable talking about exactly
this specific language because one of the creators did post just
this specific paragraph. So, we can discuss the specific paragraph.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Rook, this is basically what we're being
told. This is like a lot of the the disproving stuff they do.
They're like, "Yeah, the you report on the law, like the speed
limit on a specific like freeway and somebody responds and goes,
uh, here's me driving like 80 on that freeway, right? The the
speed limit is 65. Here's me driving 80 on that freeway. Are
you sure that there's a speed limit there?" Yeah, I it's literally
on the books, bro. What What the [__] are we talking
about? >> Um, but you know, engagements things wouldn't
change if you follow this speed limit, right? You can be there's
a lot of uh roads you'll see like one random road um like between
blocks will have a lower speed limit because there's like frequent
accidents there. You like you should still report on it just
because that's like the correct speed limit. It could have an
effect. >> Yeah, exactly. That's the that is the issue
is people are going well I I've broken that law and nothing bad
happened to me. And it's like yeah but one most people are going
to think that's the speed limit, right? I think most reasonable
people think that's the speed limit now obviously and beyond
that because you didn't get punished doesn't mean it wouldn't
be enforced. >> I haven't broken the law. I drove the speed
limit. I didn't get into an accident so everything fine. Okay.
>> I think the argument isn't that they didn't break the
law. >> I think they're saying they're trying to argue
the law doesn't exist that it's been reported incorrectly. >> That's
that's like what I'm seeing them saying like where where they're
basically like where the allegation is it's a rule in the contract.
It's specified in the contract that you cannot disclose if you're
you're being paid by chorus or do a partnership disclosure without
express written consent. And they're saying, well, here's me
talking about it and I didn't get in trouble, but it's from before
that contract existed, right? >> They're saying the law
they're like trying to say you're lying. You're saying this law
exists and they're saying, well, here's me not following that
law before that law was written. And you're like, well, >> before
I signed a Yeah, yeah, yeah, I get it now. >> Like, okay,
that doesn't that doesn't say anything. You just made a nonsense
statement. Not really, Loki Coco. Um, if you can pass a reading
test, find a reading test online. If you can pass beyond the
ninth grade reading level, I will start taking your chat seriously
again. Okay. >> Chorus will provide contractors with access
to the Chorus newsroom, which coordinates booking engagements.
Right. Yep. Da da da da da da. Contractor agrees to one, use
Chorus Newsroom to book engagements. Two, disclose to Chorus
newsroom personnel any engagements with government officials
or other topics related to Chorus's policy agenda. Very broad.
I asked Chorus what their policy agenda is. We still don't >> Oh,
wait, wait, wait. Hold on. >> Related to Chorus's policy
agenda. Very broad. I asked Chorus what their policy agenda is.
We still don't know. Uh that contractor arranges through other
means. Three, collaborate fully with Chorus regarding all such
separately arranged agreements. Um, so you know that to a lot
of creators that spoke to us felt unnecessarily restrictive.
They felt like, hey, I'm my own person. I'm fine being part of
this incubator program, but why do I have to use their system
to book all these things with lawmakers? Why do I have to loop
them in on things and sort of funnel my contact stuff through
them? I don't want to give them my contact info. I don't want
to have to loop them in because I'm worried that someone else
from the network is going to big dog me and, you know, take take
my interview or do something else. So just I think the so there
are two things going on here. So one is from somebody that's
been part of organizations and part of agencies and part of a
bunch of other things. I think it sounds like the guy the the
the goal of the newsroom basically was to connect creators in
the program to I guess like um >> lawmakers lawmakers policy
wonks whatever whoever else right so I feel like it makes sense
that if I'm going to let's say that I host an org and I have
like 20 smaller creators and I bring them you know and I have
them introduced to Bernie Sanders or whatever >> if I have
an arrangement set up to where after that meeting Bernie Sanders
staff is going to get 17 emails from creators saying like hey
we just met you can we also do our own one-on-one thing that
nobody would ever want to be a part of the the newsroom stuff.
Like you would never have access to any of that information because
now every single time that somebody's brought in. So it makes
sense for newsroom related stuff that you would have to at the
very least loop in or clue in uh Chorus with what's going on
there. Especially if they're the ones that have like reached
out,
>> but then then you're just saying the argument he's making
right now is just that chorus or sorry that the reporting is
correct because he's saying they would have to stop you from
reaching out to Bernie directly, right? they would have to you
have to loop us in because if you just reach out to Bernie like
that's actually going to [__] us over. It's like
okay so you're now controlling these independent creators if
they weren't a part of this program right they could see a smaller
creator talk to
and they could just reach out on their own but now because they're
in chorus they might be prevented from doing that or you just
made a nonsense statement because still 17 people will reach
out just through the chorus software or something. Yeah, it's
crazy that two groups of people can come away with such different
interpretations. I'm honestly I'm just watching with like the
things I know that doesn't even seem like a bad thing. I don't
know if it's a bad thing or not. I'm just watching this. I'm
surpris I'm not shocked that DG with the DG thinks that uh Destiny
responded sufficiently to Willie Mack and he literally didn't
respond to anything. He just me'd the whole time like uh that
they're lost. They're totally lost. But um I don't know. I just
like to see any tangible push back on any of the things he's
saying are lies here. And I' I've not seen it yet. I'm not seeing
it at all. Anyway, we continue. Sorry, I was looking through
chat for other messages. I guess the argument the only the only
issue I have on the paragraph is that like that funnel like heavily
implies that you the way that the article is written is that
chorus can block you from doing your own independent uh media.
That's not what that means. I don't think that's what that means
at all. And it says looped in in the same sentence, doesn't it?
Maybe in the same
looped. Uh, according to copies of the contract view by Wired,
creators in the program must funnel all bookings with lawmakers
and political leaders through Chorus. Creators also have to loop
chorus in on any independently. Oh yeah, I don't think this is
incorrect. Funnel all bookings with lawmakers and political leaders
through Chorus. I think you need to have a record of them with
Chorus. I don't think that's wrong. I don't think funnel implies
block here. I don't know why funnel would imply block.
It means that it needs to pass through something Chorus controls.
Yeah, I don't I actually don't see how funnel could mean that.
But I definitely must have watched it. I've heard that that Pisco
Aaron conversation was mostly about that. So maybe Destiny watched
that or something on a draft off of Pisco here. Maybe >> I
guess >> we don't make that claim in this story and I'm
sorry if the word funnel sort of implied that to you. Um
>> what's up? Sorry I have you a little bit lower than
the audio here.
>> No, you don't. That's what I'm saying cuz um
>> you're basically just saying he's copying off Fisco's
homework. Um, yeah, it's almost like that's been happening for
a long time. >> Orus can block you from doing your own
independent uh media. I guess >> we don't make that claim
in this story. And I'm sorry if the word funnel sort of implied
that to you. >> Where can anybody explain to me where funnel
means block? In any case, a funnel is to translate is to transfer
a material between two differentiz containers. Where in like
literally the meaning of funnel is not that there's no part of
funnel that means block.
It could possibly mean slow down, but Destiny just said Destiny's
own argument is that they might slow down contacts to certain
political leaders, right? Because they don't want them to get
spammed.
But it doesn't mean block. There's no possible interpretation
of the word funnel that means block. >> Yeah. It doesn't
mean block, but it's the it would if it would stop somebody from
doing if it would slow them down from reaching out to people
because essentially reaching out to them is like, "Hey, once
you talk to me, I need to sign you up on this email spam list."
Maybe it feels like it it blocks them from being productive or
something,
>> Um I guess so. Um I just I don't think there's any implication
of blocking. Guide or channel something through or as if through
a funnel.
a tube or pipe that is wide at the top and narrow at the bottom
used for guiding liquid or powder into a small opening. >> Yes.
No. No. Obviously, the word funnel does not mean block. But if
you as a content creator feel some sort of shame for putting
the the
uh professionals that you're reaching out to, the people you're
trying to contact for an interview. If you feel some sort of
shame for funneling them through Chorus, it might block or stop
you from contacting them. No, >> I don't think block. I
might I think it might mean like uh manage at most, but I think
the implication is not block. >> What do you mean manage?
>> Like as in as in like slow down. As in like, hey, this
guy's getting spammed. We're going to here we're going to set
you up with him, but like wait two weeks or wait 3 weeks or wait
four weeks. >> Are we talking about two different
>> Uh maybe. >> Or what is he calling blocked? because
I assume I would feel some sort of shame if every time I have
to like reach out to somebody that I'm essentially putting them
in this like uh email spam list.
>> Yeah. I I think you don't I don't think you just give
these these uh contacts out to everybody. I think you book through
the software. They have access sorry they have access to those
contacts. I don't think everybody could just see every contact
in there. I very much doubt how that matter or doubt that that
happens, right? Like you don't see every other cont every other
content creator's contacts that they put in there. I would I
would doubt that,
>> Yeah. Well, I don't know. >> So, funneling could
mean controlling the interaction, right? It could mean like,
hey, we need to tell you stuff. We need to coordinate with you.
But it says collaborate fully with chorus in independently engaged
things anyway. So, I would say that part of the contract reads
the same way. >> And I'm sort of talking about selfblocking.
Like I feel like you would stop your own like reaching out
because you're putting them through this um
I don't know this like ring of people who are now going to contact
them. Like don't you hate when you go on Amazon and then all
of a sudden all of your ads are catered to the thing that you
just
>> Not necessarily, but sometimes. Um yeah, I don't I don't
know. I think to I I understand what you're saying and like that
would be fine to be clear what she she actually elaborated on
what she meant by funnel right so you could argue it's misleading
but what funnel means here is you funnel it through the chorus
software right you have to put the contact in the course software
book it through the chorus software that is what funnel means
in this case right so we already literally know what funnel means
>> yeah yeah but you're implying that nobody else that's
on this like uh this network uh address book or whatever they
these contacts. >> Well, I doubt it. >> Only on their
back end they can. >> I I doubt it personally, but I don't
know. And it's irrelevant to what I just >> Oh, is it?
>> Yeah. So, if you're funneling, what they mean by funnel
is they mean I'm you're going to open up this software. When
you book that engagement, you're going to open up this software.
You're going to book it, schedule it through here, and put their
contact in. That's what funnel means. That's Taylor said explicitly.
That's what she means when she's talking about it. Right? So,
there's no question about what funnel means now. That's on the
record. But, we're talking about what it could be interpreted
as. Sorry, there's two different discussions. Just I'm I'm also
arguing with Chad a little >> I don't think it's I don't
think it's a different discussion. I think I'm thinking of like
the shame that you would have as a creator for funneling them
funneling people into this address book or this software
knowing that they are going to be contacted and reached out to
by people from Chorus even though they're setting up to have
a conversation with you. I feel like I would have too much shame
to >> constantly put every person through that system.
Like I would have some sort of selfblocking mechanism
>> that you are worried about them getting spammed or even
just worried and Taylor said this that that creators were worried
about like a bigger creator doing it at the like a week later
and taking views from them, right? >> Oh, I guess. Yeah,
for that too. >> That was something that I think was explicitly
talked about if I'm not >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Dude, I should just uh shut up. I'm clearly not saying
anything that makes
>> No, you're making total sense to me. No, that that makes
total sense to me. like for why they might think that they're
>> being like five times.
>> Sorry, I I was maybe misunderstanding based on how I
was talking through it. Kind of the most flexible thought process
sometimes, but um Okay, a bunch of people are adding like connotations
to funnel that I don't think are there. Um but it's fine. I think
what you're saying makes sense to me in terms of how people could
interpret it. Like they don't want things to be spammed because
they added to that newsroom. But what people are saying in terms
of oh it means chorus could say don't do that. I don't think
that's what it means. I just don't I don't see it that way. Yeah,
I'm I'm managing like five different things in my head. It's
It's whatever. You're >> Um yeah. Anyway, we're back to
this. >> Um but we don't we don't make that claim. So Stephen,
you brought something up that I think is is actually >> One
more one more quick question on that. Sorry. And then you said
Okay. Cuz I don't know why cuz you use loop chorus in on the
next sentence. Why not just say loop in? Cuz I've never in my
life heard funnel. funnel always means you're handing the reigns
over to somebody else, right? Like I'm sure
>> are using their program to book it, but sure I >> could
also book it on your own, right? Because the next sentence you
have is that um you can loop in on any independently organizing
>> them in but loop in is not fun. >> Um this is
I think these are split into two different things here. I think
the two different things are if you book it through chorus uh
sorry if you if you book it with a politician through chorus
you have to add that to the course book or the course like thing
if you book it independently you need to book it through the
course software right the looping in I'm wondering if the looping
in has to do with like notifying them or getting some kind of
like uh like if if there's a different process there but it seems
pretty clear to me that it just all channels through the same
thing. You are you are channeling it all through the same software
>> funnel. Those are two really different things, right?
>> Okay. Okay. So, >> wait, do you acknowledge those
are two really different things to loop somebody in versus to
funnel it through? >> I personally don't interpret it that
way, but if you want to interpret it that way, you're welcome
to interpret it that way. I think again this is another reason
why it would be really helpful for these creators that feel that
maybe hey that word wasn't 100%
right or something that you know they can release the contracts
and people can litigate the specific language but >> people
are saying that Taylor implied that chorus gets to dictate whether
or not any creator can ever talk to any politician if they're
in that program and Taylor is saying no I didn't say that when
I say funnel things through Chorus I mean you funnel it through
the chorus media the chorus newsroom software ware. So like even
if there is a even if there is a dispute here, let's say it's
let's say it is confusing. I don't think it's confusing, but
let's say it is confusing because you know other people aren't
familiar with this kind of software that whatever reason, right?
She's now just resolving the ambiguity and saying it explicitly.
That's not a funnel. Now that though that's a bridge, you're
just being she's saying funnel. I don't think there's any literal
reason it wouldn't be funnel. I don't think you guys are like
I don't I don't think there's any reason funnel doesn't work.
And there's not even a meaningful distinction there, right? You've
got so many people under chorus. Why wouldn't you just say funnel
instead of bridge?
>> Yeah. I I I just don't think it's like necessarily bad.
And she's literally just typing out or she's literally just saying
explicitly what she means. So like there is no ambiguity here
now, right? There's no ambiguity at all. >> Like you literally
take an island and you call that chorus.
You're the content creator. Let's say almost in a circle every
content creator builds a bridge to chorus that almost looks like
a funnel. >> Yeah. And um actually Kerski's actually hit
it exactly here. I think this is exactly the difference. Okay.
Um funnel versus loopin is funnel is you should be putting these
all through the core software. If you book something through
some other thing, you do have to you just because you didn't
book it through us, you do have to loop us in. You have to you
have to actually go back and create the thing and let us know
that that happened.
I think that is a perfect distinction between those two things
before the fact after the fact that makes total sense in the
context of this article. >> Oh yeah true. >> Yeah
that's a excellent point Kirstki. Thank you. But I think what
you brought up
managing >> bigger point in all of this is exactly the
experience or the situation that you described, right? You have
17 creators. Uh now these lawmakers are going to get 17 different
emails, whatever. Maybe Chorus is providing this service where
they're going to loop everyone in or they're going to, you know,
everyone's going to use this sort of one cohesive system and
and put it all sort of through one thing. So you're you're right.
Right. Like that that there is an argument to be made for that
type of system. And I've talked to a lot of lawmakers uh especially
on the Senate side um but also in the House because the House
has had a bunch of you know the their um uh the comm's group
there has like been doing a bunch more with influencers
and they like working with these intermediary groups because
they're like gh our lawmakers offices are inundated with all
these people. We want to hand it off to a gatekeeper who's a
middleman who can figure it out cuz we barely we just learned
that the YouTuber world existed yesterday. So we can't evaluate
all this stuff. we don't have this app. So, we like working with
these third party groups. So, I think >> YouTube what's
that? >> Like chorus especially has kind of become this
like intermediary again helping these lawmakers like some of
these lawmakers have spoken very positively of that service.
But to content creators, it it feels to some of these content
creators that spoke to us that they feel like, oh, well, now
we have this new middleman to get through where I used to just
be able to go to directly to the lawmakers and now I have to
go through this middleman. And so there's been resentment towards
not just chorus, there's other groups that are seeking to, this
is like a big new thing that all these groups are sort of seeking
to do is like establish themselves as middlemen. >> Um,
and >> but then why I'm curious, why do you think those
creators then sign that
Well, they sign the contract because they for, you know, they
all have different reasons for signing the contract, but some
of them disagree with things in the contract.
>> It's like being first Amazon, right? If I can get the
most content creators, it's not even like that be the >> dude.
It's like, yeah, but hold on. He's asking why the content creators
would sign a contract. Why would somebody sign up to work at
McDonald's?
Need money to live, okay, to eat. Like, why would why would they
even sign this if they think it's bad? Um, yeah, I don't want
to flip burgers, but I have to eat. So, I'm going to go do something
I don't particularly want to do. Sorry, I that >> why
they do is like establish themselves as middlemen. >> Um,
and then I'm curious. Why do you think those creators then sign
that
>> Well, they signed the contract because they for, you
know, they all have different reasons for signing the contract.
But some of them disagree with things in the contract and tried
to get out of different things in the contract. >> sure,
but if you're but if you're but if you're signing a contract,
there's going to be a give and take on any contract, right? Sure.
Like if I get hired by a company to do some amount of work for
10,000 a month, I'm going to hate having
this is so richcoded. Most small streamers don't know that they
can
like aspects of a contract.
>> They don't um they just sign. I just >> I just
think this is funny that like people are willing to fight on
like this isn't happening. This isn't in the contract. And then
it's like okay well maybe it's in the contract but like what's
wrong with that? It's like, okay, you don't get to play both
sides of that argument. How about you pick one and decide which
one you actually believe in, okay? Don't don't like actually
run down the line of like, "This isn't what said. This isn't
what was said. This doesn't make any sense." And then you lose
that and you go, "Actually, what would even be wrong with that?"
Come on, man. >> Of course. Of course. Yeah. Well, you'd
have to, you know, ask them. But I think it's interesting. I
think what's interesting and like what >> that's Sorry,
I got to pull it back here. That's like actually exactly what's
upset uh me so much about this is people will take a totally
disingenuous position that I feel like they know they don't they
can't stand on and maybe they don't maybe they're just like dumb
but I feel like they know they can't stand on it and then when
they get called out on that they go oh but what would be wrong
with that it's like bro you don't get to you don't get to go
and make the actual argument now I don't I you got to make the
argument I was willing to have with you I was willing to have
one you don't get to have two make one either ar e engage in
good faith and know that the article is factually reporting the
contracts and nobody's disputed that or
argue that there's no problem with that contract stipulation
as it stands. >> Yeah, of course. Of course. Yeah. Well,
you'd have to, you know, ask them. But I think it's interesting
I think what's interesting and like what what interests me about
that. >> Can you steal the argument on the side that thinks
Taylor Loren was in the wrong? Uh they think Taylor they they
base this entirely on vibes. Hassan, you literally heard it.
Hassan Hassan is bad. Hassan is tied to Taylor Loren. Taylor
Loren wrote this article for Hassan to take a shot at people
who don't want to include Hassan in the Democratic party. Um,
and everything about this article stems from how they hate Hassan
or how Taylor hates these people and she's trying to undermine
anything they're attempting to do. Right? That's that's where
it's coming from. Taylor Loren is totally trying to undermine
the Democratic party. She hates the Democratic party. She doesn't
want them to be successful and every single part of this article
leans in that direction because she hates she hates us. And if
that was the argument they went with from the start, by the way,
that would be fine. But the argument they went with from the
start was she's lying. This article is debunked. And I'm going
to I'm going to absolutely make sure that people are held to
that. You don't get to now switch up your argument, right? No,
that is the best Steelman now watching your back. That's the
best Steelman now. Every single thing they're saying is falling
apart completely. Right? every single every single thing they
said. Uh oh. What do you think of this perspective? Oh, we're
getting linked to random. Okay, hold on. Let's watch. >> This
place has been kind of >> Is this Is this somebody who
Oh, by the way, uh if this is just right-wingers do this, um
other people do this. Why can't the good guys do this? I have
no problem with that argument. In fact, I believe in that argument.
But there's no reason you can't be a good guy. Do this and also
not try to attack anybody who points out that you're doing it.
If you're going to do shady [__] that you don't want
exposed, shady you don't want to stand on business on. Then slink
into the shadows like the lizard you are. Okay? Slink into the
shadows. Go do your shadowy. You want to be like Republicans,
then nut up like Republicans and do your shadowy in the shadows.
Okay? And and don't don't surface and come and try to act like
you're a good guy, too. Shut the [__] up and take
your money. >> No, but there's also a world in which they
are the good guy, right? But you you're not actually the good
guy if you can't like elaborate or or qualify why you're the
good guy. Murder is bad. People is bad. War is bad. But guess
what? If one side is you, you can pro you can justify it. You
can articulate why you need to enact violence. And these people
are just gaslighting. They won't even give you like the the dignity
of saying, "Well, this is justified."
>> 100%.
the yes, I agree with you 100%. And if they'd actually make that
argument, I agree with that 100%. But the issue is is what they're
telling me is I'm I'm literally this this article is a microcosm.
I'm not even joking. I'm going to do it, okay? I'm going to do
the thing I tell everybody not to do. It's a microcosm of Israel
Palestine. >> It's a microcosm because what's happening
is I'm watching one side totally wipe out the other one and going,
"We're not really at war and we're the most moral army and we
do everything we can to not do right." They're like totally trying
to gaslight me on what is happening. I'm being totally gas lit
on what is happening. They're basically telling me they're like
not really doing anything wrong.
And it's like, brother, >> I'm so glad you said that. >> See
the bodies? >> No, because you you brought up Israel Palestine
for relly just to use that as an example. And I tried to tell
you I'm like, okay, a lot of people are going to invoke the Israel
Palestine thing cuz it's at the top of their head. It's what
they've researched the most. You will go to analogies or you
will go to like uh point out reasons and stuff like that on things
that you're confident on.
I didn't inherently think that that meant that chorus to every
person who invokes Israel Palestine or people who are like denying
genocide that they think chorus is like this um this shill company
or something. That was like a crazy straw man. >> Yeah.
Yes, I know. God, it's I know. I got to be better. I just I'm
like I feel like I can >> It's fine to point that out cuz
some people do that but it's not everybody. >> Yeah, not
everybody. if this person's telling but I've never I've never
come at one of the people who just is honest about it and been
like you're total anybody who has this take if this take is like
Republicans do this and there's a bunch of bad money going around
and we want to be the good guys doing this then I'm like okay
thank you thank you okay hold on um why do you keep yeah hold
on I responded to real Dr. cube. He said, "Why do you keep making
analogies with crimes?" Taylor Lawrence's article doesn't accuse
course of breaking any laws, just that it's ethically questionable,
right? Uh I the analogy around what Israel is doing is not necessarily
making uh committing crimes at all, just so we're clear. But
I I don't know why it would matter. It's about culpability. It's
about intent and culpability, right?
Like you're telling me you're doing something different than
you're doing. That's where that's the entire part of that. Just
because it's a war analogy or a crime analogy, it doesn't mean
that uh it doesn't mean that it doesn't apply. It's about what's
happening, what reality is, and how you're trying to gaslight
me and tell me reality isn't that way. If all of these people
would stop lying,
right? Lying, then I'd be okay. Here's another person who can't
engage with facts. Okay, I I actually don't know that. I saw
the name and I was just like, "This black cat person is usually"
But let me actually read it cuz I'll I'll actually check. Totally
disagree there. Taylor explicitly lied about them being forced
to go with prodemn narratives which included Zionism that is
debunked and Taylor played into it which led to people smearing
them all as Zionist. Taylor didn't lean into it in the article.
>> She leaned into it in one of her one of her appearances
with Glenn Greenwald and I said that's to do. Why the [__]
would you do that? >> You can criticize that. >> Yeah,
you can totally go in on her for her. But then you have to get
away from the article cuz you can't criticize the article if
you just you have if you want to make that criticism admit that
you can't criticize the article. The article is almost entirely
factually correct.
>> I would say the only bad part of the >> go ahead.
>> The only bad part of the article is the title and the
by line. Uh maybe the first paragraph a little bit too, but I
think the first paragraph's defensible. I actually think the
by line's defensible, too. But like that's an argument I can't
even get to because people are making such bad arguments that
I can't even get to the part where I could like actually steel
man the by line. Uh, I should go back and see what like headlines
and bylines that they did for COVID reporting and and other sorts
of topics that people don't care to um dramatize. But yeah. Okay.
What is this? Did Did we watch this clip already? Who is this?
>> We didn't. We didn't. I haven't even started on it.
Also, I just remembered Black Cat, are you the person who decided
to uh tell everybody exactly how and where like 10 different
creators were doxed? That was That was a bold decision. That
was a very bold decision. I just got to say, okay, I just got
to say it was a very bold decision. It's okay, though. Han is
bad. You're going to get him this time. I believe in you. >> The
politics space has been kind of messy today because of this article
that came out from Wired by Taylor Loren or Lawrence, I'm not
sure. So the article claims that some of the biggest progressive
creators, many of whom you follow and I follow, Suzanne Lambert,
Aaron Parnes, um, Booker Squared
were being or are being funded by a secret dark money group that
controls their content, doesn't let them inter >> dark
money group is secretly funding high-profile, not a secret group.
Uh, they're secretly funding
>> members of Congress without approval and doesn't let
them disclose the funding. Yeah. All of that turns out to be
BS. I mean, Elizabeth Booker is putting up screenshots of her
contract. Uh, and it turns out that Taylor just did doesn't know
how to read contract, which makes sense because her background
is in technalism. She doesn't have a political
>> Yeah, Taylor did not go and look into these and and
uh validate them. This is funny. This is just incorrect.
And again, if that were the case, if it were an opinion piece
and not handled and edited by Wire's Wireds or revised reviewed
by Wired's editorial staff that you could make this argument,
right, if it were an opinion piece, but it is a piece that the
the publication itself has has sat down, revised, and made sure
it's correct.
>> The group called >> I I love this argument,
>> right? I love when people say she's not she's not an
expert. She's not qualified. She doesn't have a background in
this. She has a background in this, but like what's this background
besides a green screen right now? Like why does she have the
background to debunk Taylor
>> Um, I don't know. I also don't know why she believes
this is debunking. I haven't even heard it. I I honestly don't
know. Hold on. >> I'm just going to go back and >> I'm
going to see I'm going to see >> the funding. Yeah, >> I
just like this accidentally. Can I undo that somehow? Right there.
Thank
>> I have to I have to listen again to what she's actually
saying when she says she debunked it. of that turns out to be
BS. I mean, Elizabeth Booker is putting up screenshots of her
contract. Uh, and it turns out that Taylor just did doesn't know
how to read. >> Where did Elizabeth Book Booker Squared
put up pictures of her contract >> read contract, which
makes sense because her background is in technicalism. She doesn't
have a political background. The group called Chorus journalism.
>> Hold on. We're going to pause again. First of all, she
blocked me on Blue Sky. Second, this says we cannot handle publicity
on behalf of Chorus, i.e. speaking to press on Chorus's behalf
without permission. Not that we cannot tell people we are a part
of Chorus. Um, nobody's ever said you can't tell people that
you're a part of Chorus. Nobody said that. Nobody made that assertion.
Uh, this is Booker Squared failing not just to like Booker Squared
apparently doesn't have a background in literacy. Apparently
that's also, you know, not only not a background in in tech journalism
or the law, just failed in the like overall, hey, can I can I
actually engage and read what's being said? That didn't happen.
doesn't have a political background. The group called Chorus,
which I am not affiliated with in any way, just to put that out
there, uh does not control who these creators interview in any
way. And it's actually a little bit insulting. I work very hard,
so I have sympathy for this, but I work very hard um to create
and maintain those connections with members of Congress to get
your questions to your representatives. And I know Elizabeth
does the same thing. So, it is a little bit insulting. Ariela
who does daily dems like wins that I'm sure many of you are subscribed
to describes exactly what
>> uh I'm part of a fellowship. I didn't talk about it
because I didn't need to. There was no reason you needed to know
about trainings I was in twice a week sometimes three times a
week depending on the week. Um in fact I believe they all have
the morning messaging meeting don't they? And the training is
getting policy expertise from somebody who is completely like
liberally aligned, right? Like somebody who is aligned with the
with the chorus leadership and the I assume the I keep thinking
like the zero dark 30 fund the 1630 fund. Okay.
Uh okay. Well, I'll resolve this in this chat as well. We can
just ban you here too. Good luck.
>> Cohort does. It's a fellowship. There are trainings
three times a week. >> All right. I banned the uh the guy
who's complaining. He's like he wants to debate via chat and
he's like you banned me from the discord. I don't ban people
from the discord unless they're a complete utter. So thank you
for outing yourself as someone who shouldn't be in the chat >> last
week kind of teaching some of them are kind of funny like teaching
them how to do skits on YouTube and the idea that it's not disclosed
just isn't true. Like Elizabeth has it in her link tree.
>> Yes. Uh the real Dr. Cube is engaging in illiteracy.
Wait, did you just say no one made the claim that content creators
couldn't disclose their relationship with Chorus? This is from
the article. According to copies of the contract viewed by Wired,
the c that the creator signed, the influencers are not allowed
to disclose their relationship with Chorus or the 16 fund or
functionally they're being paid at all. Uh so are not allowed
to disclose their relationship with Chorus. This is wrong. It's
it's with the explicit program that is misstated.
Uh I've I've gotten the entire different impression and they
state differently like they they never make this claim in the
article. If somebody said this, like that might be in the article.
Okay, if that is uh they don't actually prove that out anywhere
that they can't state that they're uh partnered with Chorus or
wait hold on
users are not allowed to disclose their relationship. Partnership
I would say um if they've signed this contract is the claim.
So it's if they've signed the contract, not that no influencers
are allowed to sign it, right? So I believe in the in the contract
it has some partnership disclosure like
parameter that says you can't disclose this. So you have to have
you have to have signed so I should have been more explicit I
guess if you are signed to this program you have signed a contract
that has the provision that says you cannot uh disclose
right that's it that's what it is that is what it is yeah yeah
so sorry it's uh if you're if you sign a contract right all of
the claims are flowing from the contracts you have to sign the
contract and then it's saying you can't disclose but I believe
they they updated the article okay since so the article might
have been updated since because there are some provided did like
uh talking points. So this is an update to the article after
they got a comment from Graham Wilson um that offer they there
was basically a some
screenshot from a slideshow was shared with Wired following the
article's publication by Graham Wilson a lawyer working with
Chorus that offers several talking points if a member of the
cohort wanted to discuss Chorus publicly. So this is how you
could disclose,
right? So this is an update, but I I do think that uh the initial
contracts seem to say and that's the claim from Wired that disclosing
this is is not allowed or you need express permission, right?
Uh you need consent, but there's no difference between these
two things. You would never say, "Okay, hold on, hold on. Oh,
nothing. I there's a there's an analogy here. I got to work on
it. I got to work on it. I I I don't know if I want to do that
analogy either. Not allowed to disclose is still in the article
and so is the not publicized quote. Did Taylor add without consent?
I'll have to check. I don't think she did. I think it was not
updated correctly, but I don't know if Taylor's updated it herself.
Do you think any of this ends in lawsuits? No, because the the
reporting has been updated as it's gone. And they probably should
update the content of the article for like um what not allowed
to disclose? Private standard partnerships disclosures
declaring that creators will not publicize the relationship of
course or tell others that they're members of the program without
courses prior express consent. Okay. So they mean without consent
here. Okay. Yeah. Which sure. So you can say that the the higher
points of the article without getting into the the minor details
is uh what leaning in a direction. But again if you go down to
the actual details these are the factual claims. Right. So they
have consent or are in breach. Yes. Exactly. Um I'm trying to
think. So Taylor said this and there was no push back here and
so I I ran with it. It's like she's saying she doesn't think
the group is secretive. She doesn't think people can't talk about
the group, but it's just that people who have signed the contract
aren't supposed to. There's there's provisions in the contract
that say you can't disclose. And then we have the update. So
>> that like this clause that you're bringing up is that
especially if we want to like zoom out a little bit and look
at the Democrats media strategy, they've consistently relied
on these kind of middleman groups. Uh we had village marketing
of course during the campaign um basically serving this very
same purpose where they're sort of filtering creators determining
who gets access to lawmakers etc etc and I totally understand
proof uh the proof is wired made the claim um they're a journalistic
institution that has spent decades building up a reputation for
validating and uh and telling the truth and following journalistic
ethics and chorus the company that started uh nine 10 months
ago has not actually disputed the factual claims about the contracts
uh and what's contained in the contracts. So that's why I'm saying
it's proven. And if Chorus themselves are going to uh Oh, I wasn't
watching. Sorry, they're asking for proof in a totally different
conversation. Anyway, I'll answer just in case uh people are
wondering. I chorus themselves need to actually dispute and say
the the contract provisions you're highlighting are incorrect.
That's uh that's what I'm that's where I was going. But yeah,
the trap message I was looking at, I don't get >> from
the lawmakers, you know, feel >> I need to get rid of the
quoting element of kick entirely and people need to add each
other >> makers, etc., etc. And I totally understand from
the lawmakers, you know, feeling that that's valuable. But more
recently, and I talked to one lawmaker actually just, well, it's
been a couple months ago. It was the White House correspondents
weekend, and this representative was telling me, "You know what?
I'm beginning to be suspect about some of these groups because
I've been hearing from these other content creators that I actually
would have loved to work with that they haven't been able to
get through the gates of these groups and I feel like maybe now
I'm cutting myself off from other opportunities." And so, >> I
don't understand. I guess I don't understand that because anybody
can email. I'm pretty sure all these comms people are I know
this because I've talked to some of these the on Yeah. anybody
email. So I don't know how you >> but they're inundated
and so they're not they're what they mean what they mean is that
these lawmakers and especially the the house which has established
a lot more like cuz there's so many of them um more of these
sort of like middlemen they just rely on the middlemen so they're
just like you know what we don't really take inbound now a lot
more lawmakers are more open especially people like Roana and
others they are becoming more open where they're like you know
what I might rely on this middleman for some stuff but I'm also
going to try to ensure that I hire staff that actually can evaluate
these opportunities ities and even do more proactive opportunities
um to kind of develop our own direct relationship. And on the
Senate side, Cy Booker has really done this where Cy Booker himself
has become the kind of middleman and Corey's office has done
a lot actually to help educate other pe other members on the
Democrat side on the Senate of who content creators are, how
to work with them, how to evaluate these opportunities. And uh
Cory's office has has created a lot of shared resources to try
to help empower them so that they don't just have to rely on
these like third party companies which also are making money,
right? And they don't have to like worry about that. So I think
it's one of the things I guess when I look at this >> strategies
evolve. >> Yeah. We keep using the word middleman, but
like there's a value that these types of organizations are providing
to both the lawmakers and to the >> uh internet ray. What
I would say is I would love if the lawyer decided to publicly
disclose that, right? So, for some reason, the public disclosure
didn't mean Wired went and updated the article to say like, "Oh,
this is totally incorrect." Right? They didn't feel the need
to actually correct the article. They just added as context.
So, I'm guessing what they consider a slide where they gave them
a way to disclose is bordering on meaningless, right? That's
that's what I'm guessing. But we'd have to we'd have to go and
look and see because I don't know why Chorus' lawyer wouldn't
just publish this, right? I don't know why Brian Tyler Cohen
wouldn't just publish this and say here are the here are the
instructions we gave them for how to disclose.
Right. Anyway, we continue
>> streamers themselves. Yeah. But it feels like when we
talk about whether you want to say loopin or funnel or whatever,
like it seems like we're talking about this as though it's almost
like predatory or it's preventing people from doing some things.
But the reality is is that course is just protecting the the
business that it's in of of being able to form valuable >> connection.
They're going to which totally from a business standpoint, I
understand that. And from a business standpoint, they want to
also capture like what they also want to do is make sure that
people aren't going off that people are in this program, right?
And that they're off capturing like you know, say you you're
in this program and you have these people making this content
that ends up really successful, you know, that course wants to
capture that and be able to put that in reports and stuff. So
I again I understand it. I think what what I found so interesting
about this specific thing is that there are all of these discussions
right now happening on the House and Senate side about because
again they've all sort of just discovered influencers like in
the >> I wonder why nobody in chorus by the way we made
this argument like uh I we were making this argument and um we
were making this argument before like it makes total sense if
they want to do that like obviously they want to get something
out of this they're paying people this would be something they
can get back right they can get this like this addition to their
network they they these contacts, they get this like system up
and running and they validate whether or not this system is like
going to be useful going forward, right? So, that makes total
sense. We love that. But then why doesn't anyone just come out
and say like obviously that's what we're trying to do there and
and that makes total sense. Why go like they're lying? No, they
they could just go yeah, we are doing that, but like here's the
business reason we're doing it and we don't think there's anything
wrong with that. I've never seen that. I've never seen that response.
Maybe somebody is doing that and I'm unaware of it. But who's
come out and taken that precise like allegation and said, "Oh,
here's like a totally good reason we're doing it." And why
why or why is it not an official Chorus like torchbearer? Why
is Brian Tyler Cohen not saying that? Why is Chorus themselves
not saying that, right? Why is it random influencers who aren't
related to Chorus making that argument?
That's what's kind of weird to me. These guys are saying they
understand how online media works, that they they understand
how the online ecosystem works, and they're getting their asses
kicked in the online ecosystem. This is like, is is Brianna Woo
involved? Because it sounds like Brianna Woo's level of expertise
going on here. >> Six months of like, how should we handle
this? Should we rely on these outside agencies? How much power
should we give them? How, you know, who can we hire internally?
Is it the digital team? Is it the comm's people? who you know
a lot of requests come through the comm's people but the comm's
people really only deal with traditional media and so that's
what like Corey's team especially has really on the Senate side
tried to kind of like educate people about and I think on the
house side it's a little bit more of a a free-for-all
I I understand all of that I guess I I guess what I'm trying
to say is that I think that when you come when you read the article
the article is almost completely or overwhelmingly negative in
regards to chorus and its place and the connection they have
between the influencer and Congress but it but chorus in this
way is just functioning as the same type of talent agency or
rep that that exists in ubiquitously. >> Talent agencies
and reps, Stephen. >> Because these content creators, many
of them also have talent agencies and reps. And so one drama
that Chorus got involved in months ago was actually relation
to exactly what you're just describing, which I think is what
you're going to say is like this is what talent agencies and
reps have doing like they have social good, you know, departments
at WME or whatever, right, that can help set these things up.
So,
so chorus and not just chorus and we can use chorus as like you
know chorus isn't >> oh right chorus is like ender rounding
so the drama chorus got in was that they were endounding like
talent agencies and actually using creators like faces for their
their finan their fundraising pages that weren't signed with
chorus right they're endounding these talent >> an example
of there's also like there's lots of other sort of like chorus
copycat type uh agencies that have cropped up >> these
talent agents and managers have become so livid with these middleman
agencies because the middleman a and I just say middleman because
they are I I should just say agencies like you know all all man
the managers and agents are also middlemen okay it's middlemen
against middlemen but um we have so we have like these political
groups where like you know Stuart Brian Tyler Cohen like they're
very much from the political world the people that started chorus
and then we have the entertainment world and the entertainment
world they for a long time have already been in this space and
suddenly the political world is like oh this doesn't exist. We're
going to set this thing up, right? We're going to serve this
thing and we we already have these relationships with Congress
people. So, you're seeing a lot of clashing where the management
companies and the talent agencies feel like, hey, how dare you
go off and represent our creators? Only we represent our creators.
And then also confusion on the booking side where they're like,
well, I reached out to Chorus, but should I reach out to UTA?
Should I reach out to what? Like, it's just absolute chaos. And
I think >> Well, hold on. I this this is I feel like this
is dramatically over exaggerated. should be no chaos here whatsoever.
So, I literally have signed with UTA in the past. Like, you know,
exactly when you're signing with agencies like this, the contract
they're giving you generally gives them, if you're if you're
serious talent, they have the exclusive right to organize um
any type of paid sponsor activation, whatever type of like that
stuff that Chorus or these other political organizations cover.
There might be some ambiguity there on to whether or not that
would come under my UTA contract. But, if I'm big talent or if
I'm medium sized talent, of course, I'm just going to ask my
UTA rep, right? I'm just going to shoot him an email or message
him on whatever platform to say, "Hey, does this conflict with
this contract?" I don't know how this could be massive chaos
or What's chaos? So, first of all, you're talking about >> what's
chaos is when you're supposed to be networking with these creators
as an agency of some kind. You're supposed to go to the rep yourself.
What that happens is they probably email or direct message the
actual creator, right? Bypassing the rep and they say, "Hey,
do you want to be a part of some exciting new political thing?
We could get collaborations for you." And the creator because
they're a dumb doesn't think to go to their rep, right? There's
no professional courtesy happening here. The professional courtesy
is you're doing something kind of like we do. You message us
and you talk to us. You don't talk to our rep or our person directly.
People in Hollywood cut throats over this. Okay? You go talk
to some actor who's represented by a talent agency about a film
opportunity. They will cut your throat in the street. Okay? That's
just that's just allowed by Hollywood laws. Okay? It's crazy.
Straight razor, they'll they'll kick you out in the street. Okay.
And I'm guessing that Chorus did this. And I'm guessing that's
how course up and thought they were representing some of these
people or that they had contacts with these people and used their
images because probably they they had some intermediate or said
they had some discussion with them and didn't come to any conclusion
and maybe the talent rep said oh actually like uh like no cut
that off don't talk to them at all >> about a talent agent
contract which is different of course than a management contract.
What the chaos is is that's happening is that many of these creators
especially if they're big creators are signing up. They want
to do political work. Some of these big creators like they're
like, "Oh man, I do want to get more involved in politics. I
hate that Trump won, right? I do want to get more involved in
politics." So, they'll sign up with one of these third party
things. Sometimes not even getting paid, right? They're not even
part of the paid course program. Maybe they just signed up for
course cuz they want to do more stuff. And then the talent agents
are coming in and being like, "Well, wait a minute. Like, we're
the one to negotiate deals. We're the ones that have the um exclusive
right to sort of like represent you and negotiate opportunities
for you and things like that." And so there's just this tension
which has by the way it's funny we can talk about how the right
has resolved like the right had a version of this uh also that
they dealt with. But um but I think that it just shows that like
there's just a lot of sort of kinks to work out in terms of streamlining
this process. And as the Democrats work to leverage more content
creators, I think that it's interesting for me as a journalist
to write about these different strategies and the way that these
things are evolving. And so that's why I'm interested in Chorus.
And not just chorus. I've reported on the other groups too and
I have another story coming out soon about a whole other similar
group. But they're all sort of jockeying for
>> uh you all they're all jockeying for their own businesses
and their own business interests. But also the the lawmakers
and the Democratic lawmakers that I've spoken to are also trying
to figure it out and they are sort of getting their sea legs
and so I think that covering this stuff is is interesting. And
if we want to look at the right by example. >> Well, we
before I guess we move on to that. So, like I agree with what
you're saying there, but the article in my mind like it just
basically >> just to be clear, I actually disagree with
some people in chat that say that Desi's like being way aggressive
in this. I don't think he's actually being like I've seen him
aggressively like try to steamroll somebody. I think he's aware
that like if he does that to her like she's kind of just being
kind like she's with kindness. I don't think she can be steamrolled
here. She's not like she's not reached that tone. So, I think
>> like letting her some people are saying he's being aggressive.
Like he's trying not to lose. I actually disagree. I think he's
like being talked to and he's not fighting like an attack surface.
Like basically everywhere where he has a disagreement, Taylor's
like, "Oh, that's like kind of a valid disagreement. There'd
be some dispute there, but like here's what I meant and anything
else."
>> Are they imagining just like having
a point to disagree about equals aggression? cuz he he wrote
a whole like Obsidian notebook or whatever on things he disagreed
with on the article. Like I would hope he's raising disagreements.
>> I would hope so too. Yeah. But I don't I don't think
he's been aggressive at all. I think he's let her talk a lot.
I don't think he's cut her off. I think it's been pretty respectful.
So >> I just wanted to one or analogy.
>> Not a single one. Yeah, he's really restrained actually.
I think it's like the opposite. >> He's like a hit piece
against Chorus. I don't see any of the redeeming or positive
qualities. I think the only prescription I saw in the article
when you quoted the V, whatever that person's name was, was basically
that this group just shouldn't exist at all. Like no types of
groups like this. >> A lot of these creators don't want
any middlemen. So they >> But those creators don't need
to have middlemen. They just don't sign with these groups, right?
>> Well, that creator has other they do have other middlemen.
I mean, >> why are they waiting?
>> Then why are they signing with them? They don't have
to unless they're being held at gunpoint to sign the contracts,
>> Yeah. Yeah. I think I think the the thing that struck
to me and this is not really what we're talking about here, but
I think like the main crux of the article uh is is not any of
this stuff. Like the main sort of the >> Here one second
here. I need to uh reset my headphones. It just started clicking.
Sometimes this happens. >> Are you are you talking? I feel
like I can hear you in the other room. Does chat hear you? It's
the best point he made stream. >> Did this work? Yeah.
Uh Nvidia broadcast crashed for some reason. I don't even know
why that happened, but cool. All right, we're back.is >> of
the article is that they took undisclosed money. And to me, that
is a that is something that that that people have a right to
be concerned about because Chorus is not unique in the sense
that they are not the only ones, you know, running these sort
of influence campaigns, right? This has happened on the far right
for years, although less so. They've they've gotten a lot more
transparent. But like there's there's a lot of influence campaigns
because of the lack of rules around this like you said earlier
because the FCC is like out to lunch and all >> the real
Dr. Cube says like maybe I am brain broken but this whole thing
seems like such an insane nothing burger. IMHO it was such an
insane nothing burger. Why was the backlash against Taylor Loren
so swift and so extreme? Like that's honestly >> that's
basically to me like what what set me off from this was people
just started like go >> and they were testing out their
rapid media response.
>> It worked. >> That's what it seemed like Brian.
>> Yeah. Like like the response to the
machine. Go ahead. >> Seems so crazy. Like the the response
to the article was so crazy that I was like dude this is this
is wild. And it was coming from a bunch of course affiliated
creators. So to me it's like these guys seem to be like coordinating
and uh seems like it's concerning that we might not know that
>> harmonizing. Would you say they were like a like a choir
or what's another word for choir?
>> Yeah yeah
>> yeah yeah
pretty much >> there's no regulation basically in the influencer
world. um we are seeing just like a lot of these influence campaigns
happening and consumers aren't aware of it and so consumers
consume this content and they don't know what people are being
paid and that is very different from how traditional media worked
because to all the problems of traditional media there is a lot
more >> is there do I know like every single source of
funding for like podcaster people or for like Fox >> No
we're not talking about podcaster people we're talking about
journalists So, for instance, if you're a journalist at a meme
>> What was that? I didn't see it. Oh, hold on. Hold on.
Thank you. Uh, sorry, I walked away and I have a different window
up. I need to see what that was. And I also >> Honey Duckling,
five gifted subs. >> That was five gifties. God damn. Thank
you very much, Honey Duckling. Really appreciate it, guys. I
thought I thought we were going to have to leave early tonight,
so I didn't start a timer. I'm probably not going to start a
timer now. Thank you all for all the support. Um, but I would
have started the timer if I knew we're going to be here. I I'll
be honest. We We have We made plans for
Okay. And I just thought it was Thursday today. I just I literally
just thought it was Thursday. >> I was like in the Discord
like, "Hey, The Conjuring movie came out today and it's Wednesday."
>> Yeah. So, maybe no maybe no uh stream tomorrow or a
shorter stream tomorrow or something or earlier stream. We'll
see. We'll see which way we go. I'm not totally sure. But I was
like >> we'll stream for eight more hours, you guys. Don't
worry. I had like such a lazy day, too, because I was like, "Oh,
like today's my day off." And then like unprepared. Thank god.
Thank god Taylor Loren went on a bunch of podcasts today.
>> She she literally saved me. After this, we could maybe
check out Taylor Loren and the Vanguard. Okay. I think Really
wants to talk maybe after this. >> Yeah. Why did the Vanguard
tweet out that Taylor Loren is doing an exclusive interview with
us at 2 P? I'm like, do they know that she interviewed with everybody?
Oh, well, maybe they I think this Yeah, she didn't call it >> Uh,
no, it's not exclusive because Glenn Greenwald already talked
to her. So, yeah, I was gonna say maybe they just were getting
it before Destiny didn't know, but then yeah, Glenn Greenwald
had literally already talked to her. So, wait, it is Thursday.
No, it's >> Media organization, you absolutely could never
take outside political funding. >> not political funding,
but like they could be they could take sponsorships or whatever
from other people. No, no, no, no. If you work in a mainstream
news organization, you cannot do any of that. And by the way,
I I'm sympathetic to the fact that like that might be too extreme.
Like I do think that there's probably a happy middle ground where
like maybe you can do stuff that's not directly related to your
bead, etc. Kai Nast specifically on their fashion brands and
women's fashion brands, women's media has evolved to the point
that women's media organizations are actually negotiating contracts,
spawn con contracts for their own >> Wait, can I just So
I can be clear. So, somebody who works at say who's like a host
or talent at like Fox News couldn't be paid $5,000 to
uh wait but how does Taylor Loren
the real Dr. Cube have you been following any of this? Taylor
Loren is an independent journalist. She writes she contracts
four places but she's an independent journalist and she's got
a journalist fellowship with this thing, right? So, she's she's
being paid to be an independent journalist by a company that
does that. Um you could argue that maybe because but she discloses
it, right? So she discloses it. So I don't know if this is quite
the same thing, but even with the disclosure, you could easily
argue that she shouldn't be handling any story that has to do
with Pier Midar, right? I think you could easily argue that.
Yeah. Taylor just can't write about Piro Midiar. If there's a
negative piece, if there's a positive piece, she actually has
a conflict there. She shouldn't talk about Pi Midiar. She's talking
about news organizations and their employees. Yes. >> Well,
I think like you can talk about it, but you're supposed to disclose
the bias,
right? >> Sure. I would say that probably as a journalist,
she probably shouldn't talk about it. She does disclose that
she's funded by this group, but I would say define independent
journalist, not employed, unemployed journalist, somebody with
a journalist degree that has worked as a journalist at major
publications, but is currently unemployed and writing their own
stories under their own like title.
>> Yeah. It's like selfmployed.
>> I need to go and look at define employed. Sure. I Okay,
I know it was a reply. I'm just going to hit a speech somewhere
or something like that. They would have to disclose all of that.
That's a legal thing. Or is that >> Fox? I don't know.
Fox News does not have the same editorial standards as a lot
of other mainstream media places. >> when you say editorial
standards, that implies it's not a legal thing. You're just talking
about like some standard or accepted practice of some companies.
>> So, when we're talking about mainstream traditional
reporting, and I mean maybe I should say reputable reporting
because I don't think Fox News has a great track record on reputable
reporting, but if you look at the mainstream media places, even
like CNN, I hate CNN, right? But CNN, New York Times, where I
worked, um, and other places, the Wall Street Journal, all these
other mainstream media outlets, Wired, they do have these clauses
where no, you cannot take outside money. You cannot do undisclosed
things. Is it is it just me or is it so weird?
Hearing a bunch of liberals after Trump, okay, talking about
how norms don't really have to be respected. We should only respect
what the law is. Like I thought this was the argument against
Trump was he was destroying a bunch of norms that while not codified
in the law specifically while maybe not totally illegal. It's
like obviously these are foundational to the way things work
and like trusting organizations,
>> It's actually not it's not weird to me. It's not surprising
as much as they complain about the leftist being like nihilist
and giving up or whatever. Um, a lot of liberals have have like
a sense of like defeatism
and just want to be as fascistic as
>> Yeah. I mean, I think that might be an underlying I
don't want to quite play this as fascistic necessarily, but I
know what you mean that like in general that that's what the
vibe is going, right? They just want to they basically are like,
>> "Yeah, yeah, like this isn't there. >> At least
we're not Trump. We >> turned on. >> We need to do
some of the Yeah, we need to do some of the bad things, but like
at least we're not Trump. it once. What? Dude, Ally said it exactly.
Remember when she in the TikTok where she's like, "Listen, once
we take power, okay, we'll change the rules and everything will
be better again." >> Yeah. Yeah. When did that when did
that go wrong? >> Yeah. That's a That's a historical story
that ends well right there. Then it turns then it turns out you
just got like Baron Trump is sitting there right beside that
girl. Okay. Ready to like, you know what happens to the naive
like but altruistic leader of a socialist movement, right? or
whatever. Once they gain power, they gain all the power. They're
going to fix everything and then the psy the four psychopaths
behind them like them in the back and you get stolen. Okay, it's
over.
You cannot uh do sponsorship deals on the side or uh you know
certainly not take money from a political group that would you
would be fired immediately and never hired again if you took
undisclosed money from a political group and didn't talk about
that. So I I I think that that's a level of transparency that
actually most news consumers aren't aware of. They they never
realized often that that was even something that like you know
that there >> salivation salvation. Thank you very much
for the gifted sub to scrubs. Appreciate you buddy. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you. >> Are these editorial standards
sort of behind the scenes? And I think as we move towards a more
content creator driven ecosystem, it's good to have these conversations
of what should be disclosed and when, right? I think I could
agree with that. I actually I think there should be hardcore
disclosure standards enforced and anybody that calls themselves
media alternative or otherwise. But I didn't see any recommendations
for that. It seemed like I think coming away from the article,
the takeaway is just that this course and 1630 fund are operating
in some like especially nefarious or bad way. Especially because
I think you had at least two quoted people who were claiming
that they were illegally murky at best or were being used to
evade FC restrictions. The um Duboir quote. >> That's what
their lawyer said. Yeah, their lawyer said that. I I think >> Wait,
wait, no, wait. The lawyer just was explaining the law that that's
the the thing that the >> he's saying there is no lack
of disclosure. He's not saying like hey guys the rules exist
and we're thwarting them. He's saying guys you don't have to
worry about these rules cuz we're a nonprofit. We you know we're
we're structured in this way where don't worry you don't have
to worry about blah blah blah disclosure. So I think this goes
back to the to to the crux of the problem which is that we have
an FEC that's asleep at the wheel. And I think no matter where
you are on the political spectrum, although actually no, if you're
on the right, you don't give a [__] about disclosure.
But if you're obviously I think that we can definitely >> She's
like relentlessly hugging this guy and he wants to like beat
her to death and she's just like relentlessly hugging him being
like, "We're on the same side, man. I love you. I I love you.
I love you. Uh uh the right, those guys suck. The right sucks
so badly, actually. God, the right doesn't care about disclosure.
Those guys are totally unethical." And he's like, "No, I'm trying
to get you. Shut up. Stop, stop hugging me. >> Fight over
how um you know C4s are >> at least acknowledge it, right?
We want
the articles the articles we should push these companies to acknowledge
it. >> The articles seem to explicitly target chorus as
being exceptionally bad here. So like for the for the Elizabeth
Dubois quote you had, you were saying that the legal aspects
were murky. Well, the legal aspects aren't murky. They're they're
pretty clear. It's just that the legal aspects right now suck,
right? the FC guidelines that we have on the >> No, I I
think they're explicitly
they're explicitly trying to set up an electioneering outlet
like something that supports electioneering 100%. And give money
to people who do electioneering on their side while never letting
them say that they're doing electioneering with any of that money
to try to get around the fact that they're clearly trying to
fund electioneering. Like I think they're >> I don't know.
>> All right, go ahead. >> I'm sorry. No, no, finish.
You don't know that what >> I was just gonna say the same
I was just going to repeat myself that like it's just very clearly
about funding people who are going to do electioneering for Democrats
and they're trying to get around that and I'm not even against
that. But it's like then it's like dude the the we're not trying
to do anything murky with the law. Yes, you are. Shut up. Just
shut the [__] up. Okay. Admit it. Admit that you're
trying to do >> It's it's just the saying, "Oh, this isn't
murky." is one thing, but then saying the law is very clear
when everyone's acknowledging this is a
Right. It It's supposed to be something that we weed out in law,
but there's a loophole that allows you to do it. That's not clear.
>> Yeah. Exactly. And I'm just I'm going to keep saying
it cuz I feel like it's really important. Okay. That when you
do get caught like doing this loophole, don't try to slander
the people who caught you. Just like issue a statement and duck
your head down like a good dark money organization does. Okay?
Duck your head down. Shut the [__] up and do your
that you're shadowy. Okay? and help liberals or or leftists win
elections.
Like, okay, but don't go and try to moralize and go, you guys
hate the Democratic party. You guys want Trump to be president
forever. Don't do that. Shut the up. Put your head down, okay?
And do your do your shadowy in the shadows. I just I You don't
get to do both, right? You don't get to come out and and try
to like get all the brownie points and then when people are like,
"Oh, this seems like concern. This seems like you guys are doing
a loophole." Yo, what do you what do you want Republicans to
win? No. Come on. Come on. You brought all this to light. Uh
I think Taylor's been reporting on this group for a couple months
now. And by the way, I'm not against them using those loopholes.
I'm just against them like totally trying to attack people who
point out that they're using the
This is in no way a loophole. Okay, internet ray, find me, the
creator that you know is a part of this program that does not
engage in electioneering.
If every single person you fund, you are explicitly saying we
we have we can't have you say you're going to do something electioneering
with our name on it because we'll get caught. But every single
one of them does it. You know they do it and you have to put
a contract provision in to prevent them from doing it with your
name attached. Right? That's that it's very obvious what you're
trying to do. That is literally a loophole. Come on. >> This
isn't a loophole. Look, I got this this one pro Palestinian person.
What are you talking about? >> It's crazy. The IRS guidelines
kind of >> Yeah. Yeah. It's it's just crazy >> for
this. So, it's not that the but the >> if you were to read
FC guidelines that we have on this and the IRS guidelines kind
of suck for this. So, it's not that the but the if you were to
read that the legal aspect is murky at best. It makes it sound
like Chorus is the one who >> So, when I reached out to
the FTC Yes. Well, I think what is murky is
what what crosses over to sponsored content? What crosses over
to some of this? So, I reached out to the FC and the FTC about
this. And I actually spoke to the former uh a former FTC person
at length about about this exact topic because the FTC doesn't
really cover political content, but people were
there's there's some commercial activity where they feel like
it can maybe some some disclosure requirements can apply and
all this stuff. The point is is that like I don't fault or rather
I I think a lot of creators in this program are well-meaning
and I I've said from the beginning I don't think it's necessarily
helpful to go around doing a witch hunt of hey you took the money
you didn't take the money you did this close whatever the reason
that we have this story is because creators in the program themselves
were uncomfortable with this I think >> why is it for why
is it then like you because you painstakingly go out to like
name creators and their platforms that are associated with it.
Sure, we included the ones that are that are relevant, right?
That that we think people should know and I wish that we could
include more. I if I if it were up to me, we would publish the
whole thing because I think people deserve to know. Well, I think
people deserve to know who are getting who's who's getting money
without disclosure, right? We want people to know who's getting
money without disclosure. >> The disclosure is not legally
required, though. And the >> It's not That's the problem.
It's not legally required. >> She's she's describing her
ethical preference.
She's repeatedly described her ethical preference. And in fact,
I
It's weird to go like, "Wait, you agree that there's no problem
with the law?" And she's like, "Yeah, but wouldn't you want that
law to change?" And he's like, "Yeah, but you agree there's no
problem with the law." And she's like, "Yeah, but wouldn't you
want that law to change? Wouldn't you rather it be this way?"
It's like, how many times can they loop on the same thing? >> Argument
to make illegally require there's just a targeting of this particular
organization acting like they're like in some special.
>> what this organization did is is not value transparency.
So there are other organizations similar to chorus that do value
transparency
um that that are nonprofits in this space that value transparency
and they say listen listen we're running ironically you know
we're running this uh this paid uh thing for this political you
know we're running this like political effort for whatever I
don't know whatever sort of political message they're pushing
we value disclosure we want to make sure that you make it clear
that you're you know that you have a relationship with us or
whatever whatever so a paid relationship so I think the the what
I would is kind of a witch hunt then though, right? Like if the
goal is to out every creator involved in this particular thing,
the goal is to witch hunt them out of this program, right? >> Not
out of the program. What we want is we want these companies like
Chorus to
>> I thought this was the So this is um it's funny cuz
she's actually taking the Pisco approach here, right, Jerry?
You remember watching Pisco? He was saying that he doesn't think
there should be a law or anything. It's like you should socially
pressure people, right, into doing these things that are ethical.
>> It's just it's so strange. I I feel like she just said,
"What I'm not doing is this." And then his immediate response
is, "Okay, so you are doing this." >> like we're not this
isn't a witch hunt. And then he's like, "Oh, but you're doing
a witch hunt." >> Well, I think yeah, he accused her of
a witch hunt and she's like, "No, no, no." But I think there's
like a public interest in knowing and disclosing and she the
the witch hunt is like he's saying witch hunt them out of the
program. I think she's saying, and again, if this truly isn't
changing your content and you truly like don't you don't have
any problem with like, you know, acting ethically, is it a problem
to disclose? Is there a downside to disclosing? What is the downside
to disclosing that people don't want to? I actually don't know.
>> Can you rewind it back? >> Yeah. paid. Uh, >> what's
the Wait, before you play it, explain the the Pisco thing >> that
you um >> like
repercussions or like reputational
>> No, no, no. Well, I guess it could lead to reputational
damage, but it was like we should all say that this is the standard,
the standard we all want to see and you should feel like like
we should encourage socially people to follow this standard,
right? >> Yeah. Uh, yep. >> Okay. Okay. >> That
was the Pisco thing. Sorry, I just read I the real Dr. Cube like
hasn't watched any of this and it's like crazy that he asks the
same questions that I've answered like a hundred times. I don't
know. I I'm going to let someone else answer that for you. The
real Dr. Cube and the >> It's not That's the problem. It's
not legally required. >> There's no argument to make it
legally required. There's just a targeting of this particular
organization acting like they're like in some special organization.
Well, >> what this organization did is is not value transparency.
So there are other organizations similar to Chorus that do value
transparency
um that that are nonprofits in this space that value transparency
and they say listen listen we're running ironically you know
we're running this u this paid uh thing for this political you
know we're running this like political effort for whatever I
don't know whatever sort of political message they're pushing
we value disclosure we want to make sure that you make it clear
that you're you know that you have a relationship with us or
whatever whatever so a paid relationship so I think the the what
I would is kind of a witch hunt then though, right? Like if the
goal is to out every creator involved in this particular thing
to witch hunt all >> a sudden transparency is called a
witch hunt because she said she's literally not looking to to
do that. >> Yeah, I think she's stating her ethical preference,
right? And he's like, "Oh, what what he stated already, what
I believe he said explicitly, him or possibly Loner Box, but
I think it was him. Uh, I think he said explicitly he thinks
that Taylor Loren publishes their identities to try to get them
harassed. And she's saying, "This is my ethical preference. I
don't think you should be allowed to take money from a political
thing." And she said, "I would have wanted to just publish everybody's
name that we had." And and apparently Wired said, "No, no, no.
Probably just people who have like either talked about this in
the past or they've like defended this or whatever." Right. >> But
she's saying my ethical preference is publish all of them. >> Go
ahead. >> It does not make sense. It is like supposed to
be the whole Democrats thing is to point out that people on the
right are bought, that they're grifting, and you need to know
who's funding what politician. They're paid for by big oil. They're
paid for by Elon Musk. That if that is your platform, why the
[__] is it now a witch hunt to want transparency
from those same creators? >> Yeah. I don't I >> It's
like holding them to their own standard. It's so using the word
witch hunt is just I feel like that's
>> I think um I think in this case he's basically saying
he thinks she's lying, right? Like that by publishing them all,
they get harassed. >> No, I don't. >> No, I don't
think she's li I don't think he believes that she's lying. I
think he knows she's on point. I think he knows that she has
a point. And that's why he has to use loaded language like witch
hunt to signal out to people, oh, witch hunt, that's bad.
like people shut their brains off and just think, "Yeah, witch,
I'm bad." >> Yeah. Let me uh let me run this back for Kogen
Style here who says she said she wants every creator involved
with Chorus to be known to the public. >> Yeah. She wants
anybody taking money from a political organization to have to
disclose that, right? I think that is basically from what I've
seen anybody who's taking like a contractual obligation to like
sorry if they're entering into a contract where they have obligations
for some amount of money from a political organization wanting
that disclosed is probably the majority opinion from what I've
seen maybe up until this point where Taylor Lawrence wrote this
article. This is where I I expected to to diverge because Assan's
on one side, Destiny's on the other. So, I'm expecting a lot
of people to diverge away from what their stated preference was
before, but >> yes, that is not her calling out the creators.
If she if her whole article is like, "Hey, this company course
makes it that so that creators can't do the thing that I think
that I think is healthy and beneficial and authentic for these
creators to do. It's it's literally to complain about the company
that has maybe something in their contract that's preventing
creators from making that decision themselves." >> Yep.
Yeah, exactly. I So Destiny's calling it a witch hunt because
she stated her ethical preference like and she's said I think
her ethics are disclosed this whole time. She just keeps repeating,
yeah, obviously I think it's e I think you should disclose that.
I think it should be a rule to disclose that. So downstream of
her stated positions already, you know, that she wants all of
these people disclosed, right? And she said that's her preference.
So saying that's a witch hunt, it seems like they're just ignoring
what she's expressed as her like ethical preference already to
to just say, "Well, no, wanting their names published is a witch
hunt." But it's it's not by definition, right? If you think people
should, which by the way is Pisco's opinion, Erin's opinion,
my opinion, almost everybody I can think of, it's their opinion
that if you sign a contract with somebody that's a political
organization, you're taking a significant amount of funding from
them, you should disclose that >> if you're saying you
should disclose, you should disclose is a lot different than
saying I want their name on a list and published.
saying you should disclose and then pointing to a uh organization
that prevents them from making that decision themselves. I I
just I don't understand in what way anything she did was a witch
hunt. >> Yeah. I think it's it's just loading in when she
said my preference would be to disclose everybody. That's like
oh it's a witch hunt so you can go after all of them, right?
And that's that's a line I've heard from echoed by as well that
like if you disclose this you'll just be hunted down which like
I don't know what that looks like. I think it's like two or three.
Listen, if I could swap with any of these guys and just have
instead of unhinged DJers in my Twitter comments, if I could
just have uh Hassanabi like leftists in my Twitter comments,
I would I would make that trade 10 every single day of the week.
Okay, give me all of the unhinged people who are mad about Chorus.
I'll take every single one of them over any of these DJers who
are just like weirdos. Okay, I automatic easy decision. Okay,
>> not out of the program. What we want is we want these
companies like Chorus to to
prioritize and center disclosure. And in fact, Stephen, what
they have shown is that they continue to double down on lack
of disclosure. They still will not publish the full list of creators.
They still won't release these creators from their NDA. There
are creators right now that want to speak publicly but are not
able to. And there are creators >> I feel like people So
many people have
>> I is he about to say wait who wants to speak publicly
but can't? >> I feel like he was about to say that >> gone
live and spoken publicly about this. That seems hard. >> No
no no they haven't. They've go they've gone live and they've
spoken only in the way that they're allowed to about chorus specifically,
but they're not speaking publicly about the sort of the nature
of these other programs or sorry the n the I can't speak the
paid nature of the program and so what I think that chorus should
>> just to be clear there have been people who have literally
made videos saying they get paid by chorus they're in chorus
who are >> now they have yes now they have >> after
the article came out yes which again I'm I'm guessing those people
I wonder if any of those people asked for express written consent.
They were named in the article. So I'm guessing that like Chorus
has basically said, "Yeah, we don't really care, right?"
Has anybody who was not named explicitly in the article come
forward and said, "I'm getting paid by Chorus right now." I'm
just curious if anyone cuz as far as I can remember, the two
legit two real two legit guy uh Booker Squared, Ali O'Brien,
those three were all named. Um, Brian Teller Cohen's response
to all of this, I think, should qualify as expressed uh, consent
to talk about. >> I Yeah, I think he give it. >> Yeah,
I think he can't give it. He doesn't have that authority. Yeah.
>> Or do you think he's not one of the authorized people?
>> I don't think he could. I think he could make it happen.
I don't think he has the ability. I don't think he's running
the organization at that level to say you can be released. >> I
doubt it. Yeah, I totally doubt it. >> I was saying they
get paid by Chorus. They were in Chorus. Who are >> now
they have? Yes. Now they have. Yes. Yes. But they're not talking
about the aspects of the sort of non-disclosure. And that what
I think would be valuable is for Chorus to say, "Listen, we value
transparency. We realize that this program was >> Hold
on. I just had to I This is probably the last Loki Coco message
I like pull up on stream at least for a couple days. But it's
in a way similar to Candace. Taylor Loren hides via ignorance
of the audience in order to suggest Macron's wife is a man."
No. This is maybe the most statement you've made so far. >> Candace
provides no factual basis for her opinions at all. You can easily
call her out on this. Taylor Loren has an article full of factually
like like cited facts that nobody has disputed. I don't know.
I don't know why you'd say something that stupid. It's beyond
me.
he's not going to read your chats out loud, but still type them.
I'm going to read them quietly to myself. Keep going. was not
maybe as transparent as it should have been starting out. We
want >> should have been according to to you, >> Well,
according to every ethics expert that we ask in media and I think
according to what the public expects from creators, which is
a level of transparency where if you're going to take money from
a political group for political purposes, you should disclose
that. And so I think what Chorus could do to set a good example
and to you know to help build a more transparent political media
ecosystem which I think we all want if we're somewhat on the
left we want more transparent you know ecosystem in political
media say like hey guys you are free to talk about this and that's
what I'm saying like I was surprised that they didn't announce
the program because even now they still >> well they did
they have announced I think Brian Telquin and I think David Pacman
months ago announced that they were starting this program right?
No, no, they didn't announce anything about the 1630 fund or
any of the funding stuff. They announced that they were doing
the the public facing program. Sure. That's never been a secret.
That's on the website, but this this private uh paid program
has not was not announced. So, of course, now it's all public
since I've reported on it. But >> so, this from what I
can remember, this would be where the Pisc argument would come
in where Brian said, "We're going to give resources. were going
to pay like editors and like you could maybe say he had some
aspirations to pay people eventually, but there was no public
announcement of them going to pay people going from the non-paid
to the >> Didn't they have like the application thing like
on the website? You could apply to join course if you wanted
to. >> You could apply to join the public thing, but you
were you you that wasn't the same as this like paid
thing which is private. So of course they're soliciting creators
for it. I talked to there's one creator in the story, right,
that who's quoted, who applied for it, who heard about it. It
was spreading around like creators themselves were sort of talking
about it. But I think we need a lot more transparency. Another
thing that we >> wouldn't if the if the maximum transparency
was like the goal. I feel like the easiest thing would then just
to be the publish the contract, which if you've gotten several
of them, you can you can see well, but why don't you do it? You're
the one who wrote the story. I work at >> so uh to me I
would just say I the journalistic the organization that's built
up the the trust can be trusted right that's wired we don't we
don't need everybody else to publish just get chorus I chorus
are the people who could just publish this now I don't understand
why that isn't happening why wouldn't just be calling on chorus
to publish the contracts I call on both sides to publish the
contracts but I understand why Wired feels like they can chorus
could publish it without the ethical concern that Wy has right
Like Wired has stated an ethical concern. Chorus has stated no
such ethical concern. It's it's just obvious, right? >> Wire
I I work for Wired and unfortunately they you know that is their
stance of not publishing the source material because they are
concerned about you know potentially identifying stuff. I'm >> with
tell you explicitly on this story that you were not allowed to
publish. That was Wired's decision and not yours that you weren't
allowed to publish. >> We've made the decision that we're
not going to publish the source material. >> Well, of course
I know you've made that decision because it has isn't published.
But I'm asking, >> wait, he's saying that Wired said that
or sorry, she's saying that Wyatt said that. I think he just
misunderstood. >> Was it Wired that prohibited? >> I'm
willing to go back. I'm willing to go back and and have a conversation
with the lawyer about it again. Um, but what I would say, Stephen,
is that >> he just misunderstood. She was quoting Wired
that Wired told her, "We've decided not to publish any of the
source
>> Brian Tyler Cohen >> is a stakeholder in chorus.
If he feels that this story is false, he could we don't even
have to do it publicly, right? He could go to Wired and say,
"Here's the actual contract. Here's the EV. Here's the proof
that shows that your story is wrong." And Wired would correct
it. And Wired has not received any proof from any of these creators
privately that it's wrong. And so we, you know, wired >> I
just love that, you know, I have to I have to I realize this
whole thing is like a monument to my ego and stuff, okay? But
I just have to shout myself out because this is the same response
I've made to everybody and I don't get a response back from anybody
when I bring it up except Stale being like an actual glue eater
on Twitter. Okay. Yeah. Wired has put their name on it. They've
put their reputation behind it. It's clear that they said they
didn't say, you know, the author has viewed these contracts.
They said the wired editorial staff has viewed these contracts.
Why would they stamp that with their seal of approval, their
reputation if it weren't that way?
>> So, god damn it. Thank you. >> It doesn't need
to post like receipts or whatever to to stand by their reporting.
And what I would say to these creators is if you going >> Oh,
I'll also I'll also just point out that Taylor Loren liked all
of those tweets. Taylor Loren liked all of those tweets. She
read those tweets. She's aware of those tweets. Okay. So, I'm
just going to say Taylor Loren, copy my talking points before
she came to this >> To continue to say that it's a lie
publicly, then at least provide proof to, you know, the company
privately to get a correction on the story. There's not a single
correction on the story. And trust me, they would put a correction
on the story. If we had proof myself, I I mean, I hold myself
to standards. Like, I would love to see proof, you know, that
they that they like, "Hey guys, like all those contracts, everything
else you got, all the Zoom meeting, that's all fake, whatever,
whatever." or you know like this something else refutes it like
sure but they haven't provided any of that proof privately or
publicly and I think that's because
they don't actually care I'm speculating here but it seems to
me that it's easier for them to respond to a story like this
instead of you know making it about discussions around transparency
it seems to me that what they instead want to do is or what they
have done is do all of these silly personal attacks accusing
me of being friends with Tucker Carlson or other nonsense like
this. I don't know if you've seen this online, but this is what
Brian Tyler Cohen responded. >> He said Candace Owens.
Why does she refer to the white man? Why not the black woman?
>> Oh, I see. He said both, right? But yes. >> Yeah,
he said Candace first. >> I I'm I'm shocked that she finds
Tucker more repulsive than Candace. I feel like Candace is easily
worse. But >> listen, she's trying not to be accused of
targeting black people anymore. Okay, there's an accusation that
she's been targeting black people. She's just trying to color
within the lines. Oh, here it is.
>> I'm I am a black for Taylor Loren. >> Boom. There
it is. Likes Taylor. >> That's on this tweet right here.
Uh, hold on. That's on this tweet right here. Boom. Proof. Proven.
Okay. She's reading. She was reading. She was >> Let me
ask you. >> Let's go. Go ahead. >> Now, this is like
my cynical mind. Is there any world in which Chorus loves this
attention? >> Oh yeah. >> Loves this advertising
and they're going to draw it out for a couple weeks until they're
like, "Oh, we can show contracts. Okay, here's the contract here.
Now that I've gotten like three weeks of press
here and now issue all of the retractions and now I get to call
this person a dumb bitch." >> Uh, yep. They could be trying
to do that. But I mean, >> I think that that would be malicious
beyond belief.
And
yeah, I I constantly refer to when Jay-Z
uh hit Piers Morgan, like the same day, and Piers Morgan issued
a retraction the next day, the moment Jay-Z thought that he was
being possibly being defamed from something that aired on his
uh YouTube show. >> Yeah, I would say it looks to me it
would look really bad if that's what they were doing. Yeah, that
would look really bad if they if they at this point had not decided.
Like I think at this point they were asked for comment. They
haven't done anything. Their lawyer did comment a little bit,
but they've just been fighting the whole way. I feel like if
they had if they felt like this was fraud, they could have at
least claimed as much without claiming anything and just like
trying to let this go by and not not claiming anything. I think
it looks weird if they were to come out and say like actually
this was all a lie. But I don't know, maybe maybe
I it would look really weird to me. Very concerning to me >> doing.
And they've also been saying things are >> here I'm I'm
rolling this back just a little bit >> of discussions around
transparency. It seems to me that what they instead want to do
is or what they have done is do all of these silly personal attacks
accusing me of being friends with Tucker Carlson or other nonsense
like this. I don't know if you've seen this online but this is
what Brian Tyler Cohen responded doing. And they've also been
saying things that aren't >> I think he released a 5-minute
video and I think like 3 seconds of that was related to that.
But the rest of that video was responding.
listen, he only like totally maliciously tried to slander you,
tried to use this like webbing to destroy your reputation, to
harm your reputation. He only tried to do that for like 3 seconds.
Okay, listen. What's wrong with a I I don't know how you could
possibly be mad at her for her article if you're like, well,
just a little just a little bit of defamation in there. There's
a little bit of like slander in there. >> This article
is like a 3minut read. She only she only defamed you for 3 minutes,
>> That's uh that's crazy.
>> The rest of the thing was him refuting a whole bunch
of the claims that were made in the article. He didn't show the
contract on screen, which I guess is what he >> didn't
show any proof of what it Yeah. He didn't show any proof of anything
that he claimed. He also >> But you also haven't shown
any proof of any thing that you're claiming either other than
>> journalist that published it in Wired magazine. if he
wants to go and >> but you also chose not to publish the
contract. That was your individual >> Again, it is published.
My reporting is published and wired. You're right. I could have
gone on Twitter months ago and said, "Hey guys, scoop twitter.com.
I'm going to publish receipts." Like this is what a lot of people
are used >> True. You keep saying receipts like it's a
social media term, but that's not true, right? If you write No.
Absolutely. Dude, did we ever see like I feel like for a lot
of the Harvey Weinstein stuff, we didn't see I think I guess
that goes to a court. So, I guess maybe it's a little different.
I'm just I'm trying to think like this is absolutely the the
standard for journalists. This is like by for a bunch of the
Trump reporting. This was literally for a bunch of the Trump
reporting how it operated, right? Based on a private source,
based on a private >> This is MAGA. This is what it is
to become MAGA, right? >> This is like attacking the institutions.
>> this is 2016. Oh, this is alternative facts. The mainstream
media lies to you. The fake news. And it's like, okay, am I supposed
to believe your alternative media? Am I supposed to believe your
independent media sources that don't qualify anything?
Um, >> well, and if it wasn't something if it wasn't something
that both sides had access to, right, that either side could
produce, but one side has expressed an ethical concern for producing
it, right, and the other hasn't, then I don't understand why
you don't go. Just because you're on Brian Tyler Cohen's side,
just because you're on Chorus's side, doesn't mean you shouldn't
say, "Hey, Chorus, you could just release this, right?" This
like this is like uh knowing for a fact that Trump has a copy
of the Pape and like what they're calling a Pape and he won't
play it for you. Could you imagine how Desi would react if you
knew for a fact there are two copies of the same tape that some
people say is Trump like peeing on a bed or paying prostitutes
to pee on a bed and Trump won't give it to anybody and he's like,
"No, no, it's all lies." Wait, but you have the tape right there.
Yeah, but I'm not I'm not putting that out there. Could you imagine?
>> Yeah, it seems to mean something. Like people keep qualifying
like, "Hey, it's this isn't just Taylor Loren. Take your bias
against her out of the picture because this went through editorial
approval,
right? And so you're disregarding Wired. You're disregarding
like an editorial process and saying, "Oh, well, you showed as
much evidence as Brian Tyler Cohen and his like five minute video
that just debunked you." >> Yeah, it's >> that's
not on the same page at all. >> It's not. Yeah, it's not.
There's not a third party institution backing up Brian Tyler
Cohen's things. There there just isn't. So, uh Yeah, dude. It's
uh it's just bizarre. And the funny thing is is let's say let's
say they do actually publish and they say they actually go for
a retraction. They say here's proof that the contracts are different.
Uh everything I'm saying here or we're saying here is still correct.
Like if Wired publishes a retraction, I'm totally comfortable
saying that's a retraction and that's fine. But every the way
everybody's acting is just insane. It's it's literally just acting
like MAGA and and it's not going to change. Even if you found
out you were correct, it's not going to change based on the information
we have now. She's saying
she's saying if he he could get a retraction, he could get a
correction. It doesn't even have to be public. He doesn't publicly
have to publish their contracts. You send it to Wired, they will
keep it confidential and they'll issue a retraction.
>> What's so difficult about that? >> They're not
even attempting anything. Uh they're not even attempting it.
It's a Oh, it's just weird. It's just It's I I feel like I'm
taking crazy pills, you
There are absolutely stories that are published where tons of
information is is released. >> Hold on. Tons of information
is released. Okay. She's literally giving you her reason for
not releasing stuff here. And she said it's not our decision.
Wrong tweet. Okay. >> Right. No. Absolutely. There are
absolutely stories that are published where tons of information
is is >> Sometimes the source material sometimes the source
material is released publicly. sometimes in certain instances
and there is a whole >> so uh story right off the top of
my head. Okay, the signal leaks I believe with the signal leaks
that they didn't actually publish everything right away. They
published some quotes and some innuendo and I believe the White
House basically went, "No, Jeffrey Goldberg's a liar. Jeffrey
Goldberg's a lying son of a [__] Don't believe him.
That guy's a total loser. Don't believe that guy." And he goes,
"Well, [__] it." Like, I don't know. I guess I have
to publish this [__] right? And then they published
actual parts of the conversation. No, I don't believe in the
initial in the initial article. I don't believe full screenshots
were published. Real Dr. Cube. Certainly not of like some of
the more sensitive stuff that they did publish later. There was
like a two-stage thing where where the government or sorry the
White House was like trying to slander him, right? But it's like
I don't know. I I just I just kind of trust institutions, you
know? That's how I feel. It's crazy. It's crazy that trusting
institutions is like a a baffling like insane opinion
>> Having your entire movement be about,
you know, building up trust in the institutions again and then
the moment the moment it's inconvenient to just throw that out
is ridiculous, >> dude. I Wick TV bane of Christian nationalists.
The burden of proof is on them to disprove our claims. Quoting
at Taylor Loren.
What? No, you have to prove what you're saying is true. you have
not done so. Show us the evidence or retract.
>> I just th this doesn't make any sense cuz you understand
the the reason behind not wanting to be somebody
uh who let's say blows the whistle on this and feels like if
it's publicly known that I'm the person who is exposing this,
it's kind of going to ruin my political career for maybe the
next year or two, which probably will just put it dead in the
water. And I'm like trying to do the right thing. >> Yeah.
Well, it could certainly blow a hole in all of your networking.
Yeah.
>> Yes. Exactly. And all of these people are like, "Tell
us who the niche is right now. Tell who the not saying something.
Show me the contract. Who's speaking? Tell me." >> Yeah.
It's I uh
>> Tell me who's blue no matter who. Tell me. Tell me who
the op is. Who's sus? Like jeez. >> Wait, hold on a second.
Wait. Do me help dare I get her channel back? Okay. Well, you
know what? I've uh I've got a new Cabal friend who's got the
ability to help me. Yeah. Yeah. Got a new Cabal member. Okay,
>> dude. If the Cabal gets the JTO YouTube channel unbanned,
uh I'm just I'm going to agree with Destiny suddenly. Oh my god.
There's any this this Cabal could can do anything. >> Can't
accomplish anything. >> Look at the clip. I don't know
if I believe the clip that she's saying is the reason it got
hit, but it looks like she was just reported on a clip that did
not warrant reporting like at all. >> It says hate speech
and there's no way it's hate speech. >> Interesting. Um
I will we can look at it. I do want to get through the interview
first, but we can totally get through it. >> Oh, it's not
even interesting. I'm just like letting you know in case you
get your hopes up. >> It just >> that it would be
interesting. It was just nothing. That's what I figured cuz honestly
there's just not a lot of um there's like not a lot of things
that she says that are like hate speech. Like the thing I joked
about though, what would have been really funny to me and I think
you'd agree with this is if she got hit for saying she's a and
she's allowed to use >> the word wasn't even in there.
It was like red pill men woman internet
like I didn't find a single slur >> unlucky.
This is where anonymity can't be guaranteed. But in an instance
where you've received multiple contracts, you can compare the
contracts from one to another to verify that the language is
unique from one to the other. You very easily can publish an
entire contract without damaging any of the individual creators,
right? >> No. So what we can't confirm, Stephen, and this
might be what you're getting stuck up on and confused on is that
we can't confirm. We we we just can't confirm. We haven't seen
the rest. Like we can't confirm what is identifying and what
is not unless we saw all the contracts, right? We just don't
know. And to and there's no reason for us to do that when our
reporting has not been challenged. If our reporting has challenged
reporting, they just haven't published their contract.
>> No, they they hold on. Chorus, I do not believe Chorus
has published a statement saying what is wrong and they have
not reached out to Wired to challenge the reporting. And Destiny
understands um statements made on Twitter versus statements made
in official forum. Okay, with with journalism that is through
the mail, through email, okay, you could actually officially
contact these people and say, "I am demanding a retraction on
the record." Okay, like with you right now and demanding a retraction.
Here's my evidence. [__] you. Right? And Destiny
understands this when it comes to his court cases that statements
made on Twitter are not the same. You can go on Twitter and say
anything. But if you're going to actually officially demand a
retraction, right, and do some legal action or or not even do
legal action, but officially demand a retraction and say, "Here's
my proof." Then that's a way different element, right? You're
you're operating in a way different field there. Put it on the
record. Chorus as a company sends I I would even say send a what
do you call it like a demand letter. Demand a retraction. Say
you'll be suing if they don't. Provide your evidence showing
that they're defaming you, that they're liabiling you, whatever
the
>> Well, yeah, but I mean like if if somebody says a thing,
somebody can refute a thing without >> Oh, I lied. Loki
Koko just asked another really question. Does Chorus need to
run uh to publish all of their legal contracts and documents
cuz some skit put out a vibes based article with dark money doing
all the heavy lifting? That's not what happened. And no, they
don't have to publish any of their contracts. They could start
with actually officially requesting a retraction from Wired on
the article and state what is incorrect about the reporting.
That's where they could start. They could start by actually disputing
any element of the article officially. That's where they could
start. They could they could also say they could send a demand
letter, actually go to litigation. >> Our reporting has
not been challenged. If our challenged reporting they just haven't
published their contract any >> facts without >> well
yeah but I mean like if somebody says a thing somebody can refute
a thing without publishing a thing either right >> I mean
Stephen what you're arguing is something that a lot of people
on the right argue which is that unless you publish this source
material in the way that I like it why should I believe anything
on wired.com has any editorial standards why should I believe
the wired
let's go >> the wired fact checkers the wired editors the
wired reporters Why should I believe any of that? I'm not going
to trust any of that. I'm only going to trust uh you know sort
of direct source >> Yeah, but I think that's a great thing
to some extent in that there are a lot of companies that do publish
a lot of the source material, right? I'm pretty sure W even I
think W even changed their standards to that where they don't
do conversations on background anymore. They assume that everything
is on the record when they're interviewing people. And I think
they make that explicitly clear. Um when >> wait on the
on the record or uh on background that's like totally different
from what you put in the article, right? That's saying you have
the option to put it in the article. That's completely different
from making the decision that you're going to not put it in the
article to keep the source safe, right? Okay. Even if he wasn't
lying about that, how would them saying that we don't have off
thereord conversations be equivalent to publishing all source
material for some piece they're doing? They're just saying, "We're
not going to let you make statements to us that color our reporting
that you're not willing to have us publish possibly versus we've
made this decision to we've made this decision to withhold certain
information for the safety or for some reason to help our sources."
Those are different conversations entirely.
I don't understand why
>> with spokespeople that might be. I don't >> Not
with spokespeople, with everybody. I think Wyatt has an editorial
standard now where they don't do one background anymore because
they want to be able to source people's names directly. They
don't want to have just have anonymous sources. They don't want
to rely on just a journalist claims things. >> I don't
know if that is true, Stephen. >> These aren't anonymous
sources, though. They're not claiming they're anonymous sources.
They're not revealing the sources, but they're not doing uh these
aren't anonymous sources at all. And if if you're saying that
they don't have um if they if they don't have if they have a
policy of not revealing sources to the public source, >> well,
yeah, if they have a if they have a policy of not revealing sources
or of having to reveal sources to the public, then how the article
get published? I don't I don't understand what he's even >> and
I would have to ask but I what I would say is the on background
stuff I'm generally also sympathetic to the idea I don't give
comms people the benefit of on background conversations like
there are reasons to do things on background versus not on background
all I will say is Stephen if you don't trust Wired's reporting
and if you don't trust their fact-checking process and you don't
trust the fact you know at that point there's there's nothing
that I just then I can't I can't help you because >> well
there's a really easy thing all you do is publish the contract
and that
>> Well, again,
Wired stood by their reporting. They could provide any evidence.
>> I know. You keep talking around this. It's very clever.
I understand. But like it was your choice ultimately to not publish
the contract. >> Yes. Because I don't you know that's projection
because he keeps asking for the same thing that she's qualified
over and over and over why she's not going to publish the contract.
>> Yeah. He knows exactly why. There is there is a party
here who does not have the ethical concern that Wired and Taylor
have. Right. that could publish the contract that won't then
not only will they not publish the contract, they won't even
privately send the contract to Wired to say, "Here's why you're
lying. Here's what the contract actually was." What's the Steelman
for not providing the contract? Honey Duckling, have you been
watching or are you talking about on on Chorus's side? >> No,
I could I could say the Steelman is
um You would say Chorus believes that they don't actually have
a whistleblower. Chorus believes that they are going off of hearsay.
They're going off of rumors and it completely went through the
editorial process and so they're not going to provide a contract
to I don't know to hand over for scrutiny cuz maybe there is
something wrong in there and it's not even what's in what the
story is about.
>> I actually don't think that that was a straw man. I
think I just created a worse scenario for Chorus.
dude, I
Oh, hold on. Yeah, okay. Joe, >> why? Because I don't want
to jeopardize my sources. And we had a lot of conversations and
I shared even a portion of the contract and even my source reached
out and was like, "Hey, I'm just not comfortable with this."
And we ultimately want to respect our sources right to, you know,
not be discovered, right to privacy. They're very scared right
now because there's a lot of legal threats that are going around
these sources. How could How could one single source even know
if you have multiple people who've shown you >> One single
source know what? >> How could one single source reach
out to you saying they were uncomfortable about some provision
of the contract that was shared? If multiple contracts have been
shared with you guys, how would they even know? >> I don't
understand what you're asking. >> You said that you published
something in your article and somebody reached out to you saying
they were worried about what you published. >> No, no,
no, not in the article. I I posted a small sliver of a screenshot
of a clause in the contract and we and I heard from one of my
sources that was like, "Hey, I'm really scared because they're
doing this legal there. They're we're scared of getting sued.
I just want to make sure that you're not going to share the cont."
>> I think does she mean on Twitter she posted like a sliver
of a screenshot or >> Because again, the conditions that
they shared it under is that it would not be posted all publicly
on the internet. that we would report on it and we would use
it for reporting material but we would not post it on twitter.com
which is the agreement that I made when I reported on this story
or when I initially now could I revisit it with them maybe I
I will try I've actually like I said I have fought so hard it's
ironic that you're pushing me on this cuz Stephen trust me I
have fought in every institution that I'm at to share more source
material I don't know if you remember my my uh interview with
libs of Tik Tok that interview was it actually in the context
of a 3500word story that I wrote totally separately that I think
a lot of people didn't read, but I knew that actually publishing
the source, the actual direct interview would would be the only
way that people could sort of like truly understand what this
woman had to say and that wouldn't where these quotes wouldn't
be taken out of context and such. So, I'm with you. I am totally
with you on the transparency there. >> You're saying this,
but in this particular case, I'm It sounds like why would be
okay with you publishing the contract, but you decided
>> No, first of all, I don't think they are okay with me
publishing source material. As far as I understand, that's not
something that we agreed to at all. >> I didn't say you
agreed to it, but you keep talking around this, but you you you
did you chose not to publish a contract. If you went back to
your editor right now and you said, "I usually think I want to
publish portions of this." You're telling me they would say no.
Why are you saying you signed an agreement saying that I wouldn't?
I signed an agreement saying that I wouldn't do that.
>> I'm with Wired that I agreed to report this stuff exclusively
for Wired. >> That's agreeing to report it exclusively
for Wire that you would give them the scoop on something is not
the same as agreeing that you wouldn't publish any source. No,
no, no. Stephen, Steven, please. I I know that you haven't freelanced
very much, but no. You The point is is that you >> Hold
on. I'm sorry. Just to be extremely clear, you're telling me
that you have a clause in your exclusive reporting on this with
Wired, a clause in your contract that says I will not publish
any of the source material >> in my article that I write
for this. >> Yeah. the what I signed on to, which is totally
standard in a lot of freelance
contracts, is that I wouldn't publish it, you know, that I wouldn't
publish uh that I would reserve all of my exclusive reporting
material for them. That means I'm not using it for a podcast.
That means I'm not using it for social media. Stephen, don't
interrupt. I signed a lot of these contracts and you're doing
this game. You're doing the game. If you keep interrupting me,
we're not going to have a conversation. >> I've signed
a lot of these contracts. Has Destiny signed a lot of contracts
to write freelance for for journalistic institutions? for like
actual publications. Oh, he signed a lot of NDA. Okay. >> Are
you going to let me finish speaking or are you going to keep
interrupting me? Please let me finish my thought before you interrupt
me again. >> Go for it. >> There are many reasons
why we're not publishing this material directly. All I can tell
you, you don't agree with many >> Yeah. Sorry. What Destiny
is trying to say is um I think that you he's trying to say I
think you could go to Wired and say actually I want to publish
everything and that Wired would allow it. I think she kind of
explicitly said otherwise earlier that like no Wired is also
in agreement that like they don't think it would be good to publish
these ar these uh documents and he's pushing on this from another
angle. I wonder if somebody from Wired is actually saying like
you should you you should publish this. It's possible there's
there's disagreement in their editorial staff >> of them
and you can litigate them with me all day and do debate stream
whatever whatever it is ultimately unproductive because the result
is the same which is that I am not publishing the direct source
material. Now, people can choose before you interrupt and freak
out, okay? People can choose to say, "Listen, I don't trust Wired.
I don't trust their fact checkers. I don't trust their legal
team. I don't trust whatever whatever." I'm sympathetic to that
because people don't trust the mainstream media. >> Do
you think Do you think she knows that Pixie uses whatever whatever
all the time? Do you think she knows that? And this is a secret
psychological attack. >> Does she? I don't even know that.
>> I'm pretty sure cuz Zena does it. I'm pretty sure Zena
and Pixie both do it. I think it's like a Florida person thing.
Uh, whatever. Whatever. >> Yeah. And whatever. Whatever.
And anyway, and whatever. Whatever. Yeah. I'm almost positive.
>> Choose to say, "Listen, I don't trust Wired. I don't
trust their fact checkers. I don't trust their legal team. I
don't trust whatever whatever." I'm sympathetic to that because
people don't trust the mainstream med. I hope I mean I hope this
isn't a low IQ thing because she kind of I'll be honest, the
way I'd expect any debate between Taylor Loren and Desi to go
before I watch this was Taylor Loren is like a tiny tiny like
goat kid, okay? Like a a goat uh like a baby goat, okay? And
Desi is like a Tyrannosaurus Rex. That's how I expected this
conversation to go. And if anything, like Taylor is doing better
than him. Like I don't think she's I don't think anybody's the
other person in this conversation, right? Goat kid. Yeah, I was
gonna say a kid, but then that made it sound weird. And so goat
kid then I was like baby goat is better. Okay. But yeah, I think
she's actually doing like better than him and which is just in
terms of contentious conversations.
I don't know what happened. This this guy got the yips or something.
What's going on >> media? But what I would say to those
people is that Wired does abide by standard journalistic practices.
And if Brian Tyler Cohen or any of these other people had provide
provided information not publicly but reached out to Wired with
information that counteracted the facts of the story or reached
out to me with information that disproved the facts of the story,
there would be a correction on the story. And so I welcome them
even still to provide any information privately. If they don't
want to do it publicly, they could still get corrections on the
story. They would just have to provide evidence that what we
reported was false. So far, they have not done that. Now listen,
you can disagree with this decision not to publish the contract
directly, but that is a decision that we made with that I made
with the sources and that I made with Wired when I agreed to
give this reporting to them instead of doing it online. And please,
you can critique me and disagree me with me on that, but it is
completely counterproductive to go around in circles and litigate
this over and over again when the end result is the is the same.
And it sounds like you disagree with that. And I'm sympathetic
to that disagreement because I have also been in these news rooms
where I've advocated repeatedly for us to put more things on
the internet. But that is what it is. >> Oh Jesus. They
talked for like another 40 minutes. I don't know where this conversation
goes. Like I feel like they got to the end of the conversation
here. Like they're litigating the very end of the conversation.
>> She takes or something. >> Oh, I see. >> And
so I guess we will just have to agree to disagree on that point.
There are a lot of other things related to this article that
I think are a lot more pertinent that we could be debunking that
we could be discussing and instead you just want to do this this
you know litigate this thing that is ultimately unproductive.
We are just going to fundamentally disagree and the result is
the same >> and I understand and that's fine. We can disagree
on this particular thing but um it's just in an article. >> I
love that she says it and he's like gonna fight against it but
she's just totally correct right like there's a whole institution
behind me. You've literally argued for institutionalism, trusting
institutions, backing institutions. I'm just going to keep pointing
out that you've flipped on your principles entirely to attack
me over this article that your principles don't matter one iota.
>> Well, why don't you just publish the
>> Yeah, exactly. Where it seems like you're advocating
for a maximalist approach to transparency that transcends even
what the law requires, right? which is that you want every single
content creator, influencer, talent agency, whatever, to be doing
these maximal disclosures about money going around, things that
exceed um what you even even Fox News wouldn't make these types
of disclosures. It's just interesting that in that same article,
you on your own made the choice not to publish the contract that
would easily resolve every single claim. Just to be clear that
when I say on your own, let you I let you go. You have to let
me finish. Okay? Because every time I ask you if you would have
published this, if you would publish the contract, you said you
>> framing Wired as a No, I think Wired is actually a rather
in respected journalistic institution at this point, Internet
Ray. But I do like that your your fallback here is to attack
the credibility of Wired itself. Hassan is bad knows no bounds.
keep saying we we we understand that you made decisions in conjunction
with your editor or whoever whoever you signed with to to release
this article for and then when I asked you about publishing the
contract you said you you went on to describe parts of your contract
and then you imply that I haven't seen Wired is owned by Kai
Naz which has been publishing since the early 1900s
damn these contracts. Um it sounds like I've seen just as many
if not more than you because I know exactly what you're describing
when you talk about not publish it anywhere else and you're just
talking about the exclusivity agreement that you had with Wired.
We're not talking at all about what you were allowed to publish
or the source material being published or not. You were just
explaining that you weren't allowed to publish that source material
on your Twitter or in any other place. That's just a standard
exclusive contract. I understand that, but it has nothing to
do with the substitute of the question I asked. >> Stephen,
you Stephen, again, this is just completely unproductive. I have
gotten in trouble at news organizations for publishing uh source
material directly. I have gotten in trouble many times over.
I'm not about to >> The easy question is, would block you
from publish the contract, publishing the contract? Would wire
saying no, you cannot do that? Why? I have no idea. I'd have
to talk to them again and I'd have to have conversations with
my sources about it.
So, so again, the end result is the same e but not publishing.
I you know, not talking about publicly. >> My claim was
about framing Wired as an institution. Hold on. Is that a reply?
>> Um
Wired is a part of an institution. It's part of cond.
>> it it is an institution. Once again, these creators
could disprove this by reaching out directly and they have been
unable to refute the facts of our story. So, I think they should
do that. I don't know why they haven't done that. They should
do that. Yeah. >> And next time, you know what? I take
your point. Next time that I report a scoop, you know, maybe
I will spend a little extra time negotiating and saying, "By
the way, I'm going to release this amount online and I'm going
to do this and this." Um, or maybe I'll just post it on Twitter.
I have done that myself with stories sometimes before where I'm
like, "You know what? I'm actually not even going to do this
for a news or I'm just going to go ahead and post some stuff
publicly, you know, cuz I think that this is a better way to
communicate the story. So, feedback accepted and I understand
what you're saying because I am on the same side. I think we
all want more transparency. What I would say is that I'm a journalist
and what we are asking for in terms of the the subjects of our
article. This is a political effort and I think transparency
in terms of communication about who's getting paid is so important
in politics. Dest I keep calling you Destiny. Stephen, wouldn't
you agree that it's it's important for people to disclose when
they're getting political funding? That's important, >> I
think it's essential, but that's why I advocate for change in
the laws. I would never push just one group or one side or one
thing to do that because it just puts you at a disadvantage because
now you're disclosing stuff and nobody else is and now people
are just going to attack your disclosures. >> What doesn't
make sense? >> Nobody no one advocates for changing the
laws before changing the social norms.
>> one leads to >> No, I mean you you I mean if the
social >> if the social No, no, no. That's not true. No,
no, no. That's not true. >> It goes social norms to taboos
to
to legal norms. Yeah.
>> Okay. Most of the time. I was going to say that the
social norm might not change, but our knowledge about it might
change. I was going to use smoking as an example, but I guess
I guess smoking kind of started to be made socially taboo first.
Maybe. Maybe that is >> all of a sudden they want smoking
sections in restaurants. All of a sudden they wanted smoking
to be outside. All of a sudden restaurants don't want you smoking
too close to the entrance. And then they made rules about where
you can and can't smoke. Can't smoke indoors.
>> What about segregation? Well, I think these but I think
unfort there were parts of the country where the social norms
had changed and that's where the laws started like once the country
started flipping significantly. That's where the actual friction
came for segregation, slavery, all of these >> Also, gay
people were getting married in churches by like priests and stuff
like that before it was uh acknowledged by the state, by like
the government.
>> Yeah, I haven't really thought about it enough. Damn,
this conversation's very I can't believe this.
I'll be honest, when I heard Taylor Loren's I'll I'll be real.
When I heard Taylor Lorenz was talking to Destiny, I was like,
"Oh, that's a horrible decision. That's maybe the worst decision
I've ever seen in my life." I don't know why you go talk to Destiny.
Like I think I think you could be correct and lose an argument
to Destiny entirely. Okay. I think you could be like 90 like
all I can think of is the uh the actual Jake debate. Okay. The
corn on the cob guy who lost on the debate where his his topic
was basically Destiny's a jerk and he lost on Destiny's a jerk.
>> Okay. But you would argue it's because actual Jake was
correct because like a clock is right two times a day, right?
He just has no idea why he's correct. He just knows this guy's
a jerk. >> Yeah, sure, sure, sure. But Taylor Loren is
informed on her article and she can stand up on it. And >> she's
actually doing a way better job than I thought she would. It's
very uh
it was very cool. My theory is Taylor Lorenz is incredibly smart.
I'm going to need more. I'm going to need to see more. Okay.
But I think this is a way better showing than I expected. Even
though she's not exactly like debating. It's not like she's doing
like insane rhetoric. I think she just has the facts on her side
pretty clearly. She just, you know, what is it? Um, when the
facts are on your side, pound the facts. When the something's
on your side, put when nothing's on your side. Oh, when the law's
on your side, pound the law. When uh when nothing's on your side,
pound the table. I feel like a lot of people are pounding the
table about Taylor Loren's. And Taylor is just like, "Yeah, I'm
going to keep saying the facts of the matter. Yeah, I went to
a reputable journalistic organization. Standard journalistic
ethics apply to this article. If you have problems, you can you
can literally message them for retractions. That's how it is."
Boom. Done. Anyway, I got to hit play. I'll be right back. I
need to get some water. I have like a really bad headache. Give
me two seconds here, guys. I'm going to get some water. Use the
bathroom. And now nobody else has to make the same types of disclosures.
But I do agree with you in terms of like I think that like I
listen, you know, as much as I disagree with a lot of your stuff,
I'm glad that you unmasked the libs of Tik Tok account. Okay.
I think it's really weird that there's a lot of people in alternative
media that have a huge sway over our political conversations
and we don't even know who they are, what country they're from,
or who they might be paid for, who they work for. So, I think
there is a great value in that. Um I I guess just curious the
only other like or the other the biggest strongest claim that
I had seen was that um like people who would even reference being
in the program would be that the contract said that they'd be
like kicked out. Was that like a clause on the contract written
too that if people acknowledged that they were in chorus or that
they were getting paid that they could be cut from or kicked
out of the program? >> Yeah. Creators told us that if they
had violated any terms of the contract they could be kicked out.
And I think there you know that that was that is part of part
of violating the contract would have been to go public. there
are these non you know these agreements or there is this language
in the contract that says this is not public and you cannot disclose
basically that you're in this program or disclose the identity
of the funer and that is something again that these creators
some of them wanted to do and they did not want to just get on
online and say hey guys I'm being funded by the 1630 fund or
whatever because they understood that they would be kicked out
because that because that would be one of many things that they
could do to violate the terms of the contract and if you violated
the terms of the contract of you would suffer the consequences
of >> Sure. Um, okay. I mean, that also sounds kind of
standard. If you if you violate terms of a contract, they'll
probably kick you out. Um, but the uh disclosure part, I guess,
>> dude, this guy's cooked.
>> Yeah, that sounds pretty standard. Like, if you violate
the terms of the contract, they kick you out. Yeah. So, you just
you just agreed with all of the reporting in the article now.
Like, he's actually cooked. He actually what he just admitted
there, like if this was Andrew Wilson he was debating, he just
lost the debate completely. like it's over at that point. Maybe
he doesn't maybe he maybe he's like relaxed because it's Taylor
Loren. I don't know. But that that that
point right there was uh that was wild. Also depends on how it's
being disclosed. I feel like there's probably reason for some
caution there, right? And that uh like there was one part of
your article mentioned they needed permission first. I can kind
of understand that to maintain the FC like standing, right? You
wouldn't want somebody doing some event and saying like, "Oh,
hey, I'm part of chorus and you know that's why I'm here doing
this thing if chorus has nothing to do with it." And then course
could get roped into a whole FC debacle where it's like wait
this was for uh you know they were with an AOC event and now
they said that course helped him so there's like a huge issue
here and they shouldn't have said that you know like I feel like
some of those things are kind of fair. I I I totally I mean >> so
the question there is why would that be a problem right? There's
no reason to suspect that chorus is funding people who would
engage in significant amounts of electioneering, right? They're
explicitly stating they don't engage in electioneering. Why would
it be a concern that if all of their creators just speak the
truth that they might be accused of electioneering, funding electioneering?
Can anybody tell me why that is? I've heard that they're not
they're nonpartisan. They don't get involved in electioneering.
Why is it a concern that if their creators just speak freely,
they might be accused or proven to be electioneering? One of
those imponder. I I I get it. But um one thing that I would say
Stephen and I think actually Tina win and Mia Sato at the Verge
had a really great piece. they did published this discussion
um on the verge which has also been doing amazing reporting on
the influencer industry and politics um about kind of like this
strategy of non-disclosure and they compared it to the Koch network
which is something that the 1630 fund is compared very frequently
to the Koch network in the sense that they're both these big
dark money groups and um in many ways according to Politico at
least uh like the 1630 fund is sort of this liberal response
to the Koch network and what Tina who Tina herself was a Koch
fellow like she you know she was in the right-wing media herself
now she reports on it. I thought what she said was so smart in
that piece where she was talking about like kind of why the CO
network actually has become less relevant over recent years and
in part it was because it had this um it it had this air about
it where it was these sort of like shadowy billionaires like
funding things and people sort of didn't like you know especially
around the Tea Party times that they were
we were making these articles like or sorry we were making these
arguments days ago Cherry we were making these arguments days
ago. that like it just looks like the real reason they don't
want the disclosures. Okay. Yeah, there's some FEC stuff there,
but the real reason they don't want it is they want the appearance
of of an organic movement here. >> That's what they want.
>> And if they don't get that, if they don't have the appearance
of an organic movement, uh if they're just accused of shilling,
they know it looks bad. They don't want that. And so that's the
real I that's what I suspect, but you know, there's no way to
prove that. That's all about mind readading, right? Oh. Oh, we
don't want our creators to be called chills. No, I feel like
we can mind readad. I'm sort of an empath in that way. Clairvoyant.
I don't know what phase of the moon we're at right now, but clearly
like this rapid response and this message coordination that Brian
wanted to do
it. You can see what the purpose of it was. >> Yeah, exactly.
>> It's effective.
>> Funding this, you know, fake grassroots movement. people
didn't like the idea that their that this was all happening in
secret and people don't like to feel like their political or
you know media ecosystem is polluted by these like weird dark
money forces like on the right or the left and so I think what's
interesting about what 1630 is doing now is and what what Tina
argues in her piece with Mia is that like they're sort of pursuing
this strategy that ultimately failed whereas like something like
Turning Point USA which is a lot more public the turning point
you know kids like that those influencers like literally have
at Turning Point like in their bio. It's this like public thing
that actually has been like that sort of more public program
has actually been more successful on the right. And so yes, the
the the right still does a ton of like shady dark influence stuff.
But if you look at these big programs like Turning Point, which
I've reported on a bunch myself, it is very like public in this
way. And I wonder and my question would be to 16:30 and to chorus,
which they have not. They're not talking to me. But my question
to them would be why not just do it publicly? Why not just, you
know, why have these weird things where if it gets disclosed,
it makes you seem untrustworthy? Like, why not just make this
a public program? Wouldn't
>> The reason they don't do that is because then they couldn't
do the funding model they have. That's they're they're doing
a loophole around that funding model. They if they actually just
disclosed everything, they wouldn't be able to use this exact
funding model, right? They wouldn't be able to use the uh the
501c4, right? >> Get more people involved. It seems like
a lot of these people, like the fans of these people, would be
excited for their favorite liberal creators to get funding as
long as they don't feel duped about it. So, >> what is
I'm just kind of curious cuz I've heard this term thrown around
a lot. When you say that like um or if somebody says that like
so chorus exists and then they are funded by the 1630 fund, what
when we say dark money, I guess, what is your definition of dark
money or what like how much Yeah. How far back do you have to
go for it to not be dark money? Yeah, >> definitely. So
um so actually I had Anna Mascolia who is one of the and I definitely
butchered her last name but she's she uh she was managing editor
at Open Secrets for like seven years. She's um she publishes
a newsletter called Influence Watch. She is like one of the foremost
journalists in the country talking about dark money and I just
made a video uh with her that's out today actually answering
this question. Um so I'll try to summarize what she told me.
Um, but basically dark money just means that you don't know where
you you sort of don't know who it's from. And it's usually and
it's a political like people when people talk about dark money
groups. They're not just talking about every 501c4 or whatever
nonprofit or whatever. They're talking about like a a entity
that has a certain uh structure that is meant to evade. It's
that is for political purposes that's also that also you don't
have my I'm butchering it but like you don't have to know who
funds it. So the big issue with 1630 fund or some of these other
big dark money groups, do they do a lot of great work? Yeah.
I mean 1630s funded a ton of like reproductive justice stuff.
Like you know, I'm not saying like they're evil in some way.
Just the way that a lot of conservatives wouldn't say Coke Network
is is evil. They believe that they're doing good. But um but
we don't know who funds them. And the only way we find out who
funds them is if people self-disclose. So sometimes uh public
organizations disclose like public fortune 500 companies will
donate to these funds and sometimes they'll disclose. Um, but
lots of billionaires and foreign, you know, billionaires and
stuff will donate to these things and we don't we don't know.
And so, you know, this is why one creator, I don't know if you
saw him, I forgot his name, but his TikTok went kind of viral.
He was actually asked to be part of this 1630 funding program
with with Chorus and Chorus is described as a project of the
1630 fund uh in our in our um PE or sorry, in the contracts.
He said, "Listen, I have security clearance. I have security
clearance in whatever the government and to maintain that security
clearance I have to be able to prove that I have never accepted
money from any sort of foreign adversary. If I take money from
a dark money group you don't know where that money ultimately
originated from. And so he joined the >> I I don't know
if that's that sounds not accurate to me because if you don't
know where the money's coming from, how can the foreign money
be a corrupting
>> Well, that's a really good question, right? is that
you
>> um the answer to this is right. Why would anybody funking?
How can you get addicted? >> Well, hold on. Why would anybody
fund Lance from the Surfs? Okay. >> Why would you would
any honest to god liberal or progressive fund Lance from the
Surfs? I don't see why they make you guys look How does Lance
from the surfs continue to operate? I assume Russian or Chinese.
I'm kind of kidding. Okay, I'm kind of kidding. >> I don't
even know why you say Lance. Lance is funny. Lance is entertaining.
I I would say why would anybody Lance has become attractive from
losing weight. That's all that he has going on. >> Has
become
>> I'm sorry. He was attractive from the
>> Okay, I don't think so. But listen, fine. We could agree.
But I'm telling you that that guy makes liberals and progressives
look horrible everywhere he goes. If you found out Peter Teal
was was funding that guy, that would upset you, right? If you
found out that Russia was funding that guy, that would upset
you. Actually, the GOP funds Lance and the Surfs. So, we have
someone to point to how stupid the left is. Yeah. Yeah. No, that's
my point. Cacophonyies. Yes. Is that like you could easily from
a if if you aren't getting foreign money, how it could be an
influence because it's propping up people who are total. actually
crowding out. You're actually crowding out intelligent voices
by continuing to fund and make sure that they can kind of control
the opposition just like >> like amplifying voices that
don't give legitimate like uh don't have legitimate ideas that
aren't like legitimately anything. Yeah.
>> Like when everyone in the lefty space has to be in the
same room talking about politics but Xanderhal, you all of a
sudden you have a whole lot of infighting, right? cuz all of
a sudden they mixed in like the AP class with the special ed
class
>> and the AP students didn't know to bring a helmet, right?
Just the teachers know. >> Yes.
Uh yes. Uh I got to hit play. I have to go find ibuprofen real
quick. I think I'm uh getting like a really bad headache. Just
give me a second. I'll be right back. >> You don't know.
So you you they're not directly corrupting you in the sense of
like they're not like ooh um you know hey like I'm so and so
and here's like you know here's how I'm going to influence you.
The the question I think arises with these dark money groups
is because we don't know who's funding them. We don't know how
much that's impacting their legislative uh like agenda. We don't
know how much that's impacting their policy initiatives. We >> for
if you filled out like an SF86 and you've had to Well, I'm not
talking about the lawmakers. for the clearance form. Like generally
when they're doing when you're doing your SF86 background checks
and you're talking to people, it's to make sure that they don't
have foreign relationships that they aren't disclosing to the
government because those can be corrupting or be used for leverage
or other things, you know, if you travel or whatever. So, I just
I don't understand like a dark money like it's like imagine somebody's
bribing you, but it's just $10,000 shows up in your mailbox and
you don't know who it comes from. I don't know how that could
>> he had he had to I you'll have to take it up with him,
but what he says on TikTok and he's public and he's been answering
people's questions on TikTok, so you should definitely go um
ask him. >> wait, so does Destiny agree that like uh Tim
Pool wasn't affected by the Russian money at all? Would Destiny
actually agree on that? Cuz it's not that Tim Pool knew it was
coming from Russia. He just knew it was right. Like what is the
argument happening here?
I feel like he's actually just arguing that >> Get back
here and turn my light back on. >> Oh, whoops. My bad.
I went to go grab uh I went to go grab ibuprofen from another
room and I just shut the light off in there. Very. >> He
shut it off. Then he turned it back on. Then he looked at me
like a demon and shut it back off. >> Wait. Oh, yeah. Well,
I turned it on to go find I don't know. >> No, you >> I
have a headache. Okay. My brain's not working. Except it's still
apparently functioning high at a high enough level to to detect
that Desi just gave like total cover to Benny Johnson, Tim Pool.
I don't >> Oh, did he? Is he now on their side? Well, he
just said that like, oh, well, if you don't know where the foreign
money is coming from, how could it possibly be a corrupting influence?
>> I guess. I guess I maybe maybe there's argument that
Lauren Chen knew it was coming from, so his direction could be
corrupted. I don't even know. >> I I'm saying true as in
like Yeah, that's running cover for those guys. >> Yeah,
I know. But I he must have some other point here. >> There's
no way he just said that. And >> this can be corrupting
or be used for leverage or other things, you know, if you travel
or whatever. So I just if you fil86 and you've had to well I'm
not talking about the lawmakers for the clearance form like generally
when they're doing when you're doing your SF86 background checks
and you're talking to people to make sure that they don't have
foreign relationships that they aren't disclosing to the government
because those can be corrupting or be used for leverage or other
things you know if you travel or whatever. So I just I don't
understand like a dark money like it's like imagine somebody's
bribing you but it's just $10,000 shows up in your mailbox and
you don't know who it comes from. I don't know how that could
be >> he had to he had to I you'll have to take it up with
him. But what he says on Tik Tok and he's public and he's been
answering people's questions on TikTok. So you should definitely
go um ask him. But what he said is that he had to prove basically
that he had never received foreign money from certain places.
Um his name let me just get his name for you guys cuz then you
can then you can go yourselves. And >> but also it wouldn't
be it wouldn't be receiving foreign money. It'd be receiving
money from the 1630 fund. Right. Well, so but the but the foreign
money could and we're saying foreign basically money that he
couldn't accept uh could be funded there. Hold on, let me just
grab his it's Shane Morris. So if you go on Shane Morris, you
guys can go ask him these questions. >> If I if I employ
if I have a W2 employee and I get paid and I make money from
different things like that W2 employee, they only have to disclose
that they're being paid by us. It doesn't matter where my money
comes from, right? Yeah. >> Well, you should ask this to
Shane who's very public and is is talking about this. I did not
talk to Shane for my story. So, you know, don't don't please
don't drag him because people keep saying he's my source and
he is somebody that I saw actually after my story came out. Um,
but I think the issue is is that we don't know the influence
that these donors have on the 1630 funds agenda or policy agenda
or programs. And so, that's the concern with dark money is I
personally would not feel comfortable as a journalist taking
money
>> uh hold on. Luticious Gamer says, "Well, they'd have
to report foreign gifts." I don't know why he's even talking
about an SF86 form. Um, this is his version. He's just doing
the aerodyite thing, right? Mollock Mullet game. Mollik's game.
He's just doing that. He's dropping the name of a specific form,
W2 employee, SF86 form. He's trying to do this to say, "I know.
I have life experience." That's all it is. It's uh it's like
not really useful to the conversation. I have I have life experience,
guys. I know what I'm talking about. I'm smart. somebody where
I don't know where that money is coming from because I want to
have a certain level of transparency and I want to be able to
communicate to my audience. Hey guys, I have never taken money
from XYZ. I've never taken money from Mark Andre for instance
and I never would. And that is something that I feel like I can
communicate confidently to my audience because I know exactly
who funds me. And I think one problem with these dark money groups
is that these these we don't know who funds them and we just
deserve more transparency on the political ecosystem across the
board. You're right. This is a structural problem. This is not
something that the creators themselves are going to solve, but
we should advocate for less dark money in politics cuz one thing
that the dark money groups really do, which is not even related
to the course thing, is they're funding the packs, right? And
the super PACs. So packs of course have to disclose and they
have to you I think you're part of one, right? You have to >> I'm
not. I'm definitely I'm not part of any pack. >> Oh, you're
not? Okay, take it back. Take it back. I I I for some reason
I thought you were. Um anyway, but you know what a pack is, right?
The super PACs or whatever. So some what these dark money groups
will do is they'll sort of spin up a there'll be a dark money
fund spin up or they'll sort of spin off like a shell uh sort
of group and then that will just fund the pack and so we still
don't really have transparency because we don't know who funded
that dark money group. Now it's just a black box of money and
that black box of money is funding the pack that's then doing
political activity. So we just want a lot more transparency.
>> Yeah. So I guess a question is because I'm kind of curious
because because it's hard to I guess like differentiate between
all these organizations. So obviously um a lot of people have
said I was part of some pack because I did a couple activations
I guess with uh progressive victory a while ago but um I've seen
people attack you over the Amidia or whatever
>> I know that you coordinated with these people. I know
you tried not to. So Destiny's basically using his like total
refusal to ever take a meeting with Sin uh as like his ability
to have like plausible deniability that he was involved in any
progressive victory canvasing. I'm pretty sure he was supposed
to be involved. He just didn't take his responsibilities seriously
cuz he's a lazy [__] Um but like he was supposed
to be more involved than he was. I thought like he was he was
involved with the pack and they tried to have him be involved.
He's just a lazy who doesn't want to be involved who wants to
pay people to go away and give him more time to do whatever he's
doing. Um but I'm pretty confident that like all his friends
and he's like involved and and asked questions about like tons
of things. >> I was involved for Ohio, but he wasn't really
that involved for Georgia. I think he like lost a bet to IRI
so that's why he did Georgia. Um but like I he was sick for the
Georgia. So >> well sorry
active body in it. >> No he wasn't but he would have put
the money in for Sedgeon to go do the job >> Oh that's
what you mean by they wanted him to be more involved. They wanted
him to put >> they wanted him to like actually be involved
to actually be like talking about it to actually be like engaged
in their efforts. >> Be hyped have like the Yeah. Yeah,
cuz for the Georgia >> or even just give his like expertise
or his thoughts >> on stream and talk about it. So chat
was like invested in everybody being a part of it. I guess
>> stuff stuff like that. But they like I think from what
I recall like it was basically they integrated Destiny's canvasing
stuff into Progressive Victory like through Sedon and and I think
some other people Sin was working with right like that's they
had Destiny's canvasing operation which was SEN. They integrated
that into PV. I believe said like Destiny was still supposed
to have some role there, but he just didn't do it. >> Kaku,
I was involved with Progressive Victory for three weeks while
I was pregnant
and then I had um Rihanna Woo wanted me to give my social security
number to River Jack and I said that was crazy. I'm not doing
that. And then I had a miscarriage and I didn't talk to any of
those people ever again. Or did I? No, I did after the DC trip
was like a month after or something like that, right? Uh, I have
no idea. That's your timeline.
I didn't keep track of any of that stuff at that time. >> All
really close together.
Anyway, it was for three three meetings. Um, but I didn't follow
through on any of it because man, giving your social security
number to a content creator sounded crazy to me. >> Yeah.
And also, all of your [__] would be leaked online
if you'd done it. So,
>> Lucky they accidentally leaked everybody's everything.
So, very lucky. Cool. Yeah, I'm in a journalism fellowship right
now. So, >> but I'm just curious because of that because
they use that same like hybrid funding methodology to where the
group that you work for, they are also funded by their 501c4.
>> No, no, no, no, no. So, I'm funded by Well, I I'm in
an investigative journalism fellowship that one I just should
very much be very clear about is not political. Okay? I'm not
part of any political
program or anything like that. This is an investigative reporting
fellowship that is non-political, nonpartisan. It is just to
support investigative journalism. It is funded by Pierre Omidar
who's a billionaire. Now, Pierre Omidar himself has donated to
dark money just the way that Lorraine Powell Jobs >> No,
the Amidar Network is a hybrid. I think it's a 527 on one end
and then a 501c4 and the 527 is able to bill about $15 million
a year to the 501c4 quote unquote dark money thing. What you
say about being an independent journalist, couldn't somebody
just who's part of chorus say the same thing? And then you can
challenge. >> No, because No, because I know where 100%
of the funding for my program comes from, which is directly from
Pierre Omdar and Omidr.
>> So the idea of a 501c4, you could actually know where
the funding comes from for 501c4, right? Like you don't have
to disclose it, but it could be disclosed. I believe >> came
out and gave a statement making
by him personally. You're not taking money from the entity that
>> the entity that I am part of which is part which is
the reporters and residents program the reporters and res tax
taxed entity that entity is part of a hybrid structure that does
get money through a through the C4. >> No, they're funded
by Pierre Omidar.
>> On a second let me see here.
Uh what is this? See this was in March of 2025.
Uh how likely are you to personally engage to engage personally
with streamers/content creators again? I'm pretty sure they're
all scum. This is in March, so shortly after Destiny was getting
accused of all the stuff. Never again. Switching to the Hassan/Bosch
Bosch method of whatever and just going to start acting like
celebs. Act and be stuck up and not deal with anyone who's not
on my level of fame or whatever. Lol W. Well, luckily a lot of
us are going to be on his level of fame soon. I just never imagined
how insane all the Vulture stuff would be after helping so many
of the those people. Like the entire progressive victory paid
out millions in wages to all of those people and the whole thing
only existed because of me on top of a billion other things.
Wow.
Wow. Guys, I only did a few activations with Progressive Victory.
I only did a few activations with Progressive Victory, guys.
Oh, wait. Um, actually, no. Um, these people were all snakes
and they they totally snaked me. And actually, I built Progressive
Victory by myself.
That's uh that's kind of crazy. That's a little crazy. That's
dude
whole thing only existed because of me. You actually can't quite
see it on the screen. Hold on.
>> yeah. Hold on. Let me send this screenshot. Actually,
>> who was the person who was making this argument? Was
it you? Was it somebody else? Where they were like all of these
orbiters around him got these like
big monthly checks
because that's how they could like get him invested in it is
if they got all of his friends paid. I don't know who made that,
but uh yeah, I just find it interesting that he's willing to
say this. Like, how do we how do we go between both of these
things? Isn't this a little crazy? >> I just don't think
you can >> Wait, which is it? I'm I'm just curious. I don't
know which it could >> I think whatever fits best for whatever
argument in that moment. I think you go with that one.
>> Yeah, hold on. Fbombs. Obviously,
the whole thing the whole thing only existed because of me on
top of a billion other things. Now, Progressive Victory doesn't
only exist because of Destiny. It was founded by Sam Mal and
existed for, I believe, like 2 years or a year and a half before
Destiny got involved, obviously. But the iteration of PB that
was paying out his friends did probably only exist because of
him. Like, I'll be real. >> Also, who the was actually
talking about it until like him, the people around him were involved
in it? >> Nobody. Yeah. >> Okay. Just checking. >> Yeah.
I just I just find it funny that he uh he totally wants to soy
out and say I wasn't involved. It's very interesting. It's very
interesting. Okay, this was Destiny's contribution by the way.
Hold on. I'll check this real quick. Is this going to be Aerodite
trying to get him to do stuff? >> It's going to look like
his Patreon. >> Um question about this is the boring stuff,
but >> uh fundraising and stuff. I know you're super busy.
>> Yeah, I think I linked it earlier. >> I've only
gotten like $70 raised though. So, um, if we want to be able
to cover camps and hotels, we'll have to push it. Do you want
me to
>> I'll link it again. We're trying to raise 6K. I think
they only need three more for the Nevada event, guys. Here you
go. >> Sounded like they needed a lot more than three.
If they need six and they only raise 70. >> I hope they
got the hotel with the hot tub in it for the streamers. The Democrats
win. >> It is going to help the Democrats win. >> 2K.
That's
>> uh Arite got her channel back. I enjoyed seeing her
nuked for a few days though, says Buttsnifa. I think it's cringe
to like like when content creators get deplatformed. I think
that's cringe. >> Was raised like >> even when they're
the most cringe of content creators.
Okay. >> You know, I like watching Arerdite thrive. I like
seeing her thrive. I like seeing her hands waving in the air
going
[__] [__] Like that aerodite. I don't
want that aerodite to ever go
>> Well, Ben, >> this one's good, too, where she's
just like, "Hey, could you help?" And Desessie like clearly knows
what she's asking for, and he's like, "No, I'm not going to."
Oh, I guess we I'll link it again. Uh, we need more push. Uh,
I'll link it again.
>> Oh, we need more than three. Good luck. >> Okay.
I love you all. >> Should I come in tomorrow? What should
I do? You're >> What are we doing for what? I can't tell
who's more artistic here, him being avoidant or her not picking
up that he doesn't want to do this and he feels like taken advantage
of. I don't know who's actually more
>> incapable of understanding. >> I think she's not
picking it up. I think she's picking it up. That's like a threat.
Should I do I have to come in
>> I will make you spend time with me. Okay. Just do the
fundraising or I'm going to be in your ear. I'm going to be around
you in your general area. >> Link it or I'm going to show
up. Link it or I will be there pretending to be friends. Okay.
It will be torture.
Yeah. Yep. And it worked. Or maybe it didn't. I have no idea
actually. Anyway, we're getting back to it. >> So, Pierro
Midiar is the billionaire. So, you're confusing it. So, dark
money doesn't fund billionaires. Billionaires fund dark money.
So, to be the or you're part of I can see their nfs like they
file these things publicly. They get they bill about $15 million
a year. I think it was I think it was like $14.6 $6 million last
year to their partner 501c4. You can read on the MD network.
>> So they build them. Is that for actual services rendered
or are you saying that like the money is being laundered somehow?
They build. So they get they get 14 point something million back.
They build that. Is that for like
part of Right. And I'm not part of any of that. I'm only part
of the reporters and residence program which gets 100% of its
funding from Pierre Omidar. That's his fun. That's what he funds
it for. So now Pier Midar himself, you're right, has given to
dark money funds and does his own political things. I'm not disputing
that. But I know that I know where my money comes from where
I'm like, hm, okay, do I feel comfortable taking this fellowship
that is Pier Midar's money. I personally do because he funds
the Intercept and he funds a lot of journalism programs.
>> Um, Loki Coco, no, you won't understand. Never mind.
And it's also I've worked for billionaires unfortunately
my entire journalism career. I worked for the Atlantic as well
that's funded by Lorraine Pal Jobs who I'm sure also gives money
to dark money groups. Jeff >> for the chorus for the chorus
people that reached out to you for their paychecks. Were they
signed by like the 1630 fund or were they signed by like the
chorus network? >> As far as I understand they uh it was
1630 as far as I understand. >> But you haven't seen any
like deposits or check slips or anything? >> I don't remember.
But it's but it but in the communication they say in the communication
that we have they say that you will be your it will say 1630
on it.
>> And that's why like the contracts and stuff again and
I'm not saying that like these creators are evil for accepting
this money. I think they're like what what liberals will have
many people and Anna clarifies this in the video that I made
as well. Like what many of them will say is like look I don't
like the system either right like >> uh internet ray um
isn't it possible that the billionaire just does the disclosure
himself like like literally says I'm funding this directly >> it's
like the omittier fund where you replying to >> I'm replying
to internet ray asked I mean technically she does not know where
her money comes from unless they give her the LLC's tax returns
she takes his word on it sure but like the the money going into
these things is from Pierre yeah I like I like literally he could
just make this obvious. No, I believe he is hold on internet
ray you understand right that the billionaire is funding this.
It is his fund directly and he is saying yes this is my fund
that's built on my foundation that I put the money into and I
am telling you explicitly that I am funding this program and
I've directed them to fund this program from my money. That is
a public disclosure. That is a disclosure. Uh oh. Um,
Midiar family 501c4 disclosures. Pier's disclosures, which he
is not legally required to do. Oh, Midiar Group, April 10th,
2024. Oh, these are his disclosures, but I'm guessing that these
would be outside of the Omdar
or is this the Omdar? I don't even know what this is. Omidar
group. These are his like personal ones or something. And then
what does Democracy Fund voice go back into his own [__]
I have no idea how this would go. Not the LLC though. Okay. But
but is there any reason to believe Okay, we have to figure out
the argument. Okay, do we think that the the
just to be clear, we think that LLC is laundering money, not
providing services. So that is when Tik Tockers make that claim
about Z and her when Soul Solutions is the is one of the major
things funded, it goes that money from her pack goes into Soul
Solutions and people say that's suspicious. I think they're laundering
that money. That's a valid accusation.
It can't possibly just be for services rendered. We assume that
that money because it goes into an LLC is being misused. So,
we think Z is is actually on the line for fraud in the same way
that this is uh somehow being used to launder dark money back
into the 16. I don't even know how this would go. They bill out
they they're billing out fake services. That's not the point.
That's not the point you want to make, but it's a point you have
to accept. It's like an entailment you have to accept. I understand
that's not the point you want to make. No, the services are real.
So then it's not laundering money. So that money isn't coming
back from like a the money is not disclosed.
What do you mean the money is not disclosed?
They're rendering services to the LLC. The LLC is paying for
those services. What is undisclosed there? Where the LLC money
is coming from.
Okay. But do you understand that that would only be uh that would
only be a problem if they weren't rendering actual services?
If I sell you a hot dog and you pay for it because you got money
through some dark money group and you're funding my hot dogs.
I that hot dog vendor. Okay. If everybody from National Ground
Game, okay, no, everybody from Chorus, they're at a Chorus meeting
and Brian Tyler Cohen buys a 100 hot dogs for every, you know,
every creator gets a hot dog. That hot dog vendor is not accepting
dark money because they got it through 16:30. That's the argument
you guys are making, isn't it? >> Well, how do you know?
Cuz maybe they're lying about what meat is in the hot dog. Well,
they're saying they're saying the LLC doesn't disclose it money.
Uh 1630 wouldn't disclose where their money comes from either.
If 1630 is paying for the hot dogs, you don't say the hot dog
vendor is taking dark money. They're rendering a service. They're
giving you a product, right? >> I actually stopped listening
like 2 minutes ago. I don't know what's going >> Unless
I'm miss Unless I'm missing >> I think if 1630 doesn't
disclose where their funding is coming from, taking money from
1630 is always taking dark money. It's only so it's for political
speech. I agree. The dark money is to do with political speech,
right? >> No, it's it's just because you don't know where
the money is coming from. >> I think the the disclosures
are a requirement for somebody who's doing political speech or
at least according to Taylor's worldview.
>> But in any case, it's like if you're actually selling
>> Sure. Sure. Sure. I'm just saying advocate. Yeah. Yeah.
>> I'm saying that it wouldn't be a dark money issue if
they're paying for a service directly. If they were paying for
content, if they if 1630 was saying, "I'm paying you and you
do disclosure based on hashtag ad 1630 fund." Right? None of
that would be a problem. >> I see. >> Or I don't
think that would be the same problem, right? >> They were,
let's say in the morning for their board meeting, they go to
a bakery and they get like three dozen pastries. The pastry the
bakery is not accepting dark money. That's what you mean. >> Yeah.
they're providing a service they would provide uniformly for
a bunch of different things or could provide uniformly for a
bunch of different things. And so yeah, I just I don't understand
how we're making that argument if unless you think that it's
like laundering and they're using it for something else.
>> But it sounds like they're just selling out services.
They're they're literally making a sale like a transaction.
>> Yeah. So if you if you understand what 1630 gets out
of it, then it's not dark money. But if 1630 is just paying you
and you don't have to do anything for them, that's when it's
dark money. >> Well, and I mean they're paying you based
on political things. It's a political organization taking money
for political like speech like political creators, right? >> I
mean that's what you think, right? If they just start paying
somebody who plays uh a GTA RPG,
is that it's called?
If they just start funding a creator and that creator is not
supposed to talk about that they're getting money from them,
you would still call it that creator is accepting dark money
because that creator is not giving them anything. >> Yeah.
Exactly. Well, I'm sorry. They're not giving them anything they
wouldn't give to somebody else who pays them. >> Like you're
you're making it contingent on politics. I think it's anytime
you don't know what 1630 is getting from you, you are accepting
dark money. >> I and I would say that it's like um how
do I put it? It's a little more than that. It's uh No, it's it's
pretty close to that. It's to me it's like you you could sell
a way where I'm wrong. >> It's a difficult one. >> No,
I'm not trying to. Anyway, I'm I'm just seeing like but at a
base level it's like I would just trust the Omidar group as that
as that charity as that thing that like this guy does all his
public disclosures seem to believe. He seems to believe in transparency.
Like I feel like that's fairly trustworthy, right? He's literally
saying I'm paying for it. The issue is with the 501c4 and the
the the 501c4 is set up through
1630 is that they don't disclose at all. Nobody discloses except
I guess Pier Midar when he was disclosing that he's paying into
it. >> I don't like this system either. I think that this
is bad. I think the Coke network is evil. But until we change
these laws, I think we should leverage it and I feel comfortable
taking this money. Whatever. Whatever. What I would say to them
is that's totally your decision, right? Like you've made that.
I personally I'm a journalist. I hold myself to different standards,
but you're a political activist. Maybe you feel totally fine.
>> I understand what you're saying, but your thing, your
checks are not signed by that PR. Your checks are signed by I'm
guessing it says the media. >> Uh I feel like I just caught
what you were trying to catch up to. This is about um 1630
donating money to like the journalist fellowship or something,
>> Well, it's it's not even that cuz that's not the argument
they're making. They're saying that you don't know what the LLC
Oh, Commodore Champ, thank you for the uh the new sub. But um
1630, not 1630, there's Omidar, the Omidar network um like thing
>> that receives money from 16. Yeah. >> No, it doesn't
receive money from 1630. It received one set of money from 1630
in like 2022, but it's not super relevant to this. Right. Right.
That group is a charity that also has an LLC attached to it.
The charity is a 501c3. The LLC is something else. I I forget
how the LLC is registered, but essentially the income for the
LLC, how it's funded, is not transparent, right? And they're
saying that because the Omidar Network charity bills out $15
million to the LLC that pays them the $15 million for the services,
that's them taking dark money from the LLC. But I do not believe
this is the same thing. One, it's not being used for political
>> uh, it's it just seems different. And unless you have
some reason to think unless you have some reason to think that
that LLC is not getting actual services rendered to them, that
they're doing some kind of embezzlement, right?
>> Is that just legal?
>> Yeah. Like that's just this just a >> Correct.
And I also think that there's something that is uh that is exchanged
when you are getting like a a charity donation. They are getting
something out of it. Streamers understand this. When you raise
money for charity and you donate to charities, this is a something
people do for their reputation. >> Sure. I think that's
I Yeah, sure. I think in my head I just like I I see it a certain
way and I'm having a hard time formulating it for some people
in chat and I >> you're seeing it a different way, too.
I just have it the way I have it in my head. I I'm having a hard
time explaining it some other way. I'd like have to talk through
it or draw it out. >> All right, we'll get to it someday.
>> Someday. Yeah, sure. Um,
PVA2. Yeah, I understand the the LLC thing.
Um, anyway, whatever. >> You're saying my mic sounds >> I
actually don't know cuz I
>> uh it it can sound weird sometimes. Like fine. Uh, it
just sounds different than your other mic, but I think if we
just get a mic stand set up and stuff, it'll sound better. haven't
gotten paid, but um but I would imagine that it says the reporters
and residents. Yeah, the LLC that I that I'm that I it's they're
paid for. I'm it's part of it's an LLC. So, >> yeah, but
the LLC is the that's the other hybrid. >> 100% No, no,
no, it's not hybrid. That's 100% funded by Pierre Omidar. And
>> absolutely not. It's not. You can read their filings.
It's just not you can but you I you might be confused by their
filings but here if you click on this Omidar network support
approach to funding journalism they issued a statement right
here >> I see the statement at the end it says the work
is supported entirely via our foundation and LLC that foundation
is the hybrid foundation that includes the 501c4 they're 99 >> I
understand what you're saying but when it comes to >> oh
I thought we didn't have the Omidar network with a 501c4 I thought
we found that the Omdar network was a 501c3
see
uh Omidar Network is a 501c3 and LLC misspeak from Destiny. Misspeak
critical
critical misspeak.
That is a 501c3.
Okay, so he's uh he's struggling. Oh, he can't he can't screw
this point up, can >> I can't throw stones. I feel like
I up like 12 times today trying to keep up with this. >> It
is a little confusing. So again, the 501c3, I think you do disclose
funding sources in a 501c3, right? Yeah. Fbombs were not even
engaging in the hypocrisy versus hypocrisy arguments because
it would just be so boring. But >> the reporters in >> So
he's saying the LLC, he's lost his argument, which is funny.
>> Residence program, we do know where the funding comes
from. So I'm with you. I'm with you, Stephen. I know that they
also do political stuff and all of that and the foundation itself
is completely separate. I that was something that I was like,
you know, obviously we're all aware of, but I know personally
where my money comes from. And that and the issue that some people
feel that they have a problem with with dark money is that they
don't necessarily know where that money comes from. And so that
is the argument that that I think remains to be made. And again,
>> it's some of them are f they might say like these reproductive
justice activists, right, that also take money from 1630, they're
like, "Yeah, okay. I don't know where all the money. Maybe it
is from an evil billionaire that I completely disagree with,
but I'm going to take that money anyway and I'm going to use
it for a good cause. I think that you can make that argument
and I'm not shaming anyone, you know, for for that. But what
I what I think that we can all agree with is disclosure. As you
noted, this program that I'm in sent out a press release the
day there's all the information that you can find is public.
And the reason that you're able to find those documents, >> like
none of the contracts have been published for those creators
that are there, right? >> Well, right. Cuz it's not public.
Their their contracts are not public. Is that what you're asking?
>> Yeah. Well, I'm saying but there's not just there's
not transparency there, right? Well, I don't know any I don't
know what your contract looks like. I don't know like none of
that what they put on this website is legally binding. They're
just writing a thing and they're saying it's supported entirely
via the foundation LLC, but I I can't look at the specific funding
mechanisms that are routed through the
>> right and if and if you found and if you found like
evidence or something like what I would say is that if somebody
reported on that program and was able to find evidence that the
network had lied or had not disclosed and there was a secret
funer, that would be an amazing article that somebody could write,
right? Like just the way that the chorus it's like oh wow 1630
fund is behind them actually that's confusing whatever what I
would say is again pure midair is a billionaire so billionaires
fund dark money groups dark money groups don't fund they don't
just go around giving billionaires money billionaires are the
funders so I I have made the decision unfortunately that I'm
I have taken money from billionaires ultimately working for >> unfortunately
I thought pier isn't pier nice come on isn't he one of those
nice >> for do either doing an investigative journalism
fellowship or working at these billionaire owned media companies.
I don't love it. It's part of the reason I went independent,
but at least I'm comfortable with the people that I'm taking
money from. There are billionaires that I would never take money
from. For instance, Mark Andre and >> Um, and so I think
that that's a conversation that we need to have, but I'm comfortable
with the level that I've had of disclosure. And I think that
we that's what we need to focus on is the lack of disclosure
in the political space because that's another thing that's different,
right? I'm not in a political program. I'm in an investigative
journalism fellowship. I'm not doing political activism. Chorus
is also not supposed to be in a political program as well, right?
Like I think >> no chorus is political. Chorus if you chorus
is the whole reason that chorus exists is to fix the Democrats
internet. >> Ain't no way this just said Chorus isn't political,
right? Like come on. Do they fund a non-political creator? I
dude, this argument is just insane. Like this is what I'm talking
about. By the way, when I say that they're like spitting in your
face while telling you that nothing happened, they like spit
in your face and they're like, "What are you?" You're like, "What
the?" And they're like, "What are you? What are you talking about?
It's raining." And they spit on you again. And it's like that
it's raining. What are you talking about? It's like, "Shut don't
just don't do that. Can we just not do that?" >> Okay,
but what if they have like three people who don't talk about
politics? Then they can say that they're not political. Did you
think >> I mean, even if I if they did that would at least
be a start, but they don't. I don't think they do. Also, your
mic cut out. I don't know if you're you still there. Hello. >> God
damn it. What a mic.
>> It's like not bad. I swear. I'll I'll trade you. You
can have the You can have the Yeti have the old faithful that
cuts out every two seconds. Anytime I touch it at all, it just
immediately shuts off. I don't think you could handle this one.
Um, >> not right now. >> Hold on. I'm trying to figure
out Okay, I'm trying to figure out what's going on with the LLC
here. Okay, hold on. >> Content creator problem. But this
this guy's going this guy's being goofy. I can't. He actually
said it. >> I'm not doing political activism.
Is also not supposed to be in a political program as well, right?
Like I think >> No, Chorus is political. Chorus, if you
Chorus is the whole reason that chorus exists is to fix >> why
is he acting like Brian Tyler Cohen didn't come on here and explain
exactly what he was trying to do with Chorus. Like it's just
the performative
at this point is is just goofy, right? Like I this must be why
this guy is like a halfife of fans. >> Well, oh yeah.
What could it possibly be if it's not performative >> real?
I don't know. >> Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I don't know.
Does he maybe mean being partisan? I don't know what he means.
He's I think he he So he didn't say something quite so He said
it's not supposed to be political, right? I think they have to
say they're not political because I think that's a requirement
of what they are as a like as a thing. I think they have to say
they're not political by nature or something like that. They
could be they could be issued ba issues based but they can't
be politically based. But again, to me, when when you say we're
nonpolitical, nonpartisan, and you only f fund Democrats, you
only fund left-leaning people who only apply to one side of the
political spectrum, the US, I I just sit there and I'm like,
yeah,
okay, but like you're just lying. You're just dodging campaign
finance laws. That's all you're doing. It's clearly what you're
doing here. Yeah. I don't know. >> It's the Democrats internet
content creator problem. >> Isn't the stated mission, the
stated goal is like basically just informing people on democracy
and stuff like that? Like I think the it's expressly supposed
>> what they I don't know what they have but I'll tell
you how I'll tell you how Brian Tyler Cohen described its mission.
Let's see this is how Brian Tyler Cohen described it in the New
York Times. He said uh here's how he Yeah, here he's talking
about launching chorus. We have an obligation to do it to launch
chorus because the Democratic party has been so slow in adapting
to the media environment we're in right now. And so what the
goal is according to this article which is the launch article
that Ken Bener wrote is their goal is to help the Democrats >> again.
That's not a secret. >> Sure. I I I think that that that's
a way that you could read that. But I mean, you could also just
say that like like this is Oh, he's like perfectly doing the
thing. He's like Taylor was just like, "Dude, what the [__]
You just spit in my face." Like here's what Brian Tyler Cohen
said. And he's like, "Well, that's one way you could think about
that." Well, it's raining out here, dude. It's raining out here.
It's actually raining out here right now. Oh, it's so weird how
it's raining like >> Like the values and things that I
align with the Democratic party on. The other things that I imagine
the 1630 fund supports, the Democrats have done a poor job at
that messaging. So they want to reach out and educate creators
and everything in order to I guess like advocate more >> help
the Democrats. Yeah. To help >> help the Democrats but
to like support things like ballot initiatives related to abortion
or legalization of marijuana. I don't know whatever the >> Yeah.
Democratic policies. Democratic policies that >> that's
why that's why most packs are like I think packs are like you
think about packs in the states I think of like uh anti-abortion
packs, right? Like pro-life packs. Those packs operate totally
normally and they might as well be Republican but like at least
they are believably one issue like they are single issue right
uh this does not seem to be this was not driven by a a single
issue that drives you to vote for one party it is driven by the
party abortion is 501c4 this is literally what we're talking
about we're talking about chorus you you aren't following I have
to I have to
social welfare is 501c4 I have
>> what happens when I block somebody. If I block them,
that just makes their chats disappear. Okay, they don't show
up in the chat anymore. Perfect. We're good. >> Well, yeah,
they are policies that they support, but they're not necessarily
helping the Democrats, right? Like there's no formal connection
to the DNC or anything, right? >> I don't think that Republicans
are getting into the these programs. I don't think that, you
know, I mean, yeah, you're right. I guess I guess the 1630 fund
has funded, you know, they funded RFK. I believe they had some
sort of weird funding thing with RFK. So, I guess, yeah, maybe.
it. Um, but what I would say is I don't think it's a secret that
chorus is meant the whole nature of chorus is to help Democrats
um, you know, fix and get back in power. Yeah. I I don't know.
I mean, I my issue with chorus and the center of my of my article
is disclosure and it doesn't sound like we disagree on that.
And I think that you can literally gate a lot and you can say
all this stuff about >> Sure. I just I don't understand
the difference what the difference between like Chorus and the
Omdia network is. It feels like the same like the reporters and
residence program is a is a program that's funded via the the
C4 that the OMR network runs in the same way. >> Is there
like a can somebody tell me maybe Destiny's just looked at this
way deeper somehow and there's somehow like a folded in
uh 501c4 that I am unaware of. Is that possible? Cuz like I don't
know. It's actually like concerning to me that he keeps getting
this wrong. He seems to like by the merits by the mer just totally
like be this up. >> Do you think it's an accident? He just
that's what he did with the topic ear.
>> Okay.
Post the contact but like why won't you just post the contract?
You think he just misremembered
>> I think I think this has to be an >> Okay. Then
he'll retract.
>> Oh, okay. Hold on. Funded by watches
>> No, I I think you're confused. So again, my investigative
journalism fellowship is not a political program. >> Uh
I'm guessing he'll have somebody okay who's actually like one
of the people here. I know Pisco can't write his can't do his
homework for him anymore, but uh one of the people who actually
cares will be here in the chat and they'll be reminding him in
just a second. >> Doesn't matter if it's a political program
is funded by a dark money >> No, it's not. It's No, because
the No, it's it's just not it's just not true that the that the
reporters and residence program is funded by dark money. It's
funded by Pierre Omidar. It's not your paychecks are not so your
1099. I have actually not even received you know what Stephen
I have not received you're saying this but you're not you're
not getting paid by him personally right if I pay an employee
something through my company that's not me personally giving
them money there's a level of transparency that I know where
the money came from and that is >> but that's not publicly
disclosed to any of us which is the transparency that you're
asking for right >> they publicly disclose it in this in
this um they they publicly disclose it right here >> if
this counts as public disclosure with no tax forms published
then Brian Tyler Cohen counts as public disclosure when he refuts
parts of the contract right why would he be demand >> what
If if the billionaire who runs that foundation saying they pay
for it is public disclosure. Then when Brian Tyler Cohen says
you're wrong about something, that's public disclosure, too.
Yeah, it's a public statement, Stephen. But why would that make
him correct? Yes, he is making a public statement about it. That
doesn't make it what
I
can we just I have to run that back. If this public disclosure
by Pier Midor or the Amidor network is a public disclosure then
apparently yeah the her face is actually perfect here like I
he just said something fairly incomprehensible then Brian Tyler
Cohen's disc like public statement about how you guys were wrong
how the article was wrong then that's also a public disclosure
I
>> in this in this um they they publicly disclose it right
here >> if this counts as public disclosure with no tax
forms published, then Brian Tyler Cohen counts as public disclosure
when he refuts parts of the contract, right? Why would he be
demanded to publish the contract, but Omidio Network can just
be taken at face value for network? >> Oh, wait. It's maybe
not quite as bad. No, but I mean that's not Hold on. We don't
have a credible source on the other side of this from uh we don't
have anybody who's going like, "Oh, I've proven that Omidar Network's
lying." Right? Or like PRID seems to be pretty committed to transparency.
We don't have like a committed that the problem is we have a
journalistic institution claiming otherwise. Now if a journalistic
institution claimed the opposite that Omid our network was actually
funded significantly by dark money through their LLC and they
were like laundering something then I think it would be incumbent
on them to provide like significant receipts right isn't that
how we would be looking at that one would assume it's like not
quite the same thing. You don't have a you don't have a reputable
source on the other side of this doing like saying that they're
lying >> is a political group. I don't know what you're
talking about. >> It functions as a super PAC. It functions
as a >> It's not a super PAC either, Stephen. I think you're
very confused. So part of and I and I encourage you to read Anna's
work and maybe you could have Anna on your stream actually to
talk about this because Anna covers dark money and she can go
into all of this detail where she can explain to you the nuances
that might really help you understand. Part of part of what makes
a a money or group a dark money group is the political nature
of the group. So it's not just any like you know group and this
is why people were thinking like oh the NAACP is a is a dark
money or like that's something people on threads were saying
you have to you have to be doing sort of specific political activities
as as far as she again she worked at open secrets which I would
say is sort of like the >> This is why the whole conversation
around dark money almost like every single time surrounds is
surrounded by Citizens United, right? That's the that's the backing
thing for all of >> What's up? >> I actually think
she just lost here. Oh, she lost me. Did she just source threads?
Like anybody is on threads? That's like >> she's literally
she's literally sourcing a dark a dark social media site. Okay.
Nobody can actually confirm that this sites site exists. Nobody
can confirm any of the posts on it. >> Are you on Instagram?
If you don't download threads, you can't even see what people
post on there. It's like it's behind like a download wall. Okay.
If you say something is happening on threads, I'm never going
to know the truth cuz I'm never downloading that [__]
Oh, Omidia also lists every journalist in their program too.
Yeah, sure. There there's like so many differences, right? There's
just so many differences, but it's >> description of it.
Um,
there is that political nature to it. So, I think that I I I
don't know, you know, I can't answer these specific like tax
questions of of you know that you're having about certain forms
and things, but I know that Anna is somebody who I trust who
is the top one of the top reporters in the country on dark money.
She does explain the difference between the stuff in the video
on my channel. I personally did not work at Open Secrets for
seven years, so I'm sorry that I can't like litigate all those
little things, but I do feel confident in saying that I know
where every dollar that I receive came from and who's paying
the bills. >> Sure. So, I'm just curious. So, for the Media
Art Network, cuz I read their site, they operate a dual 501c3
and an LLC structure. Do you know every
Ruben donated $3?
not memeing. But why do they call it dark money? >> Because
uh the contributions are unlimited. And so you usually have a
personal contribution limit for for super PACs. These this 501c4
or 501c4 hybrid structure, you can donate infinite amounts essentially.
There's no I believe there's no spending cap and you don't even
have to disclose that you're the person donating it. You can
have your name offiscated. You can have your identity offiscated.
You can donate however much you want. No spending cap. Yeah.
Boom. See? Oh, sorry. Reuben. And Ruben wasn't asking seriously.
People seem to think that was a joke. We're >> Yes. I asked
I asked about this when I when I uh accepted this fellowship
and I >> like they g you like a profit and loss. They've
given you some kind of tax filing a 1040 1120s. I don't know
what enough information that I that I completely trust them.
Yeah. >> But then you're taking it on word from a billionaire,
right? >> No, I'm not taking it on word.
Taylor just needs to fall back to at worst here I would be about
as culpable as the people would be at chorus if they actually
disclosed because Omidar discloses to everybody in their program.
So like at worst I am already meeting like my own bar. The bar
I'm asking for out of chorus I'm already meeting that bar. Uh
luckily for me I actually don't think dark money is illegal.
Uh I don't think dark money is evil. So I don't have to go after
this at all. >> From a billionaire. I'm taking it I'm taking
it from I mean they provided me evidence showing that and I believe
them and you're right to the outside world it's a dark money
it's a dark money fund right because we don't know what goes
into the LLC. No wait how is it not dark money? Can they not
accept an infinite amount of money from people that don't have
to disclose? >> This is not a dark an LLC that pays investigative
journalists is not dark money. Again you're missing the key part
of dark money which is that it is political in nature. The goal
>> investigative journalism can't be political in nature.
So the go the program that I'm in is not a political program
and it is not for political purposes and there is and it is completely
nonpartisan. I'm not a Democrat. And in fact I would say what
I would say to you Stephen is if Omidiar is so involved in dark
money and 1630 fund or whatever me reporting critically on one
of his investments shows that I am editorially independent from
whoever >> what you're saying is the same argument a lot
of content creators and chorus use when they said they've said
negative things about the Democratic party. David Pacman just
said that or they've said negative things about the >> I
think that is I think that they're right. Oh, the Israel stuff
we should talk about too. I think that that does I I agree with
them. I think that that is evidence of their editorial independence
and I have said from the jump and if you read our story again
our story doesn't say that they were given talking points especially
about Israel and all of that stuff. So I do think >> they
didn't say that if they didn't carry the content interrupting
me because you keep pivoting. You I think you said it sounded
like they had a lot of questions. >> They had a lot of
content. >> This is very unproductive. Ultimately, I I
don't know what to tell you other than I am not involved in a
political program. I am doing an investigative journalism ship.
>> The smuggness is very funny to me. Okay. >> Fellowship
that is not that the goal of that program is not political. >> I'll
just say she
she's being smug and it's just very funny to me that she's like
um not getting face like >> this is smug.
>> It it comes off as smug to me, but I think it's like
uh very funny. >> This is um
Okay. I It's coming off smug to you. I think you're repulsed
by this because this feels like one HP voice. >> No, I'm
not. I'm not repulsed by it. I think it's hilarious. >> No,
you're being you're being you're being mean. >> No, I think
I think it's awesome. I think it's like awesome.
>> Oh, okay. Okay. >> Just to be clear. Yeah. Yeah,
she's being mean. And it's like it's funny because Yeah, it's
awesome. >> No, I don't think she's being mean. She's got
the She's got the voice like she's the victim, right? No, I think
she's got the voice like she's dealing with a petulant child
because she's dealing with a petulant child. I think she's like
it's like condescending. It's like she's like the babysitter
who's like just like >> stop. Like uh I ultimately this
is like boring. Ultimately this is >> Yeah, I get it. You
just threw all this on the floor. I'll clean it up. Whatever.
Ultimately this is >> No, I do hear it sides. But to me,
this feels like it's two siblings and she's the one who's like
pulling her sister's pigtails and she's like, "You hit me back."
That's like, you know, it's it's deceiving, right? Her tone sounds
like she's the person who's not doing anything wrong, but she
is mopping the floor with his hair. >> I like that. I like
it. >> And I do think that should investigative journalists
also, you know, have more transparency around their programs.
Sure. But political content creators taking political money,
in my opinion, should disclose and should ask a lot of questions
because
>> and she should point out that even if she were to meet
that bar, she discloses like it's disclosed. >> There's
a lot of money aimed at influencing politics. Unfortunately,
there's not as much money paying investigative journalists. They're
just nobody's doing that. It's a charity basically. Whereas there's
a lot of money in the political system to influence specific
political outcomes. That that's that's a key difference. >> My
understanding when you read about corors is that but one of the
earlier lines was that they had restrictions on the political
content that the content creators could make. That's by the way
I think you could make this argument argument with the network,
right? I could go look at all their journalists and if their
journalists all have like the same bend in some way, right? You
could argue they're funding journalism along a certain angle.
They're like going to say, "Okay, I want independent journalists.
Let's say they all let's say every one of those people like actually
work against the interest of the Democratic party in some way.
They got like Glenn Greenwald, they got Kenis Owens, they got
Taylor Loren, they've got like a bunch of people who are journalists
or pseudojournalists, right? And they all work against a certain
interest. You could easily make this argument for the Amidar
Network in their program as well. You could, but you'd actually
have to do work and construct that argument. Yeah. I just I don't
know. That's like a part of the contract. So, one thing that
the story says is that there were restrictions on the content,
but we're not talking about specific like, you know, I don't
know what it says in terms of like Chorus's policy agenda or
whatever, but that we you can read. >> No way. That can't
be on this. That can't be on the site. Hold on. We are Chorus.
We are Chorus.
Hold on. We are Chorus. We are Chorus.
Frequently asked questions.
Uh, who funds Chorus?
Uh, Chorus is a 501c4 nonprofit organization with grass grassroots
support from over 5,000 individuals since launching in December
2024. We're grateful to those who understand the importance of
investing in the independent media ecosystem to make sure content
creators have access to training and tools that help them grow.
>> What does grassroots even mean here? >> Now I'm
starting to understand why they had all those donation things,
right? Everybody does this. These organizations are so slimy.
They go, they go, they say, "Hey guys, help us raise money, right?
Help, help us raise money. Tell your tell your fans to donate
to us, right?" And then they go, "We're grassroots. We've had
5,000 small money donators."
And one of those donators is 16:30 doing like a 99.9999999%
of your funding. Is 16:30 grassroots? It is not. It is the opposite
of grassroots. That's just very funny.
Like some of this can be answered by, okay, we're we're like
small and we're just starting up and we don't have time to update
the site all the time. So I I don't even have to hold this against
them, but it it sure looks bad. Name of the game, my friend.
Internet Ray is just ready to excuse it, even if it's a lie.
I like that you're unabashed. >> Name of the game. >> I
I love that you're unabashed, Internet Ray. I'm literally sitting
here trying to figure out why they wouldn't be trying to lie
here trying to be like give them a little charity say they listen
this was true and they only just got the money from 1630 or something.
>> no, the same people who say name of the game are the
same ones that complain like oh man this girl had so many filters
I didn't know what I was signing up for. That's false advertising.
Okay. >> Name of the game brother. Name of the game brother.
>> Language in the article says among other issues it mandated
extensive secrecy about disclosing their payments and had restrictions
on what sort of political do I have? I don't have both of these
open, do I? No. This equipment thing. Hold on. Hold on. The reason
>> because Okay. Does he understand yours? Okay. Jesus
Christ. Why voice? Yours is an instant. >> No. Do the other
one. >> Wait. Oh,
>> do I have that? Wait. Do I have that saved? I do have
that saved. Hold on. I do have it saved. You need to see both
back to back. >> You can damn it to me. >> Yours.
Okay. Jesus Christ. >> It's good times. It's good times.
Yeah. I'll damn it. I'll damn it. See, I every time I have these
two YouTube windows open, I click over to this and remember what
it is and have to play it again. >> you are like actually
a psychopath. >> You have like three different laptops.
All of these laptops have like 50 tabs left open
>> that's psychotic.
>> There's a streamable.
Yeah. Well, it is what it is. >> Produce. So, that was
like in the contract it said you are not allowed to produce this
type of like conservative content or pro um >> I didn't
see them use No. Well, one thing that I think if we could move
on to that I think would be more productive
um is to discuss this Israel question because that is something
that a lot of people have had. >> I think listen Stephen
we've talked about dark money. Let's talk about the real problem
here and the Israel question. Would you guys like to have a little
question or sorry have a little talk about the Israel question?
>> Had questions about and I've seen a lot of speculation
about online where people have said oh they're paid not to talk
about Israel. Nowhere in our article does it does it make that
claim. Nowhere. And that is something that I think people brought
up. It is something that I looked into. Um there are content
creators in this program that have spoken about Palestine and
I think that uh you know a lot of people have sort of taken the
article which is paywalled and this is another problem with journalism
that it's paywalled. So I don't think a lot of people read the
full article. But I just do want to make it clear that I think
some of what these content creators like David Pacman have refuted
are actually not claims ever made in our >> Well, but everybody
else is making Is it bother you if every other like leftist creator
is making these claims that that's what the article says? Like
why is there so much ubiquitous I guess like confusion on that
side? Like be >> I know the answer to this cuz I called
it out, right? Uh there are a lot of lefties who are going to
make every single
instance of every single problem ever about Israel and it's weird,
right? I we all understand. We all understand. We all see it,
right? But uh we're going to pretend we don't understand. We're
going to blame. We're going to pretend it's Taylor's fault. Although
Taylor, I think engaged a little bit with >> Glen. Yeah.
It's not One Direction. And I think people unfortunately once
you publish something people take a lot of you know people take
your stuff and make claims and it's I try to debunk it as best
I can. Um but you know I all I can do is continue to point to
the article and kind of share the information that I have. But
I think that I think that part of what's driving all of that
I mean aside from the fact that Gaza is is such a dividing issue
among so many people online um in the in the sort of the left
sphere is that we don't know the full makeup of the chorus program.
So we still don't have a roster. This is another argument for
transparency. OMID are not like my OMID are reporters and residence
program like we know everyone that's in it, right? Um we don't
know with the with the chorus cohort they told they told >> to
be clear we don't know we don't know everybody that's in it.
We know the PR statement that they've put out but we don't have
like tax filings or anything. We don't see all of their payroll.
We don't see all of the dispersements of >> Is anybody
saying that there's more? Cuz from what I understand, there's
somebody making a claim that there's like 85, 86, 90 people in
this cohort and like four of them are listed, right? >> The
company's man, right? >> On chorus. What are you talking
about? >> No. On the network, right, on the LLC they pay.
They announce that these are just statements, right? We don't
have any tax f.
>> Stephen, it would be a great news story if they announced
that. Why would they? Okay, first of all, they g they announced
the public roster saying, "Hey guys, here's who are the newest
members of our reporting fellowship." >> So, all we would
need to see here, right? All we would need to see here is somebody
could come along. If Omidar Network did this, how would they
not just be opening them up to getting to opening themselves
up to getting totally over by some reporter who's getting paid
by them and wants it off the books the same way the whistleblowers
from PV, sorry, from uh Chorus went and talked to Taylor Loren.
If we thought about if if we flipped this and we made it about
vaccines, Destiny would understand entirely that conspiracies
about vaccines don't stand up because obviously somebody would
be talking somewhere. You'd have some whistleblower somewhere.
But he cannot apply the same level of critical thinking to Taylor
Loren or anything to do with Hassan that he would to any other
issue. Right. So >> back everything I said before
>> about what >> um this is aggressive as from Taylor
Loren's
and I agree with you. He can't he can't look at this objectively.
The way that she keeps laughing in his face.
Stephen like
no. Just no. I disagree with this private huff that he could
just call the tax filings fake. I don't think he'd do that. I
don't think so. Right. But
I just think that like you're you're opening it like they they
announce and they like take pride in their transparency. You're
arguing that well we don't know that. They could just be lying.
No, they literally take pride in their transparency. Obviously,
if they're paying other reporters off the books, which is kind
of goofy. They're literally doing this for like the social validation
they get from funding independent journalism. But even if they
were doing that off the books, they'd open themselves up to being
blackmailed or by or like just a massive negative PR hit, right?
Like there's just no reason to believe they're doing that on
the side and lying about it publicly. The the whole point of
the of the disclosure is they're saying we are doing this virtuous
thing. If somebody they're paying is aware of the unverirtuous
thing for long, I would assume somebody's going to cut against
that in some way. If you think that there are secret journalists
that are also part of the reporting fellowship that they didn't
announce, I really encourage anyone to find that story. That
would be a crazy story. I've been on the Zoom calls. I've never
seen anybody that that was not announced as part of the program
on our our meet Zoom meetups. That would be very silly. And there
is no reason to hide who's in an investigative journalism fellowship.
With the chorus program, we >> Oh, well, she basically
just said all all of the things. We'll see if he refuts any of
that. who some creators are in the program, but we don't know
the full 90. And so what you're seeing a lot of creators on the
left say is, "Hey, we don't know who's in this program. We just
know out of this cohort, xyz amount of creators haven't spoken
sufficiently about Gaza, about XYZ." And so they're they're sort
of extrapolating a lot. What I would say to them is, "Hey guys,
before you make a lot of those claims, let's let's encourage
Chorus to publish the full roster. Let's encourage more creators
to come forward themselves and talk about it if they're able
to so that we have a better picture of the ideological makeup
because I just don't think we have enough information to know
the true ideological makeup of this cohort without knowing people
who are in it. I was able to confirm a couple dozen creators
but 90 creators we we just don't know. You know, we could have
a >> but like what is that what does that even mean? the
ideological makeup is this off of a singular issue off of Israel
Palestine and then now if all of these people harassed who have
been like named in the story then doesn't that just mean so then
we're not actually looking for transparency at all we're just
looking to make sure that they're you know in alignment on this
particular
>> some people the people who care about that issue so
for instance with Gaza right Stephen you would agree a lot of
people online care about this issue >> yeah I think Glen
Greenwald about it even I think yeah we need >> I know
who hates me and finally had me on his show after on me for years
and years. Um,
you know, for people who care a lot about Gaza and they want
to they really want to know who in this program. >> Dude,
she actually just keeps winning though. They've tried to tire
of Glenn Greenwald as well. Like as oh, she's hanging out with
Glenn Greenwald cuz they all hate democracy. They all hate Democrats.
And she's like, "Yeah, Glenn Greenwald having me on a show after
he had to have me on a show and he sh on me for years and he
had to admit that I had done journalism that interests him."
Glen Greenwald. It's very funny. is pro Palestine. Who in this
program has said what they they want that level of transparency.
Right now we just don't have that level of transparency. And
so I think one thing that would be helpful for this program and
any programs in the future is to have more transparency. So people
can look and say, "Hey, 50% of creators in this program haven't
spoken up about abortion, haven't spoken up about Gaza, have
have said this but haven't said this. Maybe support
rolling back section 230, whereas 50% uh support fighting section
230. I don't I'm just think these are tech policy things that
I care about. But like I I think that the more transparency the
better and the less the less there are going to be this sort
of like speculation because >> is the is the issue is the
scary thing that people are being funded through nearious
uh means or that they just don't align politically enough with
the people that want to witch hunt them because that this just
sounds like now we just want to see the full list of people to
make sure that they are aligned on like the monocult
um hold on nefarious. Nefarious. Yeah, he meant nefarious. But
what what she's trying to say is
>> um people are talking about Gaza. We don't really know
the full list, the full makeup. And because they don't release
that, people will run with rumors. If their whole list, if you
did more disclosures, people couldn't run with the rumors. They
just have to look at the ratio of like the people and then they
could just actually make a uh like a calculated like actual factual
statement, right? That's what she's saying. She's not saying
we you need to release these so like we can hold these people
to account. She's just saying like if you disclosed it then you
just know the opinions of all of them. You could just say if
they were actually paying, you know, if they were like 20 8020
9010 50/50 on the Palestine issue, right? You could easily figure
this out over time. >> Talking about I I don't I I I think
that personally I don't really care where these people want to
stand on whatever issue that they want to stand on. >> Yeah,
but you're publishing these articles that are being used by other
people as basically
other people, right? people those those people well they can
take my article and use it however they want those people that
are very focused on sole issues right they are going to take
a they're going to take any announcement of any program I've
reported on other programs by the way that they've done the same
thing to right where they're like well where did where where
is this program on xyz issue and a lot of people care about I
mean we saw this in the leadup to u Harris's election we saw
a lot about Gaza but we also saw this exact same thing happen
on other issues like I mean look at Gen Z for change remember
that back in 2020 or sorry Tik Tok for Biden there were so many
conversations around like well who you know who out of this cohort
is for what like that's just something that people want to know
and so I am saying in the interest of transparency it would behoove
any of these organizations to be clear about their roster because
clearly there are activists online who care about specific issues
who want to know where these different cohorts stand or who maybe
want to reach out across the aisle and say look I've noticed
that 70% of your creators haven't spoken about reproductive of
justice. So, I'd like to reach out and educate you guys on this
issue. Just more transparency is better across the board for
no matter what. It just it it alleviates all of this sort of
speculation and it just provides more opportunities, I think,
for for everyone to sort of build that trust with their >> Sure.
I mean, as you've gone around like making the rounds on some
of these shows, by the way, see a lot of people talk about uh
her pivoting. She's not pivoting at all, right? I haven't seen
her pivot one like iota anywhere here. She's just saying the
same thing over and over again on like all of these >> on
a lot of these lifted shows. Have you corrected anybody who is
running with >> I have tried to correct people.
>> She literally just came on your show and said, "I'm
correcting these people right now." She literally just came on
your show and said, "I want to talk about this Israel thing cuz
like I think there are people running with that. I think those
people are wrong. I think they're way jumping the shark on that."
She just came on to say that >> people and I actually asked
somebody to uh yeah to change a title on something and I I just
I'm going I'm doing a TV hit tomorrow uh like a television hit
and they wanted and they they literally reached out to me um
about yeah with with like misleading framing and I was like hey
before I hop on I just want to make sure that you've read what
the actual article says and I even just sent an email to another
podcast last night trying to debunk like I don't think they had
even read the article and they were going to cover it. So sure,
but with particularly with because for I'm pretty sure you told
Glenn Greenwald that you'd felt that the Democratic establishment
had chosen neoliberal content creators based on their position
on whether or not it was a genocide in the Gaza Strip. Like it
was one of the things I think you said to Glenn Greenwald. So
it seems like that's feeding like really I can't remember exactly
what she said. She kind of leaned into something along these
lines. I remember being annoyed when I watched Glenn. I can't
remember precisely what it was. Maybe you should grab it real
quick. I I'll maybe take a look inside monitor. >> I I'm
going to dip for a bit. I'm going to go run. >> Okay. Bye.
>> All right. Talk to you later. Bye.
>> No. No. I think that the I think that traditionally
during the campaign
maybe is that what you're thinking I was talking about during
the >> but it's in an interview while you're talking about
your article and this is the assumption that every other person
who's read your um pieces is running with it very
I think we're very explicitly talking about during the during
the DNC
but yeah I've I've tried to correct it I've even I mean I'm in
the Tik Tok comments if you >> hold on Glenn Greenwald
oh hold on Taylor Loren's
Glenn Greenwald okay here's this YouTube search give me a second.
Dark Money Group. Let's go take a look for Gaza in the transcript.
Let's see exactly what she said cuz I would just rather see what
she said. Who I think either stayed home or in some cases even
voted for Trump because of their anger over the Biden Harris
support for the genocide in Gaza by arming and funding Israel.
So
>> what is the nature of these contracts in terms of the
constraints that it imposes on the con the the influencers who
they're paying? Yeah, there are some significant constraints
and certainly there are restrictions in these contracts that
I myself as a journalist would never feel comfortable agreeing
to. Um, you know, there are parts of the contract that talk about
that you cannot speak. You cannot ever disclose the name of the
of the funer who's funding you. You can't disclose that you're
part of this program. Um, you know, you >> wait what did
I get upset about? Hold on. Israel
>> support the genocide in Gaza by arming and funding Israel.
So, people were angry about that. Here we go. Here we >> These
sort of creators that they want to don't have any organic traction.
Most of them are just these sort of centrist
uh neoliberal this more top down to gatekeep of malign the influencer
industry for years but now they're sort of seeking to gateep
it in various ways and um and sort of like you know have this
more top- down control over it not some sort of organic thing.
And I think it's very notable, too, that the content creators
that they want to fund don't have any organic traction. Most
of them are just these sort of centrist
uh neoliberal, you know, people that frankly will never call,
you know, a genocide a genocide. They'll never speak out against
Israel. They'll never speak out against um, you know, all of
the censorship stuff. They're not rocking the boat. Basically,
they're happy to tow the Democratic party line. And I think that's
a problem because those are not the people that have cultural
currency online. If the
>> Yeah. So this is a very very common
like lefty talking point that's pretty and doesn't apply here
and I do think it cuts against like how the article is being
rece or how the article was written. Right. So I I I heard this
and that this immediately in the Glen Greenwald interview to
me I was like okay that's bull like don't do that. You're actually
undercutting yourself. She says most which is somewhat accurate.
Ah it's it's that she did this. Um she shouldn't have. It cuts
it undercuts like some of her messaging, right? But it seems
like she's now cleaning it up at least at least she's sort of
distancing from that talking point. She's maybe maybe she's realizing
a little more cuz this is what 4 days ago, 5 days ago. This is
5 days ago now. So maybe she's starting to realize that this
was being used against her and that's not the best.
She might be speaking broadly. Maybe >> Democrats want
to win. They need to start working with people that frankly don't
agree. like they honestly they just need to change their policies
and so many things but um but yeah it's >> she might be
speaking so she might be speaking philosophically and it's funny
cuz uh I just heard I just heard Mr. Bad and Panata saying basically
this exact thing a couple days ago not saying she got it from
the same place. I think is broadly a widely held lefty belief
that you know populism is going to overlap with being pro Palestinian
a lot like engaging policy can't you can't you know run cover
for a genocide happening and have people really take you seriously
or be energized by what you're saying. I think that's like maybe
there's probably some truth to that. Okay. This could be her
speaking generally but the unfortunate thing is
uh I feel like the same way I think she has to be more clear.
She has to split these things up. She needs to do a better job
of compartmentalizing them because it does seem like she could
be speaking. Right. If we were to just clip this, it seems like
she could be thinking about that.
I
man I start the clip earlier.
Okay, hold on. >> Exactly know 100% where it's coming from,
who you know who the funer is. Um, and that's not right. But
usually the way it works and what I've seen from my reporting
is that these Republican groups will sort of notice someone online.
They might not even have their reaction with that person online.
They'll just sort of start pumping. They'll start boosting them
in the feed. they'll start doing paid media for them like just
sort of organically like testing things and boosting things and
trying a lot. The Democrats are obsessed with control. We know
that they love this like top down sort of structure of media
because they're such institutionalists. And so with the influencer
industry, not only did they sort of malign the influencer industry
for years, but now they're sort of seeking to gateep it in various
ways. >> Okay, this is more of a generalized point and
she's talking about the Democrats doing this, right? And I don't
necessarily disagree with this. Um I don't necessarily disagree
with this. The issue is she came on to discuss her article and
these things can be conflated. I think she's I think she's speaking
recklessly here for her own thing. Okay.
I do think that the Hold on a second. Thought you were I thought
you were trying to come in. It's fine. I'm back. I'm back. Yeah.
I think I think she could have just done a better job differentiating.
I think uh cuz I when I first watched this maybe I wasn't paying
like total attention and that sort of escaped me in the moment.
So I I do think she's speaking generally. I think she should
be very clear this is not a better article. Now she is being
very clear. So it's hard for me to hold against her when she
comes into this interview today. And she actually goes out of
her way to make it clear, right? It's slimy of Stevie to snipe
this. Maybe scamrex maybe. But what I would want to do is I'd
want to go check out her interview with the Vanguard and see
how clear she is there. Okay? Because it's a lot easier to be
very, you know, uh it's it's easy to be sloppy on that kind of
thing when people will just agree with you, right? People want
to hear that. It's it's a lot and it's easy to be very very clear
about what you mean when you're interviewing with somebody who's
going to disagree with you a lot, right? But if if you're going
to start mixing these things together and make it seem like,
oh well, maybe Chorus is doing that when you're interviewing
with like a far-lefty
outlet or a far-lefty channel, I would not like that. Okay? I
would not like to see that. I would not appreciate that at >> You
see me in the Tik Tok comments. I'm saying, "Hey guys, just wanted
to fact check this." And I just shared a video on Instagram.
I literally just reposted a guy like I think I reposted or I
commented I can't remember but um you know saying hey guys here's
what's true here's what's not true and I and I I when I have
time I will make a >> I think he's intentionally undermining
or clarification I will say that the Glenn Greenwald thing I
saw that as her sort of maligning these people and now that I
take another look at it and I see her being clear here combined
with you know one or two other clarifications on social media
about what she does mean and doesn't mean or what the article
is saying not saying what she believes personally I would take
that in good faith, but >> more thorough video. You know,
sometimes I try to do like a Tik Tok where I'm like, "Hey guys,
here's the 10 craziest claims about my article. Like, let me
>> share kind of like debunk some of that." >> So,
you would say that like as it stands right now based on what
you've seen from Chorus, there's no evidence that they were guiding
or telling content creators that were part of Chorus what type
of content they could make or what political positions they had
to have. >> So, they didn't give people explicit talking
points. They didn't um they have these daily messaging check-ins
and obviously they are sort of letting creators into a cohort
based on their own guidelines. We don't know their guidelines
like we don't know what what criteria they were using to select
the creators in their program. Again, more transparency would
be great. Um, but as far as I've seen and and you can see this
even in the article itself, Stephen, is that um, we we don't
make the claim that they were like given talking points or, you
know, again, and we had creators reach out to us saying like,
I was actually concerned about the Gaza stuff cuz like maybe
it would, you know, whatever. But we we I looked into it and
I did not find any evidence that they were um, you know, preventing
people from saying the word Israel or Apac or something that
some people were claiming. So it and it does it it does a lot
of disservice to the journalism I think when you have these content
creators come like David Pacman come on and refle refute claims
that were never made in the article without making it >> [__]
also repeated that like these people were basically blocked from
talking about Israel Palestine or um I think Emma Vigilant I
think also was saying as much that like oh they're only allowing
people to say good things about Israel. This is why I think a
lot of those content creators maybe weren't responding to your
article but how all the leftists had ran with the article. But
I think it's important to respond to I think it's important when
you're debunking an
>> sorry you can't say oh I'm responding to son [__]
also that article is totally debunked that's was bull right you
can't respond to son per debunk what he says and say the article
is totally debunked that's obviously article especially if you
care about building trust in journalism instead of dismantling
trust in journalism I think it's helpful to say hey these claims
have not been made in the article which actually bol bolsters
their point but of course they spent so much time trying to discredit
the article. But I think it would be helpful for them to say,
"Hey, this wasn't made in this claim wasn't made in the article,
but let me debunk it." Um, because again, there's I mean, this
is a very hot button issue and I think it's worth I know current
affairs had a piece on this in a while. I the Democratic Party
does not have a great track record in this area, which I think
is also what has like I'm talking specifically about the campaign
trail and kind of what they did at the DNC. Um, I think that
that has made a lot of people sort of question all of this stuff.
But I think the better that you know what they should do is counter
that with more transparency. And another thing I could just debunk
really quickly since you're giving me the opportunity is that
we did not mention the DNC in the article aside from just mentioning
that this girl has a pro DNC meme page. But um people a lot of
people I think are conflating this liberal dark money group with
the DNC and I saw Shelby, poor Shelby at the DNC sort of trying
to fact check that and I I think I get that because >> has
Stephen want a single point or is he getting shut out? Um,
huh. I I think some of the stuff around the funding, you probably
look good. If I'm trying to think of how this looks to like there
there's no such thing as like a non-biased viewer of this anymore.
So, I I like sometimes trying to think of how a non-biased viewer
would see this, but I I don't think those exist. I'm trying to
think of like how Steven would see it or how No, no, no. I like
I think so. Here's what I will say. Okay.
Steven argued
he did he did his whole obsidian thing. He said there were eight
false claims in the article. He has not made a single one of
these false claims stick to her. Zero. So he has he did a whole
day of research on this. He read the article. He was doing research
on it. He's got his YouTube VOD linked here. Okay. And he has
made zero of these falsehoods.
She has not agreed. They've not found he's not even found a way
to tangibly or effectively disagree or or prove any of these,
which is pretty rough. Okay. Is is pretty tough. Um, some of
them I wonder if he could I wonder if he could disprove or like
some of them I wonder if um if they're like inferences and he
could actually show them, right? So I I haven't seen him effectively
hit any of the points. I don't know why he did a day of research,
wrote a whole page of Obsidian notes and then just failed to
actually prove out any of the things he thought from before
>> Well, it's because you bring up the Democrats a lot,
right? Like when you say when you say Democrats >> specific
organization and I just want to make it clear that we don't mention
that specific organization. The DNC is is is used as slang for
the establishment on in a way that I'm sympathetic to and I totally
have done that myself. But we don't mention the DNC and I've
seen a lot of these creators tweet for instance a meme account
that was tweeting about the Democrats. They quote tweeted it
and said, "Oh, look, you know, you're paid by the DNC this you're
part of the same thing." That account was paid by the DNC actually
totally separately, but not part of of this program. So the DNC
has done tons of creator stuff. They have that new guy. No, extore.
I think you're totally wrong here. I think you're actually totally
wrong. I think she is she's actually somebody gave her this point
that Destiny defends institutions. She's writing something for
a journalistic institution that's a part of condublisher that's
existed since the 1900s. Okay.
Like like 1900.
Okay. Why is Destiny undermining them? And why has nobody contested
the reporting in the article through official channels? That
that is a very valid question. and she's given like reasonable
answers to a lot of it as far as I'm concerned. I plays who maybe
you should talk to who's um you know their new head of influencer
I think his name is Tim or something partnerships but um but
they they were not like we didn't even reach out to the DNC uh
about this story because they're not >> sure so I guess
when we say that like cuz the um I don't know what you call the
second title on the article but you the subhead by line yeah
so an initiative boosting democrats online offers influencers
up to $8,000 a month to push the party line >> and then
all they have to do is keep it secret and agree to restrictions
on their content and then you mentioned later on in the article
about the Democrats and Joe Biden. >> Ask her if she wrote
it. Ask her if she wrote it. I don't think I think she I think
it would be a bad look for her if she says she didn't write it.
But I I would love Destiny to ask her cuz I I get the impression
from most people I've talked to that editors write that the title
of the by line that's the editorial. Like that feels like a pretty
official establishment tier. >> Sure. Oh, they're definitely
they're definitely in with the establishment. >> Well,
not like the White House and Joe Biden. And I mean it feels pretty
easy to rope like the like I I would understand why anybody would
rope the DNC into that, right? If you're talking about literally
the party and pushing the party line and Joe Biden and the White
House, right? >> I I mean we don't mention that. >> Uh
unfortunately for Destiny, the easy counter here is Brian Tyler
Cohen literally has stated the goal of chorus is to be able to
respond quickly and push the party line. It is what he talks
about when he talks about rapid response days, right? We need
to push the party line. Guys, don't you know that it's it feels
really when we wake up and the Republicans seem like they went
to a morning meeting. They're totally locked step on messaging.
Democrats need to be like that, too. That's why I'm starting
course media group, right? What the is that if not the party
line? I don't know. That's just Brian Tyler Cohen's words when
he went to start the group. And I don't even necessarily think
that's bad. I just think it's weird that they're scoffing at
the notion. Anyway,
anyway, uh welcome queen of viewers. Welcome, welcome. We're
checking out this Taylor Lorenzi interview. Uh, we've been doing
that for six hours. We're almost through with it now. Okay, this
is a very long one. We've been here for a long time. It's a great
interview, though. Uh, Taylor Loren somehow
persevering, somehow making it work. I I'll be honest. I I'll
say this again for the queen of viewers now that you're jumping
in. I'll I have to do a quick recap for the queen viewers overall.
Okay. I expected Taylor Loren to be like the goat in Jurassic
Park, okay, that gets lowered into the T-Rex cage. That's what
I expected this to to be when I watched it. Um, it's it's turned
out to just be like a normal fight, but I thought she was going
to get eviscerated to be honest with you. And that has not been
the case. Not even a little bit. She's a very competent journalist.
She's an okay journalist.
And I'll be honest, she's never seemed like a great intellect
to me on Twitter. Okay. Okay. Babka, shut the up. Babka, none
of us thought Taylor Loren was smart before this. Okay. Shut
up. Shut up.
Stop faking it. Stop pretending. Okay, one one final thing for
the queen of viewers. Okay, we've watched this a couple times
today, but we'll have to to redo this one more time. Wait, wait,
wait. Did this get >> Okay, does he understand yours? Okay,
Jesus Christ. My voice. Yours is an instance where you >> And
of course, the accompanying Kathy meme that we got hit with.
Okay, hold on, hold on, hold on. >> Yours. Okay. Jesus
Christ. >> It never fails to hit. It never fails. I think
that's going to be That's like an alltime right there.
Ah, it just hits every time. Thank you guys. Thank you for joining
us. We're going to get back to back into this interview. We're
getting to We just finished the dark money section. What are
we on to now? We finished the dark money section. We are on to
I honestly forgot. Hold on. Let me pull it back 10 seconds. >> Like
I I would understand why anybody would rope the DNC into that.
Oh, yes. The specific allegation that uh Taylor's basically going
through, you know, misinformation points she thinks the article
is being used to push things that people are pushing back against
in the article that don't exist in the article. and she just
said, "We don't we don't reference the DNC in the article at
all." Kind of weird. >> You're talking about literally
the party and pushing the party line and Joe Biden and the White
House, right? >> I I mean, we don't mention that. We mentioned
Joe Biden so they can loop that in and establishment and sure,
but but like I mean, sure, but but I don't think those people
actually read the article, Stephen, based off a lot of what people
have been saying. I I just don't think people made it past the
payw wall. Because if they made it past the payw wall, the people
at least that I've interacted with that are confused about the
article, when I send them the text of the article or I send them
the remove payw wall link, uh, it usually has has cleared things
up. So, >> okay. I feel like if I wrote an article and
this many people had this big of a misunderstanding, I would
be very bothered. But, um, >> well, that's why I'm here
helping you understand it because I think >> Dude,
okay.
She's awesome. >> Very bothered. But um >> well that's
why I'm here helping you understand it because I think that there's
a lot of misconceptions about it and I do want to be accountable
to people. I pride myself on engaging with lots of people even
if they disagree. >> Okay, hold on. That has to be the
clip that O posted, right? I saw somebody posting like an O clip,
bro. That's uh that has to be the one that O posted, right? Let
me see here. This just like it just said mog. Yeah. Yeah, that
has to be it right here. Right. That has to be it. I would reserve
all of my exclusive reporting material for them. That means I'm
not using it for a podcast. That means I'm not >> It's
a different one. Okay, never mind. I thought it was going to
be that funny clip. Maybe not. Maybe not. >> Agree with
me on so many issues. I will always talk to them, hear out their
point, hear their feedback. That's how I become a better journalist.
If I only talk to people that agree with me or never have criticism
of me, I would not become a better journalist. So, I appreciate
your feedback and especially your feedback about, you know, the
ability to post more source material online. That's certainly
something again that I've advocated throughout my career and
will continue to advocate for. Um, but I I like to hear feedback.
I what I don't like is people doing stupid ptoay,
you just have to admit that you're an incel, okay? That this
woman speaking with confidence, okay, bringing like boss energy,
it just with you, okay, she's she's just been right on the points
the whole time. She's just been correct on the points the entire
time and you're just mad that she's like doing this. I think
she's earned the condescension.
Destiny's been talking all kinds of trash about her. He failed
to prove a single thing that he claimed was wrong. At least up
to this point. He's failed entirely
and she's earned the right to just like basically treat him like
a [__] He He is her [__]
He She made him her [__]
>> Tax or saying, "Oh, you're a secret." And trust me,
I have all of the thing. Okay, I have or sorry, I have all of
the all of the thing. I have all of the previously held biases
against Taylor Loren. I think Taylor Loren up to this point in
time, if if you ask me what Taylor Lorenz was like, I go complete
to be honest with you. Complete. I have all of the biases. Yeah.
>> Secret Republican or whatever. Whatever. Like that is
just so stupid and unp >> Oh, another whatever. Whatever.
Absolutely. If you guys don't understand. Okay. Infamous. I don't
know. We We got some Queen viewers in here, so maybe some former
Sugar and Spice fans. Okay, there's somebody who used to say
whatever whatever a lot. Okay, they throw whatever whatever in
in so many places. And I'm curious if if Taylor Loren knows this
and is doing like a calculated attack, okay, and whatever whatever
and you know this, that, and the other, whatever, whatever.
>> Destiny's just having like psychic flashbacks. $95,000
a month. $95,000 a month. $600,000 overall. >> Like not
that doesn't like do anything to to do you know what I mean?
It's just very silly. Not that you did that, but I just in terms
of like why I block people online and stuff like that. It's because
I have to know that you're actually coming in good faith. >> Okay.
All right. Is there any other thing you want to go over related
to this or >> I think that's it. I just I hope that people
can read it and I hope that they can keep an open mind. I think
that a lot of people reflexively
might hate the article, right? Because they want the Democrats
to win and they don't want to support any article that they feel
like is crit is critical, right? They're like, "Why are you bashing?
Why are you doing a hit piece?" What I would say is that I also
want the Democrats to win. Obviously, I don't want Trump in power.
Of course not. He's a fascist. It's terrible. I don't support
the MAGA movement. I'm not a Republican. I I want them to have
a more effective strategy. And I think before you attack me,
look at people like Tina Win or Miaato or some of these other
journalists that have written so smartly. McKenna Kelly also
writes about politics really well and the internet like a lot
of people have made similar points that I've made in this story
about these broader sort of issues with the Democrats and the
Democrats uh all over from the DNC to the lawmakers to these
groups and stuff.
>> Is cob session with zip zip after this is so stupid.
Uhoh. Somebody somebody let Taylor Loren know that she needs
to set the alarm on her Tesla if it's out there. Okay, Tesla,
whatever. Make a model of vehicle she has. Okay,
protect Taylor Lorenz's vehicle. Is Zip Zip Isip helping Destiny
out? Okay, me that vehicle that vehicle is about to have we're
going to need a black light. Okay, we're going to need a black
light. That vehicle is never going to be the same >> about
their sort of media strategy. And I think that we can all agree
that the Democrats do need a better media strategy and a better
set of policies, I would argue, um to reach more people. And
so when you read an article like mine before you get so mad or
before you start fighting, you know, on the internet or whatever,
please understand that like it would be great if I I wish the
Democrats would run a more transparent, more effective program.
I've written those pieces, by the way, announcing more transparent
programs or promoted those pieces when I see them in the news.
And then wow, that's really great. You know, I I have no problem
with an effective influencer program. I have no problem if they
just say, you know what, guys, we're only doing a neoliberal
influencer program. I don't think that's all they should do.
But maybe they want to cater to the those people online for a
while. I don't know. They've been doing that for years. But >> only
one man can prevent Zip Zip from assaulting yet another automobile.
Okay. Only one man can prevent a tragedy.
Nick Fuentes
is
the come detective. Okay. Let's go. Let's go. >> Who cares?
That's their prerogative. I think that the issue is transparency.
And what we should ask for in this space is more transparent.
>> Am I am I missing zip zip lore? Uh Doobie accused him
of trying to come on the door handles of Pixie's car or something
like as a joke. As a joke and then it's just spiral from there.
Okay. >> Across the board because the less transparency
the the more advantage the far right has cuz they don't they
they have more money. If you start to play the dark money game
like >> Oh god, I'm I'm getting sent the zip zip docks.
Oh, in a relationship with his car. My strange addiction TLC.
Oh, Jesus Christ. This is uh this is this is some disturbing
[__] This is some disturbing.
>> Okay.
All right. >> Handsome man.
>> He's got an updated vid. I know. We've watched it before.
It's It's awesome. It's awesome. Awesome video. Blast from the
past. >> Every time. So, we want more transparency in the
space. We want more transparency from our political media so
we know who we can trust and yeah, that's all. That's all. But
you don't have to like, you know, I'm not a secret Republican
or I think that it's not that
>> Sure. I mean, I agree with um >> what do I at
least have a Do I have a transcript here yet? Come on, man. >> No
longer part of the same Come on, dude. Come on, dude. Here we
go. I think I heard controversial there at the end. The word
controversial.
There we go. >> I'm not a secret Republican or I think
that it's not that controversial. >> Sure. I mean, I agree
with um I mean, I I agree with what you're saying. I just I don't
I don't think that that was hardly anywhere in the article. I
feel like the only prescription I saw from the article was the
quote from the one person which basically says >> I didn't
put prescriptions in it. Yeah, you're right. >> There was
a prescription in it which was that the middlemen is bad basically
that um that there shouldn't be that people should just give
money directly to content creators. So like that we're supposed
to fund the entire democratic messaging apparatus with super
chats and and medium or substax subscriptions. I >> I don't
know about that. But I do think less top down control is good.
I mean if you look at turning point as a as as a version of success,
right? They don't have they have of course some organizational
structure but it's pretty open and collaborative. >> Charlie
literally has phone calls with Donald Trump. That is one of the
most top down heavy organized things
in terms of Sure. Sure. Sure. in terms of their messaging. But
I'm saying it's a big sprawling organization. >> Yeah.
They raise a ton of money from people that pay money into them.
They all take direction and organizational.
>> I Why does everybody Why is everybody like we need to
create turning point for the left? Bro, Israel already has a
massive advantage. Do they really need a turning point of the
left? Okay, we need guys, we need to get these young Tik Tockers.
We need to get them flights to Israel. Stat. Okay, that's what
the Democratic party needs. More flights to Israel. Paid vacations
to Israel. Stat. Get these guys on a plane. >> We'll start
from Charlie Kirk who communicates with President Donald Trump.
Yeah, >> sure. Top down in terms of messaging. I guess
maybe top down is the wrong word. Why don't I rephrase it so
that you're not confused? >> To be clear, I'm not confused.
I'm just saying you're advocating for some type of structure
like what Charlie is doing. confusion. There seems to be some
confusion between what I'm trying to communicate and how you're
receiving it. So, let me rephrase it in a way. Go ahead. Make
>> exactly. Let me rephrase it in a way so that my message
is clear. >> It's And that is not an indictment of you.
I am just trying to explain what I'm trying to say. >> You're
very confused, Stephen. You're very confused. Um, I think that
more transparency is is good because the more open these programs
are, the more people will want to get involved, the more grassroots
the movement be becomes and the more the more the less bad faith
attacks can be levied. You know what I mean? And and I think
that that is just something that across the board is helpful.
I understand the purpose of middlemen. I think there's all these
different sort of things that they can
>> Um, the best part Okay, no, hold on. I'm not going to
engage with that. Actually, >> not serve. don't think it's
it helps the Democratic party to >> we're taking this very
seriously. We're just talking about politics, talking about how
this conversation is going, what's true and false in this case,
okay? We're not going to focus on uh >> any party here
and whatever crimes they're accused of, we're not focusing on
that. Middle, but look at Show Speed, who did a great uh live
stream from the capital the other day, got, you know, helped
the Democrats, whatever. Adam Faze coordinated that. That was
great, right? Like things like that are fine. It's great. I >> has
there been another organization like you said chorus had 90 content
creators. Is there any organization of this size that has existed
so far? >> They're the big one. Um there's a few other
I mean I like vocal media has done some stuff. There's a Teddy
Schlifer actually in the New York Times uh wrote a really good
piece which might be good for you to review with your audience
on a lot of these different efforts. There's like I think it's
called Project Bullhorn, there's project zero. They all have
sort of different goals of like some of them are funding creators
directly. Hello, >> Ruben donated $3. Should there be a
touch grassroots movement? >> Entirely possible. Could
be a good thing. Um, >> some are funding like editors.
They all sort of have different structures and things. Um, I
think channel zero is that the one that
the members the things that you just were going to or listed
are all of those people. The >> we can always see where
it's uh inconsistency hunting, right? He's just looking for anything
he can tie to like show an inconsistency. Um, I don't know why
internet debate became this. Like, if I can show any inconsistency,
I could throw at everything else if I could like soy hard enough
about it. He's just like hunting for any little thing that he
can grab like an edge on and soy out about to like try to claim
a W in the conversation
and
>> people with every person that they're paying and where
all of their funding sources are from.
>> Are every one of these organizations public with everything
they do in every possible way? Is that is that what's is that
what you're telling me? So you couldn't have gone after anybody
else. You just had to go after these people because all of them
you're telling me they they like say exactly where they get every
single descent they get. Uh is that what you're telling me? People
be more excited to join these programs but chorus seems like
the largest one of >> Yeah. Well, Chorus is also was the
first out of the gate. So a lot of those other programs haven't
launched yet and they're and they're launching now. And so that's
why we want to get these discussions going and say, "Hey guys,
look, Chorus is first mover in the space. They're definitely
the biggest and the most notable. They got that splashy New York
Times profile like 10 days after the election. But now that we're
all that all the donors are so invested in investing in media,
why don't you listen to, you know, some of these creators themselves
and and and do it in a little bit more of an open and and transparent
way. I don't think it's going to hurt them the way that they
think that it will. I think it'll actually help them. And if
you listen to twe that that great piece on the verge between
Tina and Mia, I think that they make a very compelling argument
for for
>> Okay. I hope that transparency is a thing we can all
push for, especially in the media environment. I think it's one
of the most damaging things right now in the United States is
not having that transparency. So yeah, >> and if people
want to learn more about dark money, go watch the video that
I made with Anna on my YouTube channel. I think she answers a
lot of questions and she also herself is very open to receiving
questions and feedback and if you have further questions, I know
she would love to hear from people. >> Gotcha. Cool. All
right. Well, hey, listen, thanks. I know I'm here to kind of
bully you and shout at you, so I appreciate the conversation
for like an hour and a half. So yeah, thanks a lot. >> Happy
to chat. Always happy to chat about my reporting. Thank you guys
so much for reading and engaging with my work. And if you have
a story that you want me to cover, just >> Dude, I like
honestly I understand that like I I'm perceived as having a bias
against Destiny. I cannot find like a a part of this where he
like won. The only place he was maybe a little close is when
he was being like totally unreasonable with the lines, right?
Like he couldn't be reasonable and have any significant or sufficient
argument. It just seemed like But I'm looking for like for anywhere
he came out on top of this conversation. I don't understand how
how do you get dogwalked like that when you publish a document
saying here are all of the places that I'm going to show you
where Taylor Loren lied in her article, right? Like at some somebody
must have told him after he did the stream that none of these
are actually disproving the things asserted in the article, right?
Jumped ahead because I want to see his reaction. Okay, well we'll
see. We'll see what it is. Okay, we'll stick around for the reaction
a little bit. Maybe maybe some of that Zip Zip stream. >> I
do want to check out Taylor some of Taylor's stuff, guys. Uh,
I I'll take the time here now that she jumped out to show real
quick. Guys, if you like the content, follow on every platform,
okay? Join the Discord. discord.gg/jc.
okay. If you guys want to take your sport one step further than
just following, following Twitter, follow on Twitch, follow